Hallo, Wolfgang.
Hallo, Stefan.
Bist du in Frankfurt angekommen? Hast du auch schon Böller gekauft?
Nein, aber ich war früher in Pyromanien. Na ja, früher als Kind mochte ich das schon sehr, wenn geböllert wurde und kann das auch heute noch nachvollziehen.
Genau. Die Beobachtung oder die Beobachtungskategorie von außen auf einen Krieg, Heldentum ist zu echten. Das ist eine Verlegenheitssache. Das sind, wenn überhaupt dort Opfer, dann kann man sich überlegen, wie kann man selber helfen. Dann ist man aber Helfer, man hilft aber keinen Helden. Also Heldentum einfach aussortieren. Wenn man selber so im Gespräch irgendwie abdriftet in so ein Heldending.
Ja, lieber kann man sich an Haltenwestern angucken oder so. Da gibt es das mitunter noch. Selbst da ist es ja meistens schon gebrochen, aber da kann man sich ja nochmal abholen.
Also wenn es überhaupt Helden nur in Hollywood, nicht in der Ukraine.
Das ist, ich sage ja auch immer im Kino, dann darf auch nochmal mit 500 PS durch die Innenstadt geheizt, aber nicht mehr selbst machen.
Genau, verstellen wir uns nicht den Blick auf die Opfer, indem wir hier irgendwelche Heldendinger proklamieren. Das zieht sich aber durch die Bank. Wir haben eben schon Jagoda Marinic gehört. Sie ist hier auch im Jahresrückblick bei Miki Beisenherz zu Gast, mit Jasmin Embarek und Korbinian Frenzel. Die drei hören wir uns an. Feldenkirchen, da können wir uns ungefähr denken, wie er vielleicht noch mal einen etwas analytischen Blick drauf hat. Aber wir beginnen mal bei Marinic.
Aber klar, Selensky für mich auch. Seitdem er dieses Zitat, I need ammunition or the right gesagt hat, also seit er eigentlich klar gemacht hat, dass er sich obwohl er auch keine Ahnung hat, wie er da jetzt durchkommt und was ihm da geschieht, auf eine Art Verantwortung übernommen hat und dieses Land auf eine Art führt, wo wir alle glaube ich Woche zu Woche dachten, was passiert, wie schnell besiegst du die? Ja klar, ich finde ihn irre. Zumal ich diese Videos gesehen habe von bevor er Präsident war, da hat er die skurrilsten Comedy-Dinger gemacht, inklusive, glaube ich, nackt Piano spielen und so. Also ich glaube, das ist ein Wachstumspotenzial, da würde jeder Amerikaner von träumen und deswegen lieben ihn wahrscheinlich Penlose und alle, weil es ja jemand ist, der American Dream mäßig wächst, wenn er vor der Herausforderung steht, wenn er persönlichen Wachstum zeigt, wenn er Führung zeigt. Das sind schon US-Ideale.
Machen wir jetzt ein Coachingseminar hier oder was ist das?
US-Ideale, der American Dream. Der amerikanische Traum ist, vom Tellerwäscher zum Milliardär, weil man Gelegenheiten nutzt.
Und nicht vom Showmenschen zum Politiker.
Genau.
Das war gerade das Abschreckende, was wir gesehen haben. Da kann man froh sein, dass Selensky kein Trump ist, aber man kann nicht sagen, das wollten die Amerikaner ja eigentlich alle immer haben, dass der Showmensch Präsident wird, dann wird es meistens nicht so gut. Siehe Trump, siehe Ronald Reagan.
Vor allem, man darf niemals ausblenden, also wenn man schon den amerikanischen Traum da so mit reinbringt. Das ist so dieses, die Gelegenheiten nutzen, den ganzen Militärbestand, den man, aus welchen Gründen auch immer, sich ran schafft, einmal abzufeuern, um die Lagerbestände neu zu füllen und Energie, die man produziert, für den sechfachen Preis zu verkaufen. Das ist der amerikanische Traum. Also wenn man vom amerikanischen Traum spricht, vom Ukraine-Krieg, dann da, dass da gerade sehr viele Leute sehr reich werden, dass auch noch ein Medienspiel im Krieg stattfindet, geschenkt. Das müssen wir dann ja gleich einordnen.
Aber ich möchte hier ein Wort mal sagen, denn in Bezug genommen wird auf dieses Time-Magazin, das Selensky erwartbar zum Mann des Jahres gekürt hat. Ich würde jetzt gerne mal allen, die zuhören, die irgendwas mit Medien zu tun haben, sagen, bitte ignoriert diese Person of the Year Wahl des Time-Magazins für alle Zeiten. Und zwar habe ich mal mir angesehen, wer gewinnt diesen Preis sonst? Letztes Jahr wurde Mann des Jahres Elon Musk. Würde man vielleicht heute nicht mehr so ohne Weiteres tun. Gut, ich gebe zu, es waren auch mal andere dabei. 2015 Angela Merkel, 2019 Greta Thunberg. Aber jetzt kommt's. 2016 Mann des Jahres Donald Trump. 2010 Mark Zuckerberg. 2007 Wladimir Putin. Also Time-Magazin einfach ignorieren, diese bekloppte Kür kann man vergessen. Man kann auch Selensky auch nicht dazu gratulieren, dass er da vorkommt.
Ja, es muss ja nicht im Sinne einer Ehrung, Würdigung, sondern im Nachrichtlichen, dass man sagt, die Person, die hier ist so. Kann man sie alle da einsortieren. Solche Ränkespiele sind ja eh geschenkt. Yasmin M. Barek, ich verstehe es nicht ganz, was sie hier sagt. Sie meint, glaube ich, ohne das Medienspiel hätte der Krieg einen anderen Verlauf. Und das ist eine Arbeitsthese, die müssen wir ganz hart überprüfen.
Dass er Person of the Year ist, krönt es nochmal. Sonst zeigt er nochmal, wie gut er daran war, eigentlich PR für sein Land zu machen. Und wie gut er seine Rolle erfüllt hat. Weil die Ukraine bis jetzt thematisch in den großen Medien, in den europäischen Staaten, in den USA nicht weg ist. Und das hätte passieren können. Ich erinnere mich, im Sommer war ja kurz so eine Müdigkeit da. Und dann waren die Deutschen genervt mit ihrem privilegierten Dasein. Und ich dachte so, ok, könnte jetzt so ein Kipppunkt kommen.
Es geht darum, Energie zu verkaufen, Militär einzusetzen, Profitströme, Geldströme umzulenken. Wirklich mit Interessen Weltgeschichte zu schreiben. Würden sich irgendwelche der beteiligten Mächte und Kräfte davon abhalten lassen, es trotzdem zu versuchen, wenn irgend so ein Loser-Präsident gerade wäre in der Ukraine und das Twitter-Game wäre nicht ganz so ausgefeilt, sondern vielleicht sogar gar nicht existent. Wir wüssten gar nicht, wer dort regiert. Oder jemand hätte sich da schon tatsächlich damals einfach evakuieren lassen. Man hätte jetzt so eine Ersatzregierung oder sowas. Das ist doch alles Nonsens. Das ist doch wirklich nur dieses mediale...
Das ist, weil das in Ihrer Timeline dann weniger vorkommen würde, wenn es nicht Selensky wäre. Aber das ist so irrelevant für die Weltgeschichte und für die Weltwirtschaft, dass man es gar nicht mehr kommentieren kann.
Viel schlimmer finde ich noch, dass das Gegen-Szenario denkbar ist, dass nämlich im Pentagon sehr viele Menschen sitzen, deren ganze Berufsbiografie daraus besteht, Russland zu schädigen. Und dass die jetzt natürlich diese Gelegenheit, es auch wirklich zu tun, nutzen und sich dann eher noch darüber freuen, dass sie sehr viel was ansonsten noch als Gerede usw. wir können nicht alles unter den Teppich halten, einfach, ja zum Glück haben wir Selensky. Da können sich die Leute so ein bisschen abarbeiten. So und wir, ich meine, wir hören gleich die Zahlen des amerikanischen Verteidigungshaushaltes, wie sie sich jetzt entwickelt haben, wie die Unterstützung der Ukrainer wirklich aussieht. Kennen wir diese Zahlen und ihre Entwicklung? Also da, wo es handfest zur Sache geht, wo dann auch wirklich die Verträge unterschrieben werden, das ist uns alles weitgehend unbekannt. Aber diese, ja er hatte halt ein tolles Video und damals einen tollen Spruch gemacht, das wissen wir immer noch. Was für einen Spruch er vor einem dreiviertel Jahr gemacht hat, Selensky. Also in deren Sicht hier ist schon ganz schön viel Ablenkung dabei und am besten finde ich dann, wie Korbinian Frenzel vom Deutschlandfunk nochmal vor so einer Art Überhitzung der Inszenierungsgeschichten war.
Stellt euch mal vor, da hätte dann bei Kriegsbeginn und auch in den Vormonaten jemand gesessen, der kein Redetalent hat, der vielleicht eben auch politisch ein bisschen, ja, sinister ist. Es wäre genauso ein Angriff gewesen auf die Ukraine, die demokratisch diesen Präsidenten, der vielleicht nicht Charismatisches gewählt hätte. Wie sehr hat es beeinflusst, wie empathisch wir mit dabei sind und wie sehr dürfen wir das dann unterm Strich auch zulassen? Und wie sehr müssen wir eben auch genau diese Prüffrage stellen? Also Politik, die einfach sachlich richtig ist, unabhängig davon, ob wir jetzt nun gewonnen werden durch eine Rhetorik. Und der Gedanke obendrauf, wir müssen dann natürlich, das sage ich jetzt vor allem aus einer journalistischen Perspektive, diesen Wachsamkeitsmodus dann auch irgendwann vielleicht noch mal ein bisschen stärker schärfen, sobald vielleicht auch die Gefahr größer wird, dass da etwas überinszeniert wird und dass damit eben auch Politik gemacht wird, die man vielleicht auch hinterfragen muss. Ist sowas dann denkbar?
Ja, ich meine überinszeniert. Also ich verstehe ja, was er uns hier sagen will und so.
Ich meine, da leben wir die ganze Zeit.
Der mediale Modus ist doch, im Wirtschaftsministerium arbeiten 5, 6, 7, 8, 9.000 Leute. Und medial bei uns kommt an der eine Satz, den der Chef des Ladens heute sagte.
In einer Talkshow.
Zum Beispiel. Oder irgendwo bei einer Pressekonferenz. Das wird uns am Abend mitgeteilt. Damit ist die Geschichte geschrieben, was da wirklich vor sich geht, wie die Budgets sind, wie sie zustande kommen, wie sie verteilt werden. Das findet doch niemals medial statt. Und so ist das doch auch bei dem Krieg. Da sind jetzt auf jeder Seite mindestens 100.000 Menschen gestorben. Und der Jahresrückblick, beispielsweise in so einem politischen Podcast wie bei Micky Beisenherz, dreht sich dann eine halbe Stunde von 35 Minuten Ukraine-Thematisierung um Selenskys Bild in der Öffentlichkeit. Und das sieht doch jeder, das muss man doch einfach einsehen, dass das Quatsch ist. Dass das wirklich Quatsch ist. Die Realität findet woanders statt. Und dieses Gerede darüber ist einfach, ich finde da gar keine Worte. Das ist so eine Verirrung, so eine Verwirrung, so eine Selbstverleugnung.
Das ist diese alberne Personalisierung, die vorgenommen wird. Und dann wird noch vor der Personalisierung hier gewarnt, dass man nicht eine Überinszenierung hat, die man ja schon die ganze Zeit hat, indem man nur personalisiert und das am liebsten darauf rausbringen würde, wer ist cool und wer nicht.
Da sitzen Medienstars in einem Podcast und reden über den Medienstar-Charakter dessen, was sie sehen, wenn sie Ukrainekrieg sagen. Ich will es hier einfach mal verurteilen. Ich finde es wirklich nicht gut. Wir versuchen jetzt mal so ein bisschen, das zumindest dahingehend aufzubrechen, dass zumindest das eine oder andere Narrativ einfach nicht das ist, dem wir nächstes Jahr folgen müssen, da wir wahrscheinlich das ganze Jahr hindurch mit diesem Krieg zu tun haben. Zum Thema Geld. Die Journalisten, die dann für das sozusagen große Publikum, also es ist ja zugegebenermaßen ein Unterhaltungspodcast gewesen, den wir jetzt gerade gehört haben. Ja, das läuft ja unter Unterhaltung, muss ich mal sagen. Das, was wir jetzt hören, ist ja Berichterstattung von vor Ort, die dann sozusagen auch an verfassungsrechtlich so ein bisschen niedergeschriebene Maßstäbe der Information und des öffentlich-rechtlichen Unfunks und so weiter. Der Selensky-Besuch wurde wie folgt umrahmt. Hier zum Beispiel in einer Moderation in den Tagsthemen.
Die größte Herausforderung der Reise, die Rede, in der Selensky die amerikanische Politik davon überzeugen muss, dass es sich weiterhin lohnt, sein Land zu unterstützen.
Wird Selensky wirklich die Aufgabe, die Amerikaner zu überzeugen zu müssen, nochmal die ein oder andere einstellige Milliarde zu bezahlen, um in diesem Art gerade Gewinne in Sachen Weltgeschichtsschreibung einzufahren? Oder...
Sitzen die Amerikaner da und sagen, ach so, so habe ich noch gar nichts bedacht.
Du willst Geld von uns, da musst du erstmal betteln. Oder es ist vielleicht genau umgedreht. Das ist hier in den Tagesthemen wie folgt.
Und später dann der Auftritt Selenskys vor dem US-Kongress. Wie wichtig ist dieser Auftritt?
Der ist glaube ich sehr wichtig.
Die USA sind ja der größte Unterstützer der Ukraine.
Ja, und deswegen ist es ganz wichtig, dass er noch nach mehr fragt, weil die Amerikaner irgendwie angeblich unwillig sind, noch mehr zu bezahlen. Die Korrespondenten aus Kiew, ähnlicher Tenor.
Selensky will mit seinem Besuch deutlich machen, die Ukraine braucht weitere Unterstützung. Die Ukraine braucht die USA als starken Partner an ihrer Seite. Und Selensky wird in den Gesprächen mit beiden hinter verschlossenen Türen vor allem auch darauf drängen, nicht nur Waffen für die Verteidigung zu bekommen, nicht nur Flugabwehr zu bekommen, sondern auch konkrete Offensivwaffen, damit die Ukraine schneller ihr eigenes Territorium zurückerobern kann und gleichzeitig auch beispielsweise Langstreckenraketen, um die Möglichkeit zu haben, die Militärbasen in Russland anzugreifen.
So, Vasili Golod, glaube ich, tut so, als müssten die das jetzt mal, als wäre das jetzt im Pentagon denen noch nicht klar. Das kann doch nicht wirklich sein, warum glaubt man das, dass das so ist.
Also es ist mir auch unklar. Wir haben ja auch schon darüber gesprochen, dass in Deutschland immer dieses, der Scholz hilft zu wenig, der schickt zu wenig Waffen und so weiter. Gleichzeitig fragt man sich die ganze Zeit und hat das ja auch dann öffentlich mitbekommen, wie Precht, der ja am Anfang schon dadurch aufmerksam auf sich gemacht hat, dass er meinte, die Ukraine sollen sich mal ergeben, die haben nie eine Chance gegen die russische Armee, dann plötzlich feststellte, ne, die russische Armee ist ganz schön schwach. Und eins plus eins muss man ja auch sagen, die Ukrainier sind ganz schön stark. Wie ist denn das eigentlich, wie könnte die so stark sein? Also wir sehen hier...
Sind die nur tapfer?
Genau, sind das einfach nur tapfere Helden, die sich sozusagen... Hier läuft doch schon seit ein paar Monaten eine Unterstützung auf eine Art und Weise, die allen den Ohren schlackern lässt, vor allem Vladimir Putin. Und das wir jetzt im Dezember 2020 nach diesen neun Monaten Krieg immer noch so ein Narrativ drin haben. Ja, der Selensky fährt da hin und battelt erst mal um mehr Waffen, weil der Westen will gar nicht mehr Waffen schicken.
Das hat der Nissen auch im Interview direkt widerlegt und gesagt, nö, da gibt es auch gar keine Ohneeinheit. Da gibt es ja eine große Eintracht überhaupt mal. Eigentlich ist dieses Land ja, was Demokraten, Republikanern belang derart gespalten, dass da nichts mehr zusammengeht. Also da ist ja, dass die nicht noch eine eigene Nationalhymne inzwischen einführen, ist ja das Letzte. Aber da, in der ukrainischen Angelegenheit, herrscht ja sehr großer Eintracht, bis auf ein paar Neo-Reaktionäre.
Die kommen wir gleich zu sprechen. Das ist völlig absurd.
Das ist was ganz anderes.
Dieses Narrativ zu bringen, dass ein paar Republikaner nicht an Bord sind, weil sie sich öffentlich geäußert haben. Also wir haben hier, und ich will es noch mal sozusagen abbinden mit einem dritten, das ist jetzt ein Kommentar aus Berlin. Also wir haben jetzt einmal in Washington die Cospa nennen, jetzt in Kiew. Jetzt hören wir Gudrun Engel, diesen Kommentar, den die Eigendorf so vehement auf Twitter kritisiert hat. Also wo auch mal so ein bisschen ZDF gegen ARD.
Ja genau, alle sind durchgedreht auf Twitter wegen dieses Kommentars jetzt hier. Und man hört sich den an und denkt so und wo ist der Skandal?
Ja, also die Eigendorf, der Eigendorf kam der Heldencharakter Selenskys zu kurz in dem Kommentar, den wir jetzt hören. Das war die Kritik. Und wir achten aber gar nicht so sehr darauf, dass mit dem Heldentum, das kann man nochmal mithören, das haben wir jetzt so weit abgehandelt, aber es ist halt nochmal dieses grundlegende und wie ich finde falsche Narrativ und mit falsch meine ich der Gegenentwurf, dass die Amerikaner sehr gerne mit allem, was sie haben, den Ukrainern helfen, gegen Russland, dass man das zumindest mal als Arbeitshypothese aufnimmt.
Diese Reise nach Washington von Selensky, sie ist ein Akt der Verzweiflung. Die erste Auslandsreise des ukrainischen Präsidenten seit Kriegsbeginn. Bislang hat er sich stets online durch die Parlamente geschaltet, um um Unterstützung zu bitten. Das reicht nun offenbar nicht mehr. Also ist er in die USA geflogen zu seinem Hauptgeldgeber. Die Vereinigten Staaten haben bislang mehr als 68 Milliarden US-Dollar in die Ukraine gesteckt, damit die nicht zusammenbricht. Doch nach den US-Zwischenwahlen werden die kritischen Stimmen lauter, besonders die Republikaner.
Werden die kritischen Stimmen lauter, insbesondere die Amerikaner? Fährt Selensky wirklich dahin, um dann irgendwie rumzubetteln? Wir hören hier eine Rebellin, allerdings. Es ist die Majority Taylor Greene, die wir kennen von Sprüchen wie Trump muss ins Weiße Haus, ansonsten kommen die Aliens und schießen mit ihren Lasern uns alle in den Wahnsinn. Man kann es sich nicht vorstellen, wie irre. Ja, sie hat halt so einen Posten jetzt im Kongress, aber das ist nicht Mehrheitsmeinung der Republikaner.
Am Abend wird Selensky vor dem Kongress seine Rede halten und nochmals die Dringlichkeit der Hilfen betonen müssen. Denn vor den Abgeordneten liegt der Haushaltsentwurf für das kommende Jahr zur Verabschiedung. Darin weitere 45 Milliarden Dollar an Hilfen für die Ukraine. Doch in den Zwischenwahlen haben die Republikaner die Mehrheit im Repräsentantenhaus gewonnen. Und einige von ihnen haben die Zahlungen an die Ukraine in Frage gestellt. Unter republikanischer Mehrheit wird kein Penny mehr in die Ukraine gehen. Unser eigenes Land kommt zuerst.
Schön und gut, dass jeder sagt. Das ist aber totaler Nonsens. Die Meinung der Republikaner ist die folgende.
Die Rede zeigt Wirkung. Sogar führende Republikaner fordern jetzt noch schwerere Waffen. Die US-Regierung ist nicht bereit, die zu liefern. Ich verstehe das nicht. Andere Länder wollen diese Waffen liefern, aber sie bekommen keine Erlaubnis von den Vereinigten Staaten.
Das klingt schon fast wie Norbert Röttgen.
Ja, genau.
Die anderen wollen und wir machen jetzt gerade nicht. Nun, es ist auch ganz einfach zu klären. Natürlich gibt es ein paar Irre bei den Republikanern, aber die meisten Republikaner haben eines im Sinne amerikanische Interessen. Und diese werden in der Ukraine mit verteidigt, Stichwort Stellvertreterkrieg. Deswegen gibt es da eine große Eintracht. Wo es keine Eintracht ist, gibt es bei der genauen Budgetierung und bei dem, was denn genau damit gekauft werden soll. Warum? Weil es selbstverständlich da wieder sehr viele Partikularinteressen gibt. Und da ist es keineswegs so, dass man sagt, naja, die Demokraten wissen schon am besten, was sie mit dem Geld machen. Nee, da haben ja Republikaner auch nochmal ein paar Leute, bei denen sie auf dem Bezahlzettel stehen und so weiter. Und da muss man nochmal ein bisschen rund telefonieren, welcher Panzer es am Ende wird, weil man vielleicht auch noch einen alten Kontakt...
Richtig. Also in Amerika geht ja die Schuldenbremse nicht so hart wie bei uns. Das ist ja immer so eine Spielerei. Wenn der Kongress entscheidet, da wird Geld ausgegeben, wird Geld ausgegeben. Jetzt ist die Gelegenheit da. In jedem Bundesstaat, in jeder großen Stadt gibt es irgendeinen Waffenhersteller, den man hofieren kann. Es gibt Kongressabgeordnete, egal welcher Partei, die einfach sagen, die hol ich auch noch einen Vertrag raus. Entsprechend haben wir also nicht die Lage, dass die Amerikaner gerade irgendwie so zögern und irgendwie das Geld nicht locker machen wollen und deswegen der Selensky erst kommen muss, sondern wir haben dort schon harte Haushaltsverhandlungen gehabt. Und am 23.12. dann eben auch diese Nachrichtenlage.
Das US-Parlament hat heute den Haushaltsentwurf für das kommende Jahr und damit auch weitere Milliardenhilfen beschlossen. Vorgesehen sind für die weitere Unterstützung der Ukraine darin 45 Milliarden Dollar. Das ist mehr als Präsident Biden zuletzt gefordert hatte. Insgesamt hat der neue Etat ein Volumen von 1, 7 Billionen US-Dollar.
Und davon ist ungefähr die Hälfte für das Militär über 800 Milliarden. Der Kongress bewilligt nochmal extra für die Ukraine mehr Geld, als das Weiße Haus überhaupt beantragt hat. Die haben also noch was draufgelegt. Hier muss niemand gebattelt werden oder so.
Und das lag nicht an der Rede. Das war nicht, weil er so unglücklich charismatisch geredet hat und die sich dann vorher noch Apokalypse und Filtercafé angehört haben, sagten, ja, der ist wirklich unser Medienstar. Das ist auch unsere US-DNH. So wollen wir doch eigentlich sein. Warum war also Selensky in den USA? Ich glaube, man kann die Frage relativ leicht beantworten, nämlich es gibt ja eine Politik der Bilder. Hier können wir schon davon sprechen. Und eine Außenpolitik, die auf diese Weise gemacht wird, dass man eigentlich sagt, seht her, Amerika lädt ihn sogar richtig zu sich nach Hause ein. Nicht einfach nur mal per Video, sondern er kommt dahin. Das heißt, man kämpft Seite an Seite dort. Das ist das Bild, das man nach Moskau transportiert. Und das man auch nach Europa transportiert. In dem Sinne, schaut her, dichter können wir jetzt nicht mehr zusammenstehen. Was ist mit euch?
Ich will es jetzt genauso frameen. Wir gucken uns jetzt O-Töne von dem Besuch an. Und es gibt in dieser Kriegsgeschichte der letzten 300 Jahre eigentlich eine Botschaft, die immer funktioniert, wenn das Staatsoberhaupt während eines Krieges das Land verlässt und weiß, die machen das schon zu Hause.
Und ich kann auch immer wieder zurückkommen, die werden mich empfangen.
Dann ist der Sieg eingefahren. Dann ist der Sieg schon verbucht. Die Frage ist nur, was passiert als nächstes? Wie verwalten wir jetzt unseren Sieg? Wie viel holen wir noch raus? Ich weiß noch, wie damals im Syrien-Krieg, wie heißt der Präsident dort? Dingsda Bums plötzlich in Moskau auftauchte. Überraschungsbesuch an Putins Seite in Moskau. Botschaft an die ganze Welt. Während des Krieges gegen die NATO-Mächte, gegen Deutschland usw. Konnte er sein Land verlassen. Assad tauchte plötzlich. Und dabei für alle klar, Putin hat das jetzt gewonnen. Das ist die Botschaft. Es ist noch die Frage. Wir haben gesehen, wie es in Syrien weiterging. Dieser Auftritt von Selensky in Washington ist genau diese Botschaft, würde ich sagen, viel eher als dieses Gebettel um irgendwelche finanziellen Unterstützung oder sowas. Das ist einfach nicht der Rede wert gewesen. Das war alles schon eingetütet. Es ist diese große Botschaft, wir haben jetzt in Sinne Kriegscharakter Weltkrieg einen Sieg eingefahren und verkünden ihn auch, indem wir zeigen, der Staatschef ist in der Lage, das Land zu verlassen, wieder zurückzukehren an die Front und damit diese Nähe nach Amerika herzustellen. Und entsprechend war auch der Tonfall dann vor Ort, hier beispielsweise bei der Pressekonferenz im Weißen Haus. Und das ist natürlich superproduktiv für die Amerikaner. Dieses Narrativ des Helden und so weiter. Du hast uns inspiriert.
Er steht ja auch hier jetzt neben beiden, nicht im Anzug, sondern in seinem quasi Uniform. Grüner Olivengrüner Pullover, der fast eine Uniform ist.
Das ist so seine Medienuniform. Genau. Man muss es echt ein bisschen despiktierlich sagen. Das ist so dieses...
Und so funktionieren Medien. Das ist doch noch überliefert von der Theologin Uttaranka Heinemann, die damals sehr stark den Papst kritisierte, Papst Johannes Paul II. Und da hatte sie so ein abwaschbares, türkises Kleid an. Und dann sagte sie, und seitdem wurde ich immer wieder in Talkshows angefangen, aber immer mit der Bitte, doch wieder dieses Kleid anzuziehen.
Ja, manchmal, und das... Weiß ich nicht, wir sind jetzt hier in so einer Art Safe Space Podcast. Wir sind auch Medienleute und so. Aber manchmal sieht man so Sachen, ich konnte damals einen Redaktionsschluss drüber schreiben, als es so amerikanische Wahlkämpfe gibt. Da tanzen die politischen Protagonisten, den Journalisten einfach auf der Nase herum. Und können sich Berichterstattung bestellen. Nicht indem sie anrufen und sagen, mach mal so und so, sondern indem sie genau wissen, wie es funktioniert, ihnen genau das anbieten und die genau das vollziehen, was man sich im Situation Room vorher ausgedacht hat als mediales Strategie. Und dann abends einfach die Sektkorken aufmacht, wenn der Nachrichtentag rum ist, weil es eins zu eins aufgegangen ist.
Das Charisma hat wieder gewirkt. Das war ja auch, bevor dieser Kampf dann zwischen Habeck und Baerbock war, die ganze Zeit mit Habeck so. Alle elf Minuten verliebte sich ein Journalist in Robert Habeck.
Ja, das ist, Schirrmacher hat damals diesen Spruch gemacht, als er immer seine Journalisten entsendet hat zu den Piraten. Und meint so, ja, die gehen mal zu diesen Piratenveranstaltungen und kommen dann als Piraten zurück. Die werden einfach so richtig durchgenudelt und sehen so, so kann man auch Politik machen. Und so ist das hier auch. Wir haben es ja einfach, ja, es ist immer noch ein Krieg und dementsprechend wirklich materiell super schlimm. Aber wir haben es ja mit einer Kampagne zu tun, also dieses amerikanische Wort für Wahlkampf ist ja irgendwie noch ganz passend. Wir haben es mit einer Kampagne zu tun, bei der die Kampagnen leider den Journalisten auf der Nase herumtanzen. Und es mir völlig unverständlich ist, warum die das nicht finden.
Mir ist es verständlich. Mir ist es verständlich. Ich glaube, das ist gerade in den deutschen Medien so, weil man nur in einer stark moralisierenden Weise darüber spricht. Und wir haben das ja schon festgestellt bei diesen Talkshows. Es sind dort alle sich einig, dass es ein Angriffskrieg Russlands ist. Aber alle sagen noch dreimal Angriffskrieg von Russland. Und ohne Frage, es handelt sich hier um einen Angriffskrieg von russischer Seite, damit man auf keinen Fall moralisch in eine merkwürdige Ecke gestellt werden könnte. Und dadurch, dass man aber die ganze Zeit in dieser gefühligen und moralischen Weise darüber spricht, will man gar nicht mehr das Strategische aussprechen, weil man glaubt, dass sobald man über Strategie und Kalkül spricht, man eigentlich etwas Unmoralisches meint. Nein, man kann moralisch sein. Und wenn man erfolgreich moralisch sein will, dann sollte man das auch strategisch tun. Und deswegen ist es so wichtig, über Strategien zu sprechen. Und man kann das alles so reportieren, was da stattgefunden hat. Und das passiert ja auch in Front Policy und in all diesen Fachmagazinen passiert das ja. Ganz nüchtern, ganz auf das Kalkül bedacht. Und trotzdem gibt es ja keinen Zweifel daran, dass die Ukraine angegriffen wurde.
Wenn es so leicht ist, nach Gut und Böse einzuteilen, macht man es zu häufig. Es ist zwar immer noch richtig, sozusagen das Gute vom Bösen zu unterscheiden, weil den Kompass wollen wir doch nicht verlieren. Aber es gibt eben noch andere Dimensionen.
Und Gut und Böse haben wir ja auch schon herausgearbeitet, ist nicht die beste Kategorie, um Außenpolitik zu beurteilen.
Niemals die einzige und selten die beste Kategorie.
Und mit Interessen kommt man da sehr viel weiter, vor allem einfach, weil es doch bei den Menschen ein Erkenntnisinteresse daran gibt. Was ist denn der eigentliche Grund? Was passiert denn dort? Und natürlich spielen Politiker etwas vor. Das ist ja ihre primäre Aufgabe. Und eigentlich muss man hier wieder Filmkritiker sagen, was wird dann hier gespielt?
Genau, was wird denn hier eigentlich gezeigt? Und ich glaube, der Dreh- und Angelpunkt von allem ist hier.
Das ist Washington, der erste Reise außerhalb von Ukraine seit Februar kommt, als Präsident Putin seine zahlreichen, brutalen.
Es ist ihr erster Besuch im Ausland seit Kriegsbeginn. Das ist der Punkt. Biden spricht jetzt hier und man hört so ein bisschen, wie die Ukraine jetzt, da die Sache eigentlich gelaufen ist. Also Russland kann das militärisch nicht gewinnen. Da ist sich die Welt eigentlich ziemlich einig. Selbst Selensky kann jetzt schon durch die Welt turnen. Und in dem Maße nutzt jetzt Biden die Gelegenheit, die Ukraine als Schiffre zu nutzen für die Auseinandersetzungen, in denen man sich befindet. Und das lenkt ja schon so Aufmerksamkeit auf, ach ja, wir haben ja noch andere große Auseinandersetzungen. Kalter Krieg, der neue kalte Krieg, das war ja eigentlich China und so. Und in der Hinsicht antizipiert er hier auch so ein bisschen, was wäre, wenn jetzt die Bande nicht hält mit der Ukraine, mit der Unterstützung Europas und so weiter?
Du hast eine sehr, sehr große Hilfe. Du wirst nie allein stehen, wenn die Freiheit von Ukraine die amerikanischen Menschen, wie die Generationen von Amerikanern vor uns, nicht verzweifelt haben. Die Waffe in der Ukraine ist ein Teil von etwas viel größeres. Die amerikanischen Menschen wissen, dass wenn wir sich in der Führung von solchen blöden Angriffen auf Freiheit und Demokratie und den zahlreichen Prinzipien der Gedeihung und der territorialen Integrität, die Welt sicherlich die schlimmsten Konsequenzen verursacht.
Das war ja dann so dieser Moment, wo dann auch die Tweets auftauchten und 20-jährige Soziologiestudenten in Bielefeld ganz tapfer und völlig richtig auf Twitter schrieben, da müssen die Masalas der Welt jetzt ganz tapfer sein in Deutschland. Ja, das ist ein stellvertretter Krieg. Das ist ja nicht einfach nur Russland gegen die Ukraine und zum Glück halten die Helden durch, sondern, nee, das wird uns jetzt ein paar Jahre beschäftigen. Hier geht es um mehr. Hier muss man jetzt sozusagen mal überlegen, worum es eigentlich geht und sich dann auch positionieren über diese, wie soll man sagen, dieses moralische Containment hinaus, dass man ja einfach nur in der Ukraine vielleicht kurz Aufmerksamkeit spenden muss. Und damit ist das schon erledigt. Nee, hier sind wir jetzt alle irgendwie involviert. Der Charakter des Krieges ist ein Weltkrieg. Und Biden bietet es sozusagen an. Also mein Denkangebot ist, wir helfen hier in allen Lagen, soweit es geht und es ist uns nichts zu teuer.
Und die USA ist engagiert, die brave ukrainische Menschen zu verhindern, ihr Land gegen russische Aggressionen zu verteidigen, so lange es dauert. Und ich möchte die Mitglieder des Kongressen und ihrer breiten Bipartisansupport für Ukraine danken. Und ich freue mich auf die Bipartisansupport für Ukraine und ich freue mich auf die Bipartisansupport.
Ja, und die dürfen ausgegeben werden. Und wenn es dann neuen Bedarf gibt, gibt es ein neues Gesetz. Bidens Finale extrem empathetisch.
Heute ist der vierte Nacht des Hanukkah.
Ja, aus sicherer Distanz kann man reinzufügen, wir geben Geld, aber wir sagen, geht doch ihr schon mal voraus, wir kommen vielleicht ja nicht nach, aber wir schicken nochmal was. Das ist das, was uns immer klar sein sollte. Jürgen Habermas hat es so schön geschrieben, wir sind immer in dieser Zuschauerloge, egal wie viel Unterstützung wir leisten, es sei denn, wir würden direkt Kriegspartei werden, würden also selbst Soldaten schicken, dies ist nicht der Fall, würde zur besagten Eskalation führen und das ist immer etwas, was dann durch sehr viel Pathos überdeckt wird.
Ja, aber es ist doch genau das Denkangebot nochmal für die deutschen Podcasterinnen und Journalisten, um im Hintergrund nochmal einmal die fossile und militärische Industrie in Amerika so richtig Grund zu sanieren. Nochmal 300 Milliarden irgendwie locker zu machen für alles.
Damit die Flamme brennt.
Damit die Flamme brennt. Das ist eigentlich ein ganz guter Bild. Und Selensky, klar, es ist natürlich auch ein bisschen tricky, man kann nicht einen Tag bevor oder zwei Tage bevor der Kongress sagt, ja klar schicken wir dir Geld, sogar mehr als der beiden will, dann zu sagen, danke für euer Geld und so. Nein, man muss dann auch nochmal, die Entscheidung ist ja noch nicht da, dieses Battle damit reinbringen, das macht Selensky auch ganz praktisch.
Vielen Dank, Herr Präsident, für 45 Milliarden Euro, denn das ist eine große Unterstützung und ich hoffe, dass der Kongress diese finanzielle Unterstützung für unser Land erzielen wird. Und jeder Dollar des Investments für die USA wird eine globale Sicherheit stärken.
Das ist eine interessante mediale Spielerei und wer hier meint, das ist keine mediale Spielerei, doch das ist eine Pressekonferenz im Weißen Haus vor goldenen Gardinen.
Was soll das sonst sein?
Und das ist überall so. Also das ist ja nicht jetzt eine amerikanische Eigenart, sondern so funktioniert das und das gilt es ja nur zu lesen und was anderes geht es ja gar nicht. Und ich frage mich immer die Leute, die dann nur auf diese ganze Show Effekte gehen. Man kennt es doch aus dem normalen wirtschaftlichen Leben. Also wenn man eine Gehaltsverhandlung hat, wenn man vielleicht ein kleines Unternehmen hat, das mit irgendeinem anderen Unternehmen etwas tun muss, wenn man was aushandeln muss mit Kunden, was auch immer. Es ist doch immer eine Spielerei. Es ist doch immer ein Wie wirkt dein Charisma? Wie verhandel ich? Setze ich einfach noch mal einen drauf, sag 1000 Euro mehr, bekomme ich dann trotzdem, wenn ich nicht mit der Wimper zu Kunde sage. Diese ganzen Sachen kennen wir doch daher. Da würde doch auch niemand davon sprechen. Also jetzt kann man sagen, ach, zeigt ihr jetzt, dass das alles verlogen ist? Nein, so funktioniert soziale Interaktion. Es ist, wie es ist. Und das ist auch bei jedem Geschäftsvorgang gegeben. Und jeder hat das im größeren oder kleineren Maßstab. Mir sagte mal ein sehr erfolgreicher Unternehmer, der viel arbeitet, aber wahnsinnig viel Kapital akkumuliert hat. Ich befinde mich jeden Tag im Krieg. Und das war keine falsche Äußerung.
Genau. Ich würde es nicht allzu inflationär benutzen. In dem Fall ist es wirklich ein Krieg. Aber es ist, wie es ist. Goffman hat darüber geschrieben, wir alle spielen Theater mit dem schönen Bild. Das dreijährige Kind sitzt auf der Schaukel und freut sich natürlich darüber, von der Oma angeschaukelt zu werden. Warum? Schaukeln macht schon Spaß. Aber die Oma wird nur dadurch motiviert, dass sie sieht, wie das Kind Spaß hat. Also spielt das Kind der Oma die Freude vor. Er lebt das natürlich auch als echte Freude. Dadurch ist diese Verknüpfung der Skripte, wenn ich angeschaukelt werden will, muss ich mich freuen. Und zwar so sichtbar, dass andere sich darüber freuen, wie ich mich freue. Damit hat man die Schleifen des Publikums gedreht. Man kann auch sein eigenes Publikum sein, da geht es los bei Kaufmann. Und das hier ist sozusagen der Gipfel dieser medialen Spielerei.
Als ich ins Hotel kam, ich habe ja in Frankfurt übernachtet, als wir unsere Show hatten, sagte die Dame an der Rezeption, schön, dass Sie wieder hier sind. Das wusste sie, weil das im Computer angezeigt wurde. Ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, dass sie mich das jetzt immer nicht bedient hat. Und sie freut sich, dass ich wieder da bin. Und sie freut sich dann auch, wenn ich gehe, wenn ich wiederkomme. Aber sie freut sich natürlich nicht persönlich. Aber soll sie mir sagen, wissen Sie, mir wird hier gerade angezeigt, Sie waren schon mal da. Hallo. Nein, das möchte ich natürlich nicht. Und ich freue mich, dass sie sagt, ah, schön, dass Sie wieder da sind.
Man muss, egal was auf der Welt strukturell passiert, es muss einmal durch das limbische System gedreht werden. Und am besten steht da vor ein Koch, der es nochmal aufbereitet, zubereitet und das hinrichtet. Was man dann zu konsumieren soll. Selenskys Finale.
Wir werden auch, sobald unsere Vorgabe gestärkt wird, in den nächsten Monaten, ich will es nicht in Details diskutieren.
Doch, mach doch mal. Diskutier es doch mal im Detail, was du für einen Plan hast, wie das Budget dann weiter steigert in den nächsten Monaten. Und dann so, nee, alles zu seiner Zeit. So wie man auch hier sagen muss, hoffentlich stimmt der Kongress zu übermorgen.
Ich glaube, du verstehst, warum, aber ich bin sehr dankbar dem Präsidenten Biden.
So, jetzt wird es den Amerikanern mulmig, weil die Europäer so sagen, wir sind zu nah dran vielleicht. Können wir ein bisschen mit Handbremse fahren, auf Sicht vielleicht, müssen wir so all in gehen. Biden schwört die Europäer ein.
Unsere europäischen Partner, die mehr oder weniger, verstehen es voll. Wir haben seit Weltkrieg keine große Verbreitung von europäischen Ländern gesehen. Und sie sehen keine Signen, dass Putin etwas tun wird, um das zu ändern, unless wir sich aufregen und die Ukrainern aufregen. Wir alle wissen was an Bedeutung ist, die sehr gute Idee der Wohneinheit, der UN-Kartell.
Das finde ich besonders interessant, weil er hier so markiert dieses wir kämpfen gegen Putin, also gegen Putin. Wir kämpfen aber für die UN-Karta, Menschenrechte und so weiter. Also er lädt diesen eigentlich schon eingefahrenen Sieg noch mal richtig auf. Das ist ein bisschen wie zuerst sagen wir dir, ob du schuldig bist und das Strafmaß kommt ein bisschen später. Ja, also du hast den Krieg schon verloren, aber in welchem Ausmaß, das klären wir jetzt erst mal. So und deswegen ist das so extrem aufgeladen, auch alles reingebuttert.
Dieses Einschwören der Europäer findet ja auch medial ganz stark statt. Also ich hatte ja eben dieses Zitat davor gelesen von dem Experten und Thinktanker Gessel, der dann sagt, wenn wir die Ukraine nicht unterstützen, dann stehen die Russen bald vor Berlin. Das ist ja etwas, was wir seit den 50er Jahren kennen von Eisenhower, der diese Domino-Theorie aufstellt, auf die sich dann auch Kissinger und Weichgottwehr bezog, dass man immer sagt, also wenn Vietnam fällt, dann passiert das, wenn Kambodscha, dann das. Und das ist eine Argumentationslogik, in der wir uns seit 70 Jahren befinden und die hier reaktiviert wird.
Genau, da kann man ja auch drüber nachdenken, wie realistisch ist es in den unterschiedlichen Szenarien, dass tatsächlich Russland in zehn Jahren dann mal in Europa einfällt?
Mit der an sich schwachen Armee, aber das klappt dann.
Genau, das ist nämlich die Frage. Szenario eins ist, man lässt diesen Krieg in der Ukraine jetzt so lodern, Hauptsache die Russen müssen weiter Material, Material, Material verschleudern ohne Ende. Oder man beendet den Krieg jetzt mit diplomatischen oder sonstigen Mitteln und gibt damit den Russen wieder die Gelegenheit, jetzt zehn Jahre lang aufzurüsten, ohne dass sie ihr Material die ganze Zeit einsetzen müssen. Und da würde ich sagen, da gibt es auch eine gewisse Logik, lieber kleine Flamme köcheln lassen und dafür den großen Anlauf zu vermeiden.
Die Alternative wäre, dass man beiderseitige Abrüstungsverträge hätte. Danach sieht es wirklich überhaupt nicht auf.
Es werden ja eher die Abrüstungssachen zurückgefahren.
Aber das wäre die einzige Möglichkeit, um das auf jeden Fall zu verhindern.
Das heißt aber echte Verständigung.
Das geht nur mit Echtem Verständigung. Du hast es mitbekommen, ich weiß nicht, bislang ist es glaube ich nur ein Gerücht, dass Lammstorf von der FDP deutscher Botschafter in Moskau werden soll. Also der Lammstorf, der mal so ganz schnell ausflippt bei Twitter, sobald er irgendwie eine halbe Information hat.
Lammstorf ist ein Medienstar.
Ja, aber das ist doch der völlig falsche Mann.
Genau, also damit ist er völlig falsch. Man bräuchte jetzt jemanden, der ganz ruhig Diplomatie in Russland macht. Umso mehr man das Szenario hier sieht, umso undenkbarer, aber die Geschichte ist ja geschrieben, umso unwahrscheinlicher ist es, umso mehr magisch, wie Deutschland und Frankreich 1955 schon wieder gemeinsame Sache machen konnten, zehn Jahre nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg. Das ist hier völlig undenkbar. In Deutschlandfunk hatte ein Russland-Experten da von irgendeiner Uni, der jetzt gar nicht so viel mediale muss, wo ich dann dachte, das ist bestimmt interessant. Und der meinte, in Russland setzen sich als Putins Konkurrenten gerade diejenigen durch, die ihre Teile der Armee, die sie befehligen, noch am besten im Griff haben. Also Putin wird wahrscheinlich, wenn ersetzt durch denjenigen, der sich auf dem Theater of War am besten geschlagen hat. Das sind natürlich keine guten Aussichten für eine Nachfolge für diesen Posten. Also es ist in der Hinsicht schon dramatisch, wie es sich entwickelt. Und ja, Biden macht das hier nochmal klar.
Wir wollen diese Waffe beenden. Wir wollen sie beenden. Aber das wird nicht passieren. Sie kann auf dem Wettbewerb mit unserer Hilfe und der Hilfe unserer europäischen Allianz und anderen. Wenn Präsident Selensky bereit ist, mit den Russen zu sprechen, wird er auch auf dem Wettbewerb auf der Badezene sein können.
Bei Assad und er in Syrien war vor acht, neun Jahren in der Bundespreisekonferenz. Völlig klar, es kann keine militärische Lösung geben. Das war der Spruch, der jede Woche dreimal, da kamen Montags, Mittwochs, es kann keine militärische Lösung geben, bis Putin eine erzwungen hat. Assad hat einfach gewonnen. Und jetzt reibt sich gar keiner daran, dass Biden auf der Bühne steht und sagt, es kann nur eine militärische Lösung geben. Diplomatie sehe ich gerade nicht, ist ausgeschlossen, wir müssen eh auf Putin warten, dass er ein Angebot macht, wir machen keins. Und es kann nur eine militärische Lösung geben. Und alle, also ich habe jedenfalls keine große Resonanz auf diesen Spruch gehört irgendwie, sondern das ist einfach so durchgelaufen. Ja, es kann nur eine militärische Lösung geben. Und das ist schon gerade in diesem, dass es mit Syrien damals so vehement durchgeboxt ist, dass es eben keine militärische Lösung geben kann. Das ist schon erstaunlich. Wahrscheinlich ist das wieder so Geschichte, was für den Siegern geschrieben, wenn es anders gestanden hätte, um Syrien hätte man wahrscheinlich auch gesagt, es kann nur eine militärische Lösung geben, aber nicht der Gegenseite. Der kann mir das nicht zugestehen. Na ja, eine ukrainische Journalistin. Das war super interessant. Sie haben mir vier Fragen zugelassen, zwei amerikanische, zwei ukrainische Journalisten, die ihrerseits dann auch weit über den journalistischen Auftrag hinaus vorstellig wurden.
Wenn die Vollzweiflung begonnen hat, haben die US-Fraktionen gesagt, dass Ukraine nicht Petros bekommen kann, denn, wie du gesagt hast, es könnte eine unnötige Ausstattung sein. Und jetzt passiert es. langweilige Missile-Attacke.
Die Antwort hören wir gleich. Als es losging, Putin greift an. Dann hat man in Deutschland ganz schnell, es gibt ja dann immer, wie bei Corona auch, man lernt so neue Grundsatzworte, Grundbegriffe, wie z.B. Eskalationsdominanz. Und hier hat man jetzt gesehen, die liegt jetzt in Amerika. Man entscheidet einfach, wann man welche Waffen schickt, weil sie sind ja da. Und dann fragt sie, und ich finde es schon irgendwie so zurecht, naja, ich bin zwei Jahre absehbar, dass er uns ja auch Penjot schickt, warum macht er das erst im Dezember, nicht schon im August? Könnte er nicht einfach jetzt schon mal das schicken, was er dann im Mai schickt? Und ja, er spielt das dann so diesen, ja, ich habe hier so ein paar Experten, mein Joint Chief of Staff, die wissen, wie man eskaliert.
Selensky sagt gleich ja, aber wir machen das hier ein bisschen anders.
Genau, wir wissen, wie man Krieg führt. Wir haben sehr viel Erfahrung, wir müssen vorsichtig eskalieren.
Und dann nimmt er noch mal Rücksicht auf das Bündnis.
For two reasons. Und jetzt hören wir mal, ob da auch genannt wird, weil wir nicht wollen, weil wir zögern, weil wir noch nicht überzeugt sind, weil Selensky zu wenig reden gehalten hat oder so, sondern eigentlich hören wir hier raus, wir würden sofort, aber, und jetzt kommen seine zwei Aber.
Es gibt eine ganze Verbindung, die kritisch ist, um mit Ukraine zu bleiben.
Wir werden uns in der Waffe erzielen, und das ist das, was wir tun. Und das ist das, was hier so wichtig ist, was hier nochmal deutlich wird. Es geht immer noch darum, dass man einen dritten Weltkrieg verhindern will. Also das ist eigentlich das, was alles taktische Denken bestimmen muss. Und da helfen solche Podcaster, Floskeln wie, wir sollten uns nicht zu sehr von unserer Angst regieren lassen, einfach nicht weiter. Und da kann man ja dann doch immerhin noch froh sein bei aller Eskalationsdominanz, die an den Tag gelegt wird, dass man es mit Menschen dort zu tun hat, die sich dieser Bedrohung zumindest an sich gewahr sind. Ich denke ja immer, was wäre eigentlich, wenn diese entsprechenden Medienleute, die nur so Kolumnen darüber schreiben, wie steht Selensky eigentlich, diese olivgrüne T-Shirt, wenn die jetzt entscheiden könnten, also wenn die regieren würden, ich habe keine Ahnung, also ich glaube, dann wären wir wahrscheinlich mal hier.
Ja, also hier wird sehr strategisch, taktisch, klug, mit historischer Erfahrung, was auch immer, wird hier einfach gerade eskaliert, weil man weiß, Russland hat verloren, es ist kein militärisches Szenario denkbar, in dem Russland irgendein militärisches Ziel, das vorher gesetzt wurde, erreicht. Und die Frage ist nur, wie weit kann man die Niederlage treiben? Das ist im Grunde, und das ist auch so ein bisschen...
Und auch da muss man ja wieder langfristig denken, und da gibt es ja durchaus Strategien, die das ähnlich sehen, wie auch Kissinger. Man kann natürlich Russland sehr stark wirtschaftlich noch weiter schädigen und kann diese Abnutzung noch verstärken, und Abnutzung von Material meint im Übrigen auch Abnutzung von Menschen, also viele tote Russen. Und das führt aber dieser Schwächung ja nicht unbedingt dazu, dass man dann zum Schoßhund in Moskau wird, sondern kann natürlich bedeuten, dass man eine Art Vasallenstaat für China wird, was dem Westen, wenn wir das mal wieder so bedienen, auch nicht besonders recht sein kann. Also auch da ist noch mal zu überlegen, wie sinnvoll das eigentlich ist. Es gab ja vor 20 Jahren Ideen, wäre das nicht toll, wenn man Russen in die EU aufnehmen kann. Also wenn man mal dachte, ah ja, das wäre ganz gut nicht, dass die mal nach China ganz abhauen. Diese Gefahr besteht natürlich durch so eine große Schwäche wiederum, dass China dann leicht das Spiel hat, den Russen zu diktieren, was sie wollen und die Russen müssen da wohl oder über mitmangel.
Ja, also gerade aus europäischer Sicht würde ich sagen, wir kennen zwei Szenarien für das Ende von so großen kriegerschen Auseinandersetzungen. Das eine ist der Versailler Vertrag und das andere ist die Gründung der Europäischen Union für Kohle und Stahl. Und jetzt muss man überlegen, was zielt man eigentlich an? Also nicht so sehr Ende des Krieges, sondern danach. Wie kann man den Krieg so beenden, dass eins dieser beiden historischen Beispiele, dass man denen so ein bisschen entspricht? Und wir wissen, wir haben glaube ich klare Präferenzen, was das angeht. Vor Publikum wird eine Show gemacht für deutsche Podcasterinnen. Ich komme immer wieder dispektierlich darauf zurück. Aber beispielsweise dieser überbordende Applaus, der dann auch den Protagonisten etwas zu viel wurde. Und hier lief quasi schon fünf Minuten Einlaufapplaus. Selensky ist am Rednerpult angekommen im Kongress. Pelosi versucht jetzt mal ein bisschen für Ruhe zu sorgen.
Ich habe die hohe Privileg und die distincte Ehre, dich zu präsentieren, Herr Excellente, Wladimir Zelensky, Präsident der Ukraine.
Alle Außenhäusern. Sieht nicht danach aus, als seien die auch sehr uneins, was die Budgetierung anbaut.
Also die Rede inhaltlich war unerheblich. Es ging um diesen Moment, um diese Bilder. Wir haben es heute auch auf dem Cover drauf. Das wollte man zeigen. Und Selensky hat entsprechend auch, keine Ahnung, so ein bisschen saloppe Wortwahl.
Gegen alle Verbrechen und Dummen und Blumen, sind die Situationen, dass Ukraine nicht fallen würde. Ukraine ist ein Leben und ein.
Er erzählt dann so, wie er gestern noch in der Front in Bachmut war. Und Bachmut steht aber, wird seit Mai bombardiert und stans. Großer Jubel auch dafür. Und zum Thema Waffenlieferung, es klingt schon so ein bisschen flapsig. Es.
Ich glaube, es sollte keine Abweschnitte zwischen uns in unserer Allianz geben.
So, jetzt hat er ja die Journalistin gefragt, können sie uns nicht das, was sie schon in petto haben, heute schon mal schicken?
Diese Panzer und Flugzeuge, die da noch ausstehen, können wir die nicht schon mal jetzt haben, denn wir können die auch selbst fliegen, keine Sorge.
Schon mal an amerikanischen Panzern und Flugzeugen vor allem. Das ist natürlich, da weiß man, in welche Richtung das geht.
Die fliegen auch über Grenzen hinaus.
Genau, also da wird jetzt, da geht es zur Sache. Jetzt ist ja eine Neuerung, die es gibt im Krieg, Material, sachenmäßig dieses Patriot-Raketenabwehrsystem.
Man muss ja auch übrigens diesen Satz dann so mantra-artig wiederholen. Über das Ende des Krieges entscheidet allein die Ukraine. Und wir sehen jetzt hier auch mal ganz schön, entscheidet die Ukraine gemeinsam mit dem US-Präsidenten und den Verbündeten in Europa. Das ist die korrekte Antwort darauf. Es gibt keine andere korrekte Antwort darauf. Denn sonst müsste man sagen, wenn die Amerikaner nicht unterstützen würden und die Europäer auch nicht, dann wäre der Krieg auf eine andere Weise relativ schnell beendet. Nämlich damit eine Niederlage. Also das heißt, es ist eine gemeinsame Entscheidung, die getroffen wird. Und das machen die ganz alleine für sich. Und da haben wir uns auch gar nicht einzumischen. Es stimmt ja nicht. Also Biden hat es ja gerade mal ganz ausführlich erklärt. 100 Stunden haben sie da konferiert, um mal genau die Strategie auszuarbeiten.
Genau. Also da ist einfach, wir sind, wir können es nicht unterbetonen, weil auch nächstes Jahr ein neues Jahr angeht. Das ist ja Kriegscharakter Weltkrieg. Wenn auch noch nicht Nature, aber zumindest Character ist hier Weltkrieg. Dieses Patriot-Abwehrsystem, das ist ja so ein bisschen, keine Ahnung, es muss irgendwie supergut funktionieren. Es ist mobil, man fährt irgendwo hin, dann fliegen die Raketen 50 Kilometer weit, können Sachen abschießen, ohne dass man nochmal einen eigenen Piloten oder vielleicht sogar ein Kampfflugzeug opfern muss dafür oder so, sondern die Gefahr besteht dann nur für die Gegenseite. Es war großes Thema und es ist interessant, dass Selensky diesen Deal als Thema eröffnet hat. Also gar nicht beiden im Sinne von, sondern die erste Wortmeldung.
Das ist in der Tat sehr ungewöhnlich, dass solche eine Verkündigung nicht von dem kommt, der auch das Mandat dafür hat. Das scheint nur so dann zu sein, dass man sich gar nicht hat, du darfst es sagen. Dann ist das für mich auch nochmal besonders gut, wenn du mich lobst und es sagst.
Genau. Also es ist schon komisch irgendwie. Ja. Es hat wahrscheinlich auch mit so einer semantischen Eskalation zu tun, dass jetzt nicht Biden als Auftritt, sondern dann nur gönnerhaft rüberschaut. Ja, es sind jetzt eure, ihr dürft sie einsetzen. Und provoziert natürlich Fragen im Publikum. Und das ist auch so irre. Also der Journalist fragt im Dezember, der Krieg läuft jetzt seit neun Monaten, zehn Monaten, und sie haben das bisher nicht geschickt, das Patriotsystem wegen dem Eskalationspotenzial. Und dann sagt er, ich bespreche das wieder mit ihnen, ich habe das nicht mal mit Selensky besprochen. Wir schicken das jetzt einfach. Also Selensky verkündet eine Entscheidung, die die Amerikaner komplett selbstständig getroffen haben. Das ist doch irre, dass das so dargestellt wird. Und hier noch, das ist auch verrückt, die Journalisten stehen ja so da und wir wissen ja so ungefähr, wie das so ist, wenn dann auch die Ukraine, wir können es ja immer kurz hören, wenn die Ukrainer so Fragen stellen.
I want to thank the United States for supporting my country and you know, my family is in Ukraine and I definitely understand, they will not be alive today if America will not support my country, both politically and militarily.
Wie ist das eigentlich mit deutschen Journalisten, die so was sehen und sich sonst immer ganz hart von diesem Aktivismusvorwurf fernhalten? Wenn sie hier sehen, diese ganze Hellentumgeräte, was ich die ganze Zeit selber produziere, ist ja gar nicht so weit davon entfernt, dass wenn ich jetzt selber Ukraine wäre, wäre ich ein Aktivist des Krieges, weil das wäre ja irre, wenn man auch noch bei einem Krieg sagt, du darfst aber kein Aktivist sein, es darf nicht dein Anliegen sein. Weil das ist einfach so ein überragendes, generalisiertes Anliegen für Frieden zu sein, dass man da gar nicht mehr unterscheiden kann, zwischen Journalismus und Aktivismus, aber dazu auch keine Reflektion. Das hätte mich mal besonders interessiert, ob die Journalisten dann irgendwann mal sehen, nee, es hat keinen Sinn, nur über Themen zu Berichterstatten, die mich selber nicht interessieren, weil ich ansonsten Aktivismusvorwurf kriege und das will ich ja nicht, also halte ich mich von den Themen fern, die mich eigentlich betreffen.
Alle Aktivisten, auch gerade die, die immer mit diesem Satz ankommen, sich mit keiner Sache gemein machen und das kommt ja immer von gewissen Leuten. Und die, wenn du deren Timeline siehst, deren Tweets der letzten zehn Monate, dann ist das reiner Aktivismus für die eine Sache. Zum Teil hat sich das auch bei Corona ja eingeschlichen.
Stimmt, das kam ja schon mit Corona.
Das war ja ganz erstaunlich, wir hatten ja noch mal diese Krönungs, haben wir hier nicht gespielt, als wir drei Wochen vor diesem Auftritt sprachen wir im Salon über das Buch von Precht und Bälzer, wo sie sagen, ja die Journalisten missverstanden haben. Wir verstehen sich jetzt immer mehr so auch als Politiker und glauben, dass sie das mit denen einfach Hand in Hand regieren müssen. Und drei Wochen später tritt Journalistin Margarete Schukowsky mit Karl-Laute Bach in der Pressekonferenz aus und sagt, ich habe mich infiziert, vermutlich mit Corona nicht im Innenraum, sondern draußen und deswegen empfehle ich euch jetzt, wo eigentlich wir noch wenige Wochen davor waren, dass trosten die Pandemie für beendet erklärt, empfehle ich euch auch draußen Maske zu tragen. Und Lauterbach sitzt daneben und da habe ich gesagt, gut, wollte man jetzt einfach nochmal sagen, hiermit bestätigen wir das Buch von Richard David Precht und Harald Wälzer.
Was ist da los? Und ich habe gar nichts dagegen. Journalismus und Aktivismus nicht allzu scharf unterscheiden, aber es ist halt amüsant, dass da aus Grunde einer Betroffenheit plötzlich so ein Aktivismus reinrutscht, der gar nicht mehr kritisiert wird von denjenigen, die es eigentlich immer kritisiert haben.
Nee, das darf man dann nicht. Und das ist dann immer das Ding, weil ja dann von Julian Reichels Seite oder so dann ein solcher Auftritt kritisiert wird. Denken alle, oh, dann müssen wir auf jeden Fall jetzt diese Journalisten in den Schutz nehmen, denn die wird ja schon von rechts angegriffen. Und dann ist von einer anderen Position aus einfach keine Kritik mehr möglich.
Und damit ist das mediale Spiel wieder gespielt. Also in diesem Tenor werden hier diese Fragen gestellt. Und Selenskyj kommt jetzt mit seiner Antwort. Haben Sie eine Botschaft an Putin? Oder was sagen Sie zu Putin und so? Und Selenskyj denkt sich so, wenn ich nach Putin gefragt werde, rede ich über Biden und die Patriots-Raketen.
Ich kann Messungen zu Präsidenten Biden schicken. Nachdem wir das machen, schicken wir einen anderen Signal an Präsidenten Biden, dass wir mehr Patriots wollen. Als Präsident Putin...
Dann kommt er auf, Putin zu sprechen. Er dreht da noch mal diese extra Runde.
Aber es herrscht eine gute Stimmung zwischen den zwei. Es werden Scherzien gemacht.
Es ist keine Pressekonferenz im Krieg.
Genau. Das ist sehr, sehr gruselig. Das finde ich auch immer, dass es sofort vorgeworfen wird, wenn irgendjemand eine Waffenlieferung in Frage stellt, dass das dann nicht empathisch genug vorgetragen wurde in den Talkshows. Das ist ja dann auch immer, wenn ich schon hier wie unempathisch. Und hier muss man sagen, also zur gleichen Zeit sterben jetzt gerade Menschen auf dem Felde und hier wird ein bisschen herumgescherzt. Das bedeutet auch wieder ganz klar, naja, den Krieg, den müssen halt manche austragen, die nicht vor goldenen Vorhängen stehen.
Und jetzt hören wir nochmal Gudrun Engel, die uns ihre kommentierte Sicht auf die Patriot-Wende nochmal zeigt.
Noch mehr Geld, das muss erst mal genehmigt werden. Und ein Raketenabwehrsystem, das halten Militärexperten nicht für einen Wendepunkt. Kriegstreiber Russland hat bereits angekündigt, darauf mit gezielten Angriffen zu reagieren. Für diese Reise hat Selensky also sein Leben riskiert. Aber sie bringt vermutlich nur Symbolik. Und hat die Welt keinen Meter näher an ein Ende des Krieges gebracht.
Es geht so drunter drüber. Es ist nicht nur Symbolik, Patriot-Raketen zu schicken. Nein. Hat es die Welt näher an den Frieden gebracht? Man weiß es nicht so genau. Man weiß ja nicht, wie Putin sich verhält.
Was ich am wenigsten nachvollziehen kann, ist, wieso Selensky sein Leben riskiert haben soll.
Das haben wir auch nicht ganz verstanden durch so ein Flug.
Glauben die jetzt, dass Putin Selensky abschießen würde? Also gut, wenn man eine maximale Eskalation will, dann würde er erjungen. Aber das könnte er auch auf anderem Wege. Das ist ja unsinnig.
Es ist so ein bisschen verrückt. Jetzt haben wir ja auch aus dem Syrien-Krieg, wir haben ja zum Beispiel in Deutschland Airbases zur Verfügung gestellt. In der Türkei, damit Amerika... Nee, wir haben deutsche Flugzeuge benutzt, die dann aber mit Hilfe amerikanischer Airbases usw. Also wir waren so ein bisschen involviert. Wir haben aber nur Fotos gemacht, also nur für Aufklärung gesorgt und nicht geschossen mit unseren Tornados usw. Dann haben wir ja einen anderen Kriegsszenarien, Drohnenkrieg z.B. mit Rammstein als Stützpunkt der Amerikaner, der aber auf deutschem Boden ist. Es ist kein amerikanisches Hoheitsgebiet, sondern da wird eben Kriegshandlung auch über Deutschland abgewickelt.
Aber man tut immer so, als sei das nicht so.
Genau, also sind wir jetzt eigentlich Kriegspartei, ja oder nein? Diese Frage spielt ja gerade auch keine große Rolle, weil wir schicken halt Material und wir wollen ja, dass mehr Material geschickt wird. Also ist die Frage, ja sind wir jetzt Kriegspartei, ja oder nein? Eigentlich mit dem klaren Ja zu beantworten, aber nein, wir schicken ja keine Soldaten. Irgendwie so. Also wir fahren ja so ein bisschen Slalom um die Frage, ob wir jetzt hier irgendwie beteiligt sind oder nicht. Und deswegen finde ich diesen MRT-Wissen-Hinweis hier gar nicht verkehrt.
Und vor diesem Hintergrund ist die Lieferung des Patriots-Systems sehr wichtig. Es hat eine Reichweite von 1000 Kilometern, kann also eine weite Fläche abdecken, schützen vor reinkommenden Raketen. Und das Bedienpersonal dafür, etwa 1000 Personen sind notwendig, Soldaten und Techniker. Das wird in Deutschland ausgebildet werden, dann wird das System in die Ukraine geliefert und dort ausschließlich von Ukrainern bedient, weil man eben eine Schwelle nicht überschreiten will, nämlich den direkten Eintritt in diesen Krieg.
Und er erklärt uns hier, wie wir nicht die Schwelle überschreiten, direkt am Krieg teilzunehmen, indem wir auf deutschen Boden amerikanische Waffen den Ukrainern zur Verfügung stellen und sie noch ausbilden.
Aber keine deutschen Soldaten. Das ist die Nicht-Schwellenüberschreitung.
Wo will er denn diese Argumentation anbringt, wenn Putin jetzt irgendwie sagt, doch, ich finde, das ist jetzt eine Schwellenüberschreitung, aber der T-Wissen hat doch gesagt, ist es nicht. Für welches Szenario ist das hier noch, also vor welchem unbekannten großen dritten oder wie auch immer der große andere. Vor welchem großen anderen wird das hier eigentlich gerade erklärt? Das ist so die Frage, ne? Also es ist wirklich verrückt.
Ja, das ist genau der alte Zizek Witz mit dem Patienten in der Irrenanstalt, der sagt, Herr Doktor, ich glaube, ich bin ein Samenkorn und werde von einem Huhn gefressen. Dann wird er lange kuriert, dann weiß er wieder, dass er ein Mensch ist, geht hinaus aus der Anstalt, sieht dort ein Huhn, kommt panisch wieder zurück und sagt, oh Gott, ich habe Angst, gefressen zu werden. Ja, aber sie wissen doch, dass sie kein Samenkorn sind. Und dann sagt der Patient, ja, ich weiß das, aber weiß das Huhn das auch?
Genau.
Und hier ist die Frage, weiß Putin das auch?
Weiß Putin das auch?
Dass das keine Eskalation ist?
Genau, das ist genau die Frage. Weshalb wir uns noch mal kurz um das Schicksal Putins kümmern? Denn die Frage ist ja jetzt, du hast einen Plan gehabt, der ging nicht auf. Das kann man glaube ich sagen.
Was ja häufig vorkommt, fast alle Kriege sind immer so, dass man sie beginnt und glaubt, man sei bald schon wieder daheim.
Genau.
Wolfgang Streeck hatte das in diesem 99%-Podcast gesagt, beim Ersten Weltkrieg wurde zum Teil keine warme Unterwäsche mitgenommen, weil man dachte, vor Weihnachten sind wir eh wieder daheim.
Genau. Und das ist ja ein echtes Problem, dass wir jetzt, wie soll man sagen, Putin ist in einem Unternehmen verstrickt, das keine GmbH ist. Hier gibt es keine beschreitene Haftung, sondern hier ist All-in. Hier geht es um Leben und Tod, auch um sein eigenes, entweder als politische Person oder vielleicht sogar als komplette Person. Das hat einen Krieg nun mal mit Ansicht, das ist ein Konflikt, der aufs Maximale generalisiert ist. Es gibt keine Themen neben einem Krieg. Und Putin hat ihn angezettelt und jetzt muss er aus dieser Nummer irgendwie raus und das wurde hier so ein bisschen mitverhandelt. Zum einen hören wir mal Ina Ruck als Zarges-Them-Korrespondentin jetzt in Moskau. Sie hat ja sehr viel Amerika-Erfahrung, schwirrt jetzt da in Moskau rum und naja, es wird jetzt alles zusammengebunden.
Aber völlig klar, Putin richtet sich auf weiteren Krieg ein, er zieht das durch und er hat ja auch seinen Schicksal an diesen Krieg so stark gebunden, dass er eigentlich gar nicht anders kann und er hat es vor allem an einen Sieg gebunden.
Danke für diese Information, Ina Ruck.
Ja, das Gespräch ist ja leider zu Ende, wo es beginnen sollte. Was heißt denn das jetzt? Putin hat das an sich gebunden, ja das stimmt. Man kann einen Krieg nicht, also sich von ihm entbinden, während man ihn gleichzeitig ansettelt. Irgendwer muss den Befehl geben.
Und jetzt würden viele sagen, ja ist doch gut, dann wird Putin bald gestürzt. Aber du hast es eben schon kurz skizziert, wer dann danach kommen würde, das sieht keineswegs besser aus. Ja, es gibt eine Opposition in Russland, die ist aber nicht die Mehrheit der Bevölkerung. Und wir sehen jetzt auch nach zehn Monaten nach auch diesen verheerenden Schicksalen der russischen Soldaten, die nicht mehr wiederkommen. Trotz dieser Mobilmachung, wo dann einige abhauen. Aber wir sehen trotz all dieser extrem harten Schläge, die Putin da seinem eigenen Volk an tut, dass es kaum Widerstand gibt. Und es gibt ja oft auch diesen Effekt, dass, wo die Zeiten dann härter werden, eher da sich die Reihen schließen plötzlich. Und es dann diese Haltung gibt, jetzt ist aber vielleicht doch kein guter Moment für Opposition. Und das ist jedenfalls, also es ist sehr diffus. Wir wissen sowieso nicht genau, was in Russland passiert. Es ist eine große Blackbox. Aber man kann wohl sicher sein, selbst wenn Putin jetzt seine Niederlage eingestehen würde und sagt, ich bin absolut nicht mehr euer Präsident, ihr müsst jetzt einen anderen suchen, dann würde Russland nicht ein vorbildlich demokratischer Staat werden mit einem Präsidenten, der nichts lieber will, als sich dem Westen anzuschließen.
Ja, und das Interessante ist ja auch, also wir haben jetzt eine politische Lage in Russland, in der es eigentlich nur noch den Krieg gibt, alles andere sind sekundäre Themen und man kann alle austauschen. Es gibt generelle, admiräle, Soldaten, was auch immer, die sind austauschbar, der Präsident aber nicht, also es ist einfach Putin. Und die Frage ist ja auch, angenommen es passiert jetzt was mit Putin, er stirbt, er ist verletzt, er ist krank, keine Ahnung, er kann nicht mehr so öffentlich auftreten und so weiter. Also es gibt eine Lücke zu füllen. Man würde ja nicht einfach nur wie in einem normalen Ablauf, jetzt seid neuer Präsident, sondern er reißt ja das ganze Amt mit sich. Also man weiß ja gar nicht, die müssen sich ja danach erstmal neu strukturieren.
Das ist nicht wie in Regierungswechseln in Berlin, wo das Ministerium in etwa so bleibt und da kommen dann noch ein paar nach. Und das war es aber dann auch eigentlich.
Es ist drunter und drüber, nur jetzt noch nicht. Und das ist so ein bisschen problematisch, weil wir wissen, naja, es ist ja niemand. Also irgendwann ist ja vorbei mit Putin. Die Frage ist nur, wann? Und wir haben auch kein richtiges Ende des Krieges vor Augen. Also geht das jetzt noch drei Jahre so oder was auch immer? Es ist halt völlig unklar. Und wir haben hier eine Einschätzung von Christian Mölling von der Deutschen Gesellschaft für Auswärtige Politik, der in den Tagesthemen noch mal dieses Putin kann nicht gewinnen.
Wir haben zehn Monate oder 300 Tage hinter uns. Die Ukraine hat gezeigt, dass sie militärisch nicht besiegbar ist, dass sie in sehr kurzer Zeit Gelände wieder zurückgewinnen kann. Der Westen hat es in der Hand, es möglich zu machen, dass dieser Krieg sehr schnell zu Ende ist. Und dafür muss er tatsächlich seine Anstrengungen deutlich erhöhen.
Ja, es ist ganz merkwürdig, dass die Geschichte auf der einen Seite schon geschrieben ist. Also die Alternativen werden immer weniger.
Außer die Eskalation.
Genau, es kann nur noch der Krieg eskaliert werden. Aber es gibt jetzt kein Szenario mehr, in dem Putin irgendwie militärisch gewinnt. Es gibt kein richtiges Szenario, in dem Putin den ganzen Kriegsstatus politisch zurückdreht und sagt, ich bin aber immer noch Präsident. Weil dann müsste er eine Niederlage eingestehen.
Und das ist ja auch kaum zu machen. Ja, genau, das wird da nicht hinführen. Aber es wird auch nicht einen Maximal-Sieg des Westens geben können. Zumindest nicht in der Konstellation oder ohne in der Eskalation. Wie soll das sein?
Genau, das einzige, was wir jetzt anhaltspunkt haben, ist jetzt zum Jahreswechsel. Putin steht halt noch vor den Soldaten, macht seine Jahresendarmee-interne Pressekonferenz vor 15.000 Offizieren und verspricht ihnen einfach das Blaue vom Himmel.
Immer im Dezember trifft sich die militärische Elite Russlands, um Bilanz zu ziehen und um aufs kommende Jahr zu blicken. Eigentlich ein Termin, um die Stärke der eigenen Streitkräfte zu feiern. Doch dieses Jahr steht Putins Armee unter Druck. Der Präsident sieht sich vor 15.000 teils zugeschalteten Offizieren genötigt klarzustellen, wozu Russland in der Lage ist.
Alles, was der Kämpfer braucht, muss modern, bequem und zuverlässig sein.
Es gibt keine Beschränkungen bei der Finanzierung der Armee. Alles, worum die Armee bittet, wird sie bekommen.
Alles, was die Armee braucht, wird sie bekommen.
Die Show ist auch zackhaft, also wenn wir jetzt mal die Shows miteinander vergleichen, dann sehen wir hier trübsinnig dreinblickende Militärs, die zackhaft applaudieren, weil sie es müssen.
Ja, genau. Also es ist ein ganz trauriges Bild, so euphorisiert die Gegenseite ihrer Show da durchzieht in den Podcasts und so. Hier haben wir dieses einfach im Vorzeichen umgedrehte, aber als Show genauso ausgeprägte Veranstaltung. Und der Deutschlandfunk wollte eigentlich mit Melnick sprechen. Der hat aber in der Nacht dann irgendwie abgesagt, jetzt vor ein paar Tagen. Also haben sie irgendwen angerufen. Jürgen Hart von der CDU. Ich kenne ihn gar nicht. Wahrscheinlich auch so ein verteidigungspolitischer Sprecher jedenfalls. Ich habe das so das erste Mal hier gehört. Der Deutschlandfunk kam dann in seiner eigenen Berichterstattung immer mal wieder darauf zurück, dass das ja so gesagt wurde. Sozusagen die ersten Regungen aus dem deutschen Parlament zum Thema. Wie sieht denn jetzt so ein Ende des Krieges aus?
Man stellte sich vor, die Ukraine und auch der Westen würde sagen, Putin ist der führende Kriegsverbrecher. Mit dem können wir doch jetzt nicht über einen Frieden verhandeln. Und umgekehrt weiß Russland, in dem Augenblick, wo es Russland selbst sich des Problems Putin entledigt und dann sozusagen jemanden hat, auf den die gesamte Schuld und Verantwortung für diesen Angriffskrieg geschoben werden kann, dann wäre natürlich die Verhandlungsposition Russlands einer anderen in Friedensverhandlung. Und ich glaube, das weiß Putin auch. Und deswegen hat er selbst überhaupt kein Interesse daran, dass es zu ernsthaften Friedensverhandlungen kommt.
Das heißt, solange mir Putin an der Macht ist, kann es keinen Frieden geben?
Ich fürchte, dass das die bittere Wahrheit aus diesem Krieg ist. Ich halte allerdings es durchaus für möglich, dass man auch in Moskau dieses Problem sieht und dass man in dem Augenblick, wo man feststellt, dass man in einer Sackgasse ohne Ausweg sich befindet, dass man dann schon auch die Überlegungen anstellen muss, gibt es vielleicht jemand anderen in Moskau, der an der Stelle Putins und sozusagen als der Nachfolger Putins in solche Verhandlungen eintreten kann.
Ich halte das für sehr gefährlich, was hier artikuliert wird. Denn das ist dann so, dass wir auf jeden Fall noch zehn Jahre damit rechnen können, wenn jetzt Putin nicht umfällt. Und dass sich da etwas in Moskau bildet, das dann Putin ablöst, ist ja Wunschdenken. Und eigentlich wird hier ein jeder noch mal auf die Spur gebracht, lange jetzt durchzuhalten. Auch wir sollen durchhalten. In dem Sinne, dass wir sagen, ja, es ist halt alles sehr schwierig, aber wir leben jetzt in nicht friedlichen Zeiten, in Kriegszeiten und das für die nächsten zehn Jahre. Aber was erwartet man auch? Also, ich meine, eine Friedensverhandlung kann sicherlich nicht dazu führen, dass man Putin danach schickt. Das wird nicht passieren. Also das ist alles, jetzt werden manche Leute sagen, oh, das ist aber zynisch und da müsste man doch, die Weltpolitik, die Lage ist eine andere. Man hat auch nicht die Macht und das ist auch deshalb nicht vergleichbar mit 45, weil wir da eine ganz andere Konstellation hatten und wir haben es hier mit nuklearen Mächten zu tun. Und die geben nicht auf und sagen, ja, dann schicken wir jetzt den Putin nach Den Haag und dann könnt ihr mal gucken, was ihr mit denen dort macht. Das ist ja kein kleiner Schurkenstadt. Man muss das immer wieder herausstellen. Und ich glaube, dass auch generell diese ganzen Äußerungen, das geht doch lange so weiter und da dürfen wir nicht und so in der deutschen Bevölkerung auch für eine enorme Unruhe sorgen und auch für enorme Ängste, die dann bisweilen irrational sein mögen. Aber wir haben es, glaube ich, schon mit einem Klima der Angst jetzt inzwischen zu tun, was ich an einer Sache illustrieren will, nämlich es gibt ja diese große Angst, dass wir bald keinen Strom mehr haben, dass wir ein Blackout erleben, einmal weil vielleicht nicht genug geliefert wurde oder weil es irgendeinen Anschlag oder was auch immer gab. Also man hat diese Fantasie, dass man bürgerkriegsähnlichen Zuständen entgegengeht. Und mein Vater wies mich darauf hin, dass in Supermarktprospekten jetzt ständig geworben wird für irgendwelche Stromgeneratoren. Ich habe hier eine Seite aus dem Aldi-Prospekt. Hier wird geworben, deine mobile Stromversorgung, Diesel-Stromgenerator. Und dieser kostet 1799 Euro, ist reduziert. Den kann man hier kaufen, 4-Takt-Diesel-Motor. Und wenn so etwas selbst in einem Aldi-Prospekt drin ist, 1799 Euro, dann sieht man, wie groß die Angst noch ist. Und das ist hier irgendwo zwischen Fitnessgeräte und Thermometer, wird dann auch noch sowas angeboten. Das hat man vorher nie gesehen.
Also wir haben ja dies Jahr auch von der Stadt Frankfurt aus eine Botschaft an die Bevölkerung doch vorzusorgen. Für den Fall, dass hier immer sieben Tage lang nichts funktioniert, wo ich mir auch denke, ihr könnt sechs Stunden Strom also Blackout machen oder so. Wir hatten letztens auch so einen zehn Minuten Stromausfall. Aber danach ist keine Ahnung, ob man dann noch eine Nudel zu Hause hat oder so, die man essen kann, ist dann auch egal. Also es ist auch so ein bisschen, wir sind jetzt auch ein bisschen in Gottes Händen, wenn es tatsächlich zu solchen Szenarien kommt, die wir uns alle nicht vorstellen können.
Deswegen braucht man eigentlich jetzt einen friedensethischen Diskurs. Man braucht einen diplomatischen Diskurs und das heißt ja nicht, dass man irgendwelche albernen Zugeständnisse macht, wo man sagt, das geht nun wirklich nicht. Aber wenn wir jetzt an dem Punkt schon angelangt sind, also wir waren mal an dem Punkt, dass man sagte, alles was Putin erobert hat während dieses Krieges, das darf er nicht behalten, das wäre eine Grundlage. Dann hat man gesagt, naja die Krim soll eigentlich auch noch zurück. Jetzt sagt man, eigentlich ist die Grundlage, dass Putin schon gar nicht mehr da ist.
Und dass die Russen auch noch das Den Haag-Ding unterschreiben, also sich ausliefern.
Und die Russen sich danach am besten eine Demokratie verschaffen, wie wir sie genau gerne hätten. Dann kann man sagen, dann will man offenbar den ewigen Krieg. Also das kann nicht sein. Und das hat auch nichts mit Moral oder sonst was mehr zu tun. Das ist einfach ein fürchterliches, kriegstreiberisches Karkül, wenn man diese Maximalforderung stellt. Denn die kann es ja nicht geben. Das ist ja vollkommen logisch.
Genau. Und deswegen beschäftigen wir uns jetzt nochmal in wenigen Clips mit, sagen wir mal, dem Jahr 2023. Was ist zu erwarten, wenn auch erstmal kein Ende in Aussicht ist? Falls ihr euch fragt im Hintergrund, es wird hier schon geböllert in Frankfurt. Aber ich glaube, das ist noch zu vertragen. Jürgen Hart nochmal mit einer weiteren Anmerkung, von der ich mir auch denke, das ist bestimmt nicht so richtig abgesprochen mit der Partei vor, sondern es ist einfach so, 23 Uhr hat man ihn nochmal erreicht, um ihn einfach Fragen zu stellen und er gibt Antworten.
In dem Augenblick, wo Russland Angriffe auf die ukrainische Zivilbevölkerung mit Drohnen startet, ist es im Übrigen ein legitimes Kriegsziel. Wäre es ein legitimes Kriegsziel für die Ukraine, die Basen zu treffen, von denen aus diese Angriffe durchgeführt werden?
Also dann führt man den Krieg gegen Russland mit dann den Waffen aus Europa und USA. Naja.
Das ist heikel. Selensky hat auch die Frage bekommen im Weißen Haus, wie könnte ein Ende des Krieges aussehen?
So, Mr. Biden, Mr. Selensky, could you share your vision? And how do you understand this word fair peace?
So, haaa... So, er spricht beide an, Herr Biden, Herr Selensky. Wie könnte ein faires Ende des Krieges aussehen? Wir hören uns jetzt eine Minute lang an, wie Selensky darauf antwortet. Er wusste, was es für ein Termin ist. Er hat viele Sprüche mitgebracht. Wir haben ja gehört, wie er auch für ein paar Lacher sorgte. Bei dieser Frage allerdings bin ich mir unsicher, ob er überhaupt mal kurz vorher drüber nachgedacht hat.
Es ist eine sehr philosophische Beschreibung. Das ist ja wirklich eine Antwort, das ist unglaublich.
Da steckt keine Antwort drin.
Da steckt keine Antwort drin. Und dann weiß er auch selbst nach 30 Sekunden nicht mehr weiter und sagt dann, ich bin ja ein Vater von Kindern, da könnte man noch mal so eine Emotionalisierungsstrategie machen wie ein Avatar 2.
Ich habe ihn noch nicht gesehen, aber ich kann mir ungefähr vorstellen.
So geht es auch. Denn der Kinderwegen kann man jeden Krieg rechtfertigen.
Genau, und die Frage ging ja auch an Biden. Also hören wir uns das Finale von Selenskys Antwort an und dann Bidens Ergänzung.
Also diese Inhumane, würde ich sagen.
Ich teile ihre Vision. Ja, das war eine Minute Gestammel, muss man leider sagen. Das ist schon brenzlig. Schließen wir also mit dem letzten Clip. Welches Szenario hat, oder was droht uns denn jetzt? Und in welchen Kategorien müssen wir denken? Auf welcher Ebene wird denn jetzt über Ende verhandelt, Strategien entworfen, Pläne gemacht und umgesetzt? Biden gibt uns dieses Angebot.
Es geht um jemanden, der sich in den Augen sieht. Und ich meine es ehrlich. Ich glaube nicht, dass es einen, einen, einen Zufall für jemanden gibt, der sich mit einem Freund oder einem Fohlen face-to-face befindet und ihn in den Augen sieht. Wir haben das mehr als einmal gemacht. Wir werden es immer weiter tun. Und Putin geht immer weiter nach zivilisierten Zielen. Und Frauen und Kinder, Orphanen. Dieser Typ ist... Aber er wird verfallen. Und er wird verfallen. Er hat bereits verfallen, weil er jetzt weiß, dass er in keinem Fall die Ukraine aufnehmen wird. Und er hat in der Vergangenheit verfallen und es ist sehr wichtig, für ihn und für alle anderen, dass der Präsident Selensky und ich zwei Länder zusammen verbreiten, um sicher zu sein, dass er nicht erzielt. Und ich denke, ich bin vielleicht falsch, aber ich weiß, ich verrate jeden Leader durch die Weise, was sie sagen, ihre Konsistenz und sie sehen in die Augen, dass dieser Mann, der seine Seele ist, wer er sagt, er ist.
Es ist so relativ beängstigend, würde ich sagen, für die Weltlage und dass das so wenig reflektiert wird und auch sich nicht politisch was anderes darum bildet und nicht nur Opposition zur Unterstützung der Ukraine entsteht, sondern Opposition dazu, dass man die Eskalation immer weiterlaufen lässt, ist in meinen Augen höchst bedenklich und man sieht, wie hier auch man entweder maximal Forderungen stellt, die völlig unrealistisch sind oder wir haben es dann mit einem Ausweichen ins Emotionale zu tun. Erst hatten wir die Kinder, jetzt wird der Blickkontakt, der Direkte angesprochen. Ich kann es in seinen Augen sehen. Das erinnert mich daran, als man mal diesen berühmten Türsteher von Bergheim befragte, nach welcher Kategorie er eigentlich vorgeht. Wer darf rein und wer nicht? Was muss man tragen? Jeans oder Shino oder was auch immer? Und dann sagte er so etwas wie, ja, ich will das Leben in den Augen sehen. Das ist seine Kategorie. Also das heißt eigentlich ja völlige Willkür. Und so kann man keine Außenpolitik machen. Das ist einfach nicht denkbar. Das ist auch dann Geschwätz.
Und naja, das ist das Gerede auf der Bühne. Im Hintergrund läuft natürlich.
Anderes und da braucht man auch diese ganze Metaphorik, nicht?
Ja, in der Hinsicht, wir sollten uns darauf einstellen, dass das noch eine Weile geht. Und das zumindest Amerika schon versucht jetzt, die Niederlage Russlands auf die Spitze zu treiben. Gerade Putin noch in so einem langen Du musst entscheiden, wie du auf uns reagierst. Material Schlacht dazu verwickeln. Und das ist ein bisschen heikel wird insgesamt.
Es gab im Bundestag eine Anhörung zum Thema Metaverse Web 3. Die Politik interessiert sich, was haben die Experten dazu zu sagen. Aber, und das ist sehr ungewöhnlich für eine Anhörung, auch andere waren plötzlich sehr daran interessiert, wer wird da eingeladen. Und zwar, ich nenne sie einfach mal der Einfachheit halber, die Bitcoin Bros. waren erzürnt wohl darüber, dass man diese Experten eingeladen hat. Wir hören jetzt hier Jens Zimmermann von der SPD, der darauf Bezug nimmt.
Zunächst, wir haben Post bekommen, der Ausschuss hat viel Post bekommen von entrüsteten Bürgerinnen und Bürgern, dass wir Expertinnen wie sie benannt haben, weil sie das nicht genug hier bejubeln, was alles im Web3 passiert. Können sie sich das erklären?
Ja, natürlich konnte man sich das erklären, wenn man hört, was die einzelnen Experten zu sagen haben. Wir hören uns das jetzt mal an. Zwei Stunden ging das. Ein paar Clips habe ich mitgebracht. Malte Engeler war dort. Er ist Jurist und er hat sich mit dem Eigentum, mit dem Recht auf Vergessen, mit all diesen Fragen beschäftigt. Und wir hören jetzt erst mal diese Sache mit dem Recht auf Vergessen.
Dieses Recht auf Vergessenwerden geht unter anderem auf ein Urteil des EGH, außerzeit noch vor der DSGVO zurück, wo der EGH die spanische Google-Niederlassung dazu verurteilte, Suchtreffer zu löschen, die erkennbar machten, dass ein Geschäftsmann vor Jahren in einer Insolvenz hing. Rechtspolitisch ist dieses Recht auf Vergessenwerden ungeheuer wichtig, weil wir uns als Gesellschaft darauf geeinigt haben, dass alle Menschen eine zweite Chance verdienen, einfach weil die Menschen würde das gebietet. Demgegenüber steht jetzt die Blockchain, eine Technologie, deren zentrales Feature es ist, dass ich nur Einträge ergänzen kann, aber keine alten löschen kann, jedenfalls nicht, um die ganze Datenbank zu zerstören. Da anschutzrechtlich ist die Blockchain also grundsätzlich inkompatibel mit der DSGVO.
Ja, aber das ist ja so nicht gemeint. Das Recht auf vergessen, also dieses BGH-Urteil damals, da ging es ja ganz gezielt nur um Google und andere Weitervertreiber von Informationen, nicht um die Ursprungsquelle, wie zum Beispiel diese spanische Zeitung, die in den Berichter stattfand.
Ich bin nicht sicher.
Da bin ich mir sehr sicher, wir haben das damals sehr ausführlich.
Aber Zeitungen werden jetzt zum Beispiel auch belangt, wenn sie die Archive nicht löschen. Also es ist ja zum Beispiel so, nehmen wir mal an, dich wird jetzt keiner kennen und du hättest mal ein Unternehmen gegen die Wand gefahren und hättest vielleicht da noch einen kleinen Korruptionsdelikt und da gäbe es einmal in der Lokalpresse einen Artikel zu gegeben. Und jetzt kann es ja passieren, dass du danach immer eine weiße Weste hast und was weiß ich tust und dann dich irgendwo bewirbst. Man googelt deinen Namen und das ist das Erste, was man finden wird, da du sonst nicht präsent im Netz bist, ist ach, da korrupt, da gab es da diese Geschichte. Und da gibt es dieses Recht auch vergessen und dagegen wird auch dann geklagt und dann kommen da zum Beispiel auch Zeitungen demnach. Also das weiß ich von Online-Redaktionen, die dann auch das e-Paper zur Not schwärzen.
Die DSGVO hat ja sozusagen die Persönlichkeitsrechte, die am Datenschutzrecht mit sozusagen ausgearbeitet werden, ausgewirkt werden können, schon in dieses moderne Zeitalter geholt. Das stimmt, da hat man diese Rechte.
Das ist bei der Blockchain alles nicht mehr möglich, ne?
Aber dieses EUGH-Urteil, was er eben nannte, das hatte eben diesen anderen Charakter. Da ging es darum, wenn ich mich für jemanden interessiere, aber eigentlich gar keine Lust habe zu recherchieren und so, dann trage ich das bei Google kurz den Namen ein und kriege als allererstes diesen zehn Jahre alten Artikel. Und da baut eben Google über die Auflistung der Suchergebnisse ein Profil einer Person zusammen, die das Recht darauf hat, andere Sachen in den Vordergrund stellen zu dürfen. Hatte aber ausdrücklich keinen Effekt damals auf die Berichterstattung selbst, gilt aber wie gesagt dann auch nur, wenn sozusagen ein öffentliches Interesse da ist. Die DSGVO klärt ja sozusagen alle Fälle der digitalen Datenverarbeitung. Da würde ich aber auch wieder sagen, dieses Recht am eigenen Bild, Recht auf hier, Recht auf da, das war ja auch vorher, das wurde ja nur durch die DSGVO nochmal so zusammengebaut, dass man weiß, damit kann ich jetzt auch klagen und so, ob da dann so viel Neuerungen mit dazu kamen. Aber stimmt, die Blockchain, es steht dem natürlich gegenüber.
Web3, Metaverse, NFT, das waren die Themen, die dort besprochen wurden. Und dann auch die Frage, wie würde man das strukturieren? Wie würde man das gestalten? Welche Smart Contracts über welche Plattformen? Nun ist es ja so, dass das große Versprechen von Web3 und auch das Metaverse darin liegt, dass man sagt, jetzt gehört dir endlich mal etwas. Ownership, sagte Finn Kliemann mit glänzenden Augen. Oder Julian Bam sagte, ja, dann hast du so ein Zertifikat und das gehört dann auch wirklich dir. Was bedeutet das eigentlich, wenn man jetzt ein Avatar von sich hat und der ist woanders unterwegs, also im Metaverse und zunächst einmal gehört er doch einem? Malte Engler, geht jetzt diesem Eigentumsgedanken einmal nach.
Das Web3 bewirbt als zentrale Errungenschaft die Steigerung der individuellen Souveränität der Nutzenden. Sei es ein Like, auf einen Tweet, ein Kommentar unter einer Insta-Story, ein neuer Avatar mit neuer Frisur. All das wird in der Blockchain mir zugewiesen und steht dann mir zur aufschläglichen Verfügungsgewalt zu. Rechtlich reden wir dabei über Eigentum an personenbezogenen Daten. Meine Daten gehören dann endlich mir und so das Versprechen, nicht mehr in die großen Plattformen. Das Web3 erfasst das Problem also völlig richtig, das wir derzeit haben, nämlich die Konzentration von ökonomischer und politischer Macht in der Hand weniger Digitalkonzerne.
Nun kommt das große Aber.
So verlockend dieses Eigentum an personenbezogenen Daten zunächst klingt, muss man sich allerdings klar machen, was das bedeutet. Es geht im Web3 praktisch darum, dass alle relevanten gesellschaftlichen Vorgänge digital abgebildet werden. Wir sprechen deswegen auch von digitalen Zwillingen samt eines digitalen Körpers in dieser digitalen Welt. Dieser digitale Körper, sowie alle Interaktionen, soll jetzt in einem ersten Schritt mir zur aufschließenden Verfügungsgewalt zugewiesen werden. Eigentum heißt aber auch, dass ich darüber verfügen kann. Mit der Folge, dass das Eigentum dann jemand anderem zusteht, inklusive des Rechts Andere, auch mich als ehemaligen Eigentümer dann davon auszuschließen. Das Ausmaß an Abhängigkeit, das ein Web3 in diesem Sinne ermöglichen würde, ist noch einmal um Potenzen größer als die in der analogen Welt, weil dann ja sogar die Grundlage dessen, was wir zur Teilhabe am digitalen Leben brauchen, unseren digitalen Körper oder Teile davon, nicht mehr mir gehören könnte. Dateneigentum heißt eben nur im ersten Schritt mehr Kontrolle und im zweiten in der Regel auch endgültiger Verlust.
Und all das noch neben den technischen Problemen, die wir damals schon im Metaverse Buch besprochen haben, dass ja irgendwer das operieren muss. Also man kann nicht das Fahrrad ohne die Straße denken. Und in dem Fall geht es nicht nur um das Fahrrad, sondern auch um den Fahrer selbst. Also das eignet ich. Dann verliert man plötzlich seine Nutzungsrechte.
Ja, im Kaufmann von Venedig geht es darum, dass man einen Handel, eine Wette eingeht, sodass man mit dem eigenen Fleisch bezahlt. Also wenn du nicht nachkommen kannst deiner Schuld, wenn du die nicht begleichen kannst, dann kann ich mir zwei Kilo aus deinem Fleisch schneiden. Das ist im Kaufmann von Venedig. Im Prinzip hat man genau dieses Problem jetzt tatsächlich. Im Metaverse. Engler hat da eine Metapher parat.
Um das dystopische Potenzial des Web3 noch mal ganz deutlich zu machen, vielleicht zum Abschluss folgende Metapher. Die Idee des Web3, die Ungleichheit im Digitalen dadurch zu beheben, dass wir unser digitales Leben eigentumsfähig machen, entspricht in etwa der grauenvollen Idee, ein marodes, kaputtgespartes, privatisiertes Gesundheitswesen dadurch zu reparieren, dass wir unsere Organe eigentumsfähig und handelbar machen würden.
Na ja, also wenn man jetzt sagt, wie unser Gesundheitssystem hat ja viele Probleme, die können wir alle benennen. Es wäre gut, wenn jetzt jeder mal das Eigentum an den eigenen Organen hätte und damit wenigstens einen freien Handel machen könnte. Denn dann könnte man seine Leber noch verkaufen oder so. Und das sei eigentlich jetzt die Konstellation, die wir da in der digitalen Welt vorfinden. Jürgen Goethe war zu Gast, genannt Tante bei Twitter. Auf den kommen wir nachher nochmal zurück. Denn wir machen jetzt gerade einen Umweg. Wir gehen in den Kaninchenbau über den Umweg Metaverse Web3. Was ist da eigentlich los? Und er spricht auch dieses Ding an. Na ja, was wurde denn eigentlich bislang erreicht, zum Beispiel mit der Blockchain?
Blockchains sind mit 14 Jahren nur marginal jünger als das iPhone und behaupten immer noch, eine junge Technologie zu sein, die einfach noch Zeit braucht, um Einsatzszenarien zu finden. 14 Jahre, das ist eine digitale Ewigkeit, das sind zwei digitale Ewigkeiten. Blockchain sollten zum Beispiel 2018, als ich auch schon zu diesem Thema hier Experte war, Supplychains revolutionieren und Identitäten abbilden, etc. Nichts davon hat sich eingelöst, nichts davon ist real. Nach 14 Jahren haben die Verfechterinnen nichts vorzuweisen, außer Scams, wie der gerade in den Nachrichten diskutierte FTX-Skandal.
Ist ja eigentlich noch viel schlimmer, es war ja kontraproduktiv. Alle sind in, und das ist ja nun der Anwendungsfall, der noch am ehesten als Erfolgsversprechen galt, Bitcoin, Geld, Werthaltung und so. Und es war ja eigentlich genau gemacht für das Szenario, was ist, wenn mal irgendwo ein Krieg ist und irgendwas fällt aus, dann haben wir ja noch das. Und genau das Szenario jetzt, wo wir Inflation und Zinsen und so weiter eigentlich ein alternatives Geld bräuchten in dieser Prepper-Denke, fällt es aus und verliert komplett so seinen Wert.
Willit Wittmann schließt sich dem an.
Bei den im Web3 eingesetzten Technologien handelt es sich häufig noch um Technologien in einem sehr experimentellen Stadium, allerdings schon seit mehr als 15 Jahren. Es kommt bei Transaktionsplattformen immer im Wochentag zum Abfluss von personenbezogenen Daten und digitalen Gütern. Es ist fraglich, ob diese Technologie diese Phase auch mit entsprechender Regulierung jemals verlassen kann. Dennoch investiert Deutschland in den letzten Jahren eine signifikante Menge an Geld in Projekte auf Blockchain-Basis. Um staatliche Prozesse mit Web-3-Konzepten abzubilden, vor allem im Bereich der digitalen Identitäten. Allein eine Suche nach Blockchain im Förderportal des Bundes findet Förderung mit einer Gesamtsumme von mehr als 65 Millionen Euro. Der deutsche Staat scheint wirklich völlig wahllos alles zu fördern, wo das Wort Blockchain auch nur drin vorkommt.
Ja, aber ohne irgendeinen Erfolg bislang. Und sie erinnert dann an die App-ID-Wallet. Kannst du dich daran überhaupt noch erinnern, die mal für drei Tage verfügbar waren? Da waren wir ja schon mal kurz digitale Bürger. Alles schien so toll zu sein. Sie erinnert daran, wie schief das Ganze gelaufen ist.
Die App-ID-Wallet. Da hat die letzte Bundesregierung im September 2021 für drei Tage uns in Deutschland einen digitalen Personalausweis und einen digitalen Führerschein auf Blockchain-Basis beschert. Der wurde aber sofort wieder eingestellt, weil das Prinzip von Ausweisdokumenten auf einer Blockchain, aus der man bekanntlich nichts löschen kann, in Verbindung mit der Idee, dass man die Ausweisdokumente auf seinem eigenen Smartphone speichert und von dort aus weitergibt, so viele konzeptionelle Sicherheitsprobleme hatte, dass es unverantwortbar war, dieses Projekt weiterzuführen. Hier zeigt sich ein Problem, das wir in der Web-3-Welt auch häufiger beobachten können, nämlich der Schutz von digital signierten Gütern liegt allein in der Verantwortung der Nutzerinnen. Und das führt schon jetzt andauernd zu Problemen. Hardware und Software wird nämlich unsicherer, je älter sie ist. Nicht alle können sich immer die modernste Hardware und Software leisten. Wir hätten also in der Zukunft mit Ausweisen oder anderen digitalen Gütern auf Smartphones der Bürgerinnen das Problem, dass sich reiche Menschen besser vom Diebstahl ihrer digitalen Identitäten schützen können, als Menschen, die vielleicht nicht so viel Geld haben.
Ja, jetzt wo zum dritten Mal der Kras-Communication-Kongress ausfällt, ist ja gut, dass sie das ein bisschen im Bundestag nachgeholt haben.
Ja, in der Tat. Und das ist, finde ich, auch ein sehr wichtiges Punkt, den sie hier anspricht. Wenn sie sagt, man muss ja seine Daten, man muss seine Identität schützen können. Wir wissen, wie schlimm das ist, wenn man seine Identität verliert. Denn wir haben den Film Departed gesehen, wo Leonardo DiCaprio am Ende fleht, seine Identität bitte zurückzubekommen. Und da wird Identität mit dem Faustrecht verteidigt oder geht dabei auch für lustig. Und das haben wir eigentlich, wenn wir diese neue Web-3-Welt haben, dann verfügst du da zwar über irgendetwas, kannst da mit der Blockchain agieren. Aber natürlich gibt es dann ganz viele Akteure, auch kriminelle Akteure, die an deine Identität rankommen. Und das ist ja so, dass wir, wenn wir uns jetzt mal Eigentumsstrukturen in Deutschland ansehen, das Eigentum vom Staat gesichert bekommen. Das heißt, wenn du jetzt ein Haus kaufst, dann musst du da zwar zum Notar, aber dieser Notar erfüllt ja auch die Funktion, dass du nicht mit dem langen Messer da sitzen musst und sagen gut, wenn die mich jetzt versuchen abzuzocken, dann drohe ich denen, dass ich sie absteche, sondern da ist der Notar als Intermediator dazwischen, der das dann alles auf eine rechtliche Ebene, also dafür sorgt, dass die rechtliche Ebene eingehalten wird. Und dann aber mit dem Eigentumstitel ist das ja dir sicher. Das heißt, du musst jetzt nicht hier ein Tresor irgendwo hinstellen, wo du sagst, oh Gott, da muss ich mal drinnen nochmal meinen Brief haben, dass das Haus mir gehört, weil sonst verlier ich vielleicht mein Haus, wenn jemand den Brief hat.
Anders als im Mediensystem haben wir im Rechtssystem den großen Dritten, der dann alles regelt.
Ganz genau. Und man möchte ja diesen großen Dritten loswerden. Dezentralität ist das Stichwort. Dazu kommen wir gleich, ich habe natürlich auch was zu lachen mitgebracht, denn es war ein Professor von einer Bundeswehruni da, Philipp Rauschnabel. Und der stellt sich das mit dem Metaverse eigentlich ganz toll vor. Auch vielleicht ein bisschen Avatar 2.
Ich verstehe unter dem Metaverse die Vision von einem dreidimensionalen Internet, das die Realität und die Gesellschaften in gewisser Weise abbildet, wo wir Zeit verbringen und auf das wir über AR- und VR-Technologien gemeinsam auch als XR-Bezeichnete zugreifen können. Das ist ein großer Unterschied. In den Neunzigeren hat der Satz, ich bin drin, das Internet geprägt. Rückwirkend ist es falsch. Ich bin davor, ist der richtige Begriff. Im Internet surfen wir, oder besser gesagt, wir surfen auf dem Internet. Wir kratzen an der Oberfläche. Im Metaverse werden wir nicht surfen, da werden wir tauchen. Wir sind Teil davon, wir sind im Metaverse drin.
Ach du großer Gott.
Wenn ich vorher die anderen Sachverständigen da höre und dann weiß, das ist mein Beitrag, dann habe ich so einen Motivationsschluss. Entschuldige ich mich nicht, doch. Kurz und komm nicht wieder, oder?
Nee, es geht immer weiter. Wurde auch noch ein paar Mal befragt. Wie könnte es aussehen, zum Beispiel so?
Ein Restaurant Review sehen wir nicht mehr auf unserem Display, sondern das wird auf die Fassade des Restaurants geblendet. Und wir sehen es über AR-Technologien. Das sind viele Möglichkeiten.
Nee, das ist eine Möglichkeit und er nennt auch keine andere. Also er nennt das als Möglichkeit. Wenn wir jetzt gleich das Schnitzel essen brauchen, müssen wir noch in die Speisekarte gucken. Ah nee, wir wissen ja schon, was wir nehmen. Aber sonst könnten wir das auf die Restaurantwand projizieren. Warum auch immer, um da einzutauchen in die Schnitzelwelt. Und das kann aber auch natürlich ein guter Weg sein, um sich zu bilden. Das Internet ist ja schon jetzt ein Ort der Bildung. Und man kann es natürlich mit dem Metaverse noch viel besser gestalten. Hier wird das auch noch mal ausbuchstabiert.
Wir sehen die aber auch im Bildungsbereich. Und jetzt sind wir gerade in Berlin. Man kann sich zum Beispiel in Berlin mal die Berliner Mauer in AR anschauen, genau an der Stelle, wo sie früher war. So eindrucksvoll kann man auf Geschichtsthemen, glaube ich, nicht anders hinweisen, wie über AR-Applikationen. Es gibt Anwendungen, da kann Holocaust-Überlebende vor einem sitzen und berichten, was sie erlebt haben. Das überzeugt eine emotionale Nähe. Das führt dazu, dass ein diese Themen bewegen. Und das ist eine der Stärken von XR. Und dem Metaverse gehe ich davon aus oder wie auch immer es irgendwann heißen wird, werden wir eben viele solche Anwendungen haben und können vor allen Dingen Nähe erstellen, also Distanz überbrücken.
Genau, da haben wir auch dann diese entsprechende Technik. Also erstmal ist es ja ein pädagogisches Konzept, was vollkommen schief ist, dass man glaubt, man muss Nähe in dieser Weise herstellen, dass man glaubt, nahe ist einem nur, was einem ganz groß begegnet. Das ist ja auch das Interessante bei Avatar 2. Das ist technisch beeindruckend, aber der Film kommt einem nicht in dem Sinne nahe. Es ist ja nicht so, dass man immer versuchte, in irgendetwas einzutrauen, sondern mir sagte ein Freund so schön, ich gehe ins Kino, um der Dreidimensionalität zu entkommen, um wirklich mal nur auf der Leinwand zu sehen. Und dann hat man jetzt aber die Dreidimensionalität und zu glauben, dass man irgendetwas über die Mauer oder den Holocaust versteht, weil man das Ganze nahe hat, ist ein Irrglaube. Und dann möchte ich auch nochmal das ein bisschen erden und an die Ausstattung unserer Schulen erinnern, wie die gerade sind. Ich höre von Menschen, auch die Kinder im Kindergarten haben, dass es inzwischen so ist, dass sie dort Toilettenpapier, Taschentücher etc. mitbringen, weil es einfach nicht mehr zur Verfügung steht und die Eltern sich jetzt da selbst organisieren, dass wenigstens die rudimentär benötigten Dinge vorhanden sind. Wir kennen das von Schulen, wo man froh ist, wenn man einen funktionierenden Fernseher auf der Etage hat. Also wovon reden wir jetzt? Was sollen da eigentlich passieren?
Also ich habe gerade die Webseite von Herr Rauschnabel aufgerufen. Das ist ja unglaublich. Was ist denn das für eine...
Also ich bin mir jetzt nicht ganz sicher, aber ich glaube, die CDU hat hineingeladen. Zumindest hat die Dame von der CDU auch die langweinigsten oder uninteressantesten Fragen gestellt. Und ich will sagen, von der AfD kamen klügere Fragen zum Metaverse als von der CDU, um es wirklich ganz deutlich zu sagen. Aber das wollen wir uns gar nicht anführen.
Also dafür, dass das hier im Bundestag so standfand, ist es wirklich, wirklich erschütternd.
Es ist sehr erschütternd.
Das kann nicht die deutsche Expertise sein. So, das ist unglaublich.
Ich hätte noch viele weitere Clips dazu gehabt. Lasse das aber weg, wir gehen wieder zur Ernsthaftigkeit über Molly White, sie ist aus den USA aber nur zugeschaltet und spricht mal über diese Idee der Dezentralisierung.
Blockchain-Advocates typically point to decentralization as an advantage of blockchain-based technologies, but they tend to gloss over the incredibly important distinction between network decentralization and the decentralization of power. Decentralization of power is not something that is meaningfully improved in many blockchain-based products.
Wenn die Blockchain Geschichte jetzt 14 Jahre ist, wie sie eben sagten, dann wissen wir doch seit der Hälfte der Zeit, dass am Ende die Mainer auch durchmonopolisiert werden. Und am Ende, klar, müssen dann alle zustimmen, aber wenn 51 Prozent der Mainer drei verschiedene Unternehmen sind, dann machen die halt unter sich aus, wie es weitergeht. Also das ist ja sehr gut, dass ihr da nochmal drauf hinweist.
Dann war Herr Siegele von The Economist auch zugeschaltet, der keine besonders interessanten Sachen gesagt hat. Wir hören aber etwas, was er glaubt, in Mastodon auch zu erkennen.
Und ich wollte auch noch darauf hinweisen, dass es natürlich vor diesem ganzen Kryptowahnsinn Versuche gab, das zu machen. Die gibt es teilweise auch noch, Mastodon, Falcoin und so weiter. Also Dezentralisierungsprojekte, die vielleicht nicht so kommerziell sind und die vielleicht sinnvoller sind.
Er versucht jetzt hier Mastodon mit in diese Web-3-Geschichte einzuspeisen. Da widerspricht Engelhardt. Zunächst einmal macht er noch mal diese feudale Komponente deutlich.
Im Grunde eine Art Abbild unserer analogen Welt ins Digitale, nur eben mit dem Unterschied, dass wir im Analogen uns alle darauf geeinigt haben, dass unser Körper nicht eigentumsfähig ist. Das ist jedenfalls nach der Abschüttelung feudaler Lebensverhältnisse Konsens. Im Web3 würden wir das quasi, was wir im Analogen erwunden haben, im Digitalen neu schaffen. Nämlich so etwas wie eine Möglichkeit einer digitalen Leibeigenschaft. Etwas, was offensichtlich in einer digitalisierten Welt hochgartig problematisch wäre.
Und in diesem Ethereum-Paper führt er dann noch länger aus, ist das auch daraufhin angelegt? Und dann zum Schluss?
Und das ist übrigens auch der Grund, weswegen ich es eine sehr freche Vereinnahmung, freundlich formuliert, empfinde, wenn Herr Siegle davon spricht, dass Mastodon irgendwas mit Web3 zu tun hat. Das ist offensichtlich nicht der Fall.
Nee, Mastodon fühlt sich ja an wie Web 1.0 irgendwie.
Ja, aber Mastodon ist natürlich ein interessanter Punkt, inwieweit man so eine Dezentralisierung herstellen kann, inwieweit man ohne diesen einen großen Intermediär auskommen kann. Wir haben uns mit dieser Mastodonsache hier noch nicht näher beschäftigt. Mastodon wächst etwas, aber es ist keineswegs so, als würde es Twitter ablösen. Ich gehe auch ehrlich gesagt nicht davon aus. Dennoch ist es, glaube ich, sehr gut, wenn dort Leute, die sich wirklich auskennen mit der Thematik, also nicht irgendwelche Schwätzer, wie ich einer bin, sondern wirklich Leute, die auch programmieren können, so sich damit auseinanderzusetzen, ist wichtig, denn ich denke, man braucht diese anderen Plattformen, aber das wird auch ohne eine große finanzielle Hilfe ja nie vonstatten gehen. Also man könnte das natürlich... Also wie will man diese ganze Arbeitszeit, die man benötigt, um ein gut funktionierendes Alternativsystem aufzubauen, wie will man die entgelten?
Also das hat er in Metaverse im Buch, wer hat es noch mal geschrieben? Ah, Matthew Ball, genau. Der hat es ja auch beschrieben. Das bisherige Internet wurde von Pionieren erschaffen und dieses Metaverse kommt jetzt von den Leuten, die die Milliarden eingeheimst haben, also dieses Entwickler, die Entwicklerkapazität und das Potenzial haben. Das sind dann eben vor allem Microsoft, Apple, mal gucken, Facebook, die all in gehen. Das Mastodon, also bei dem, was man wirklich braucht, könnte man ja sagen, da spielt dann Mastodon doch schon eine Rolle, weil am Ende gibt es ja viele, die so kleine Publikationen haben. Was weiß ich, Ursula von der Leyen macht ja mittlerweile auch, gibt ja alles per Twitter bekannt und so. Das könnte man ja genau so gut per Mastodon machen. Mastodon ist dahingehend gar nicht viel mehr als, keine Ahnung, diese WordPress-Welle vor 15 Jahren mit RSS-Feeds. Und dann publiziert man halt nur die Überschriften oder so, um die Textlängen knapp zu halten. Also in der Ansicht könnte ich mir schon vorstellen, dass wir dieses ganze Metaverse-Theater haben, aber dann, wenn es drauf ankommt, doch kurz beim Mastodon nachlesen, was so Sache ist, weil dort entsprechend publiziert wird. Und das muss ja auch gar nicht kompliziert sein. Da kann ja wirklich jeder seine eigene kleine Instanz betreiben. Es wird halt zentral irgendwie Open Source. Also könnte man ja wie WordPress auch das einfach weiterentwickeln. Jeder, der was beisteuern will, steuert irgendwie was bei. Und dann hat man das halt. Aber ich finde es auch komisch, dass da überhaupt eine Rolle spielt, der Mastodon, weil das hat ja nun mit Metaverse gerade weil gar nichts zu tun.
Ja, also die Expertenrunde war zum einen sehr gut besetzt, zum anderen war sie doch ein bisschen nachher desolat und das hat nicht allzu viel gefuchtet. Aber Jens Zimmermann stellt die entscheidende Frage, die uns überleitet zum eigentlichen Thema.
Aber meine Frage wäre da noch mal hinsichtlich dieser ganzen Web3-Geschichte, ist es aus Ihrer Sicht eigentlich ein technologisches oder eigentlich eher ein ideologisches Projekt?
Und damit sind wir im Reich der Ideologie schon angekommen, denn wir können sagen, ja, es ist selbstverständlich auch ein ideologisches Projekt oder vielleicht sogar primär ein ideologisches Projekt. Aber es gibt ganz viele dieser ideologischen Projekte, die zugleich erst einmal rein technisch auftreten. Hast du schon mal von Urbid gehört?
Nein, wie Urbid, aber mit U oder was?
Genau, wie Urbid nur mit U. Und dieses Urbid kannte ich auch nicht. Als ich Theresia Enzensberger traf, als Tilo und ich mit ihr einen Auftritt hatten in Essen, da fragte sie mich im Nachhinein, was ich eigentlich zu Urbid sage. Und ich sagte, was soll denn das eigentlich sein? Also habe ich mir gesagt, damit muss man sich doch näher beschäftigen. Und Theresia Enzensberger schickte mir auch ein paar Links, die mich da weiterführen sollen. Man fällt in einen Kaninchenbau und man kann immer weiter fallen und weiterfallen und fallen. Und Tante, der auch hier in diesem Ausschuss ausgehört hat, der twitterte vor einer Weile über einen Post, der zu Urbid war, was Urbid so alles machen kann. Absolutely true, Urbid look kinda interesting in the fuck is this kind of way, but falls apart as soon as you look at it through the lens of human use cases. Was hat es damit aus? Urbid ist ein dezentralisiertes Netzwerk. Dabei sind zwei Komponenten wichtig. Einmal die Urbid ID, eine Art Benutzernahme, also die permanent ist und die dann dem jeweiligen Nutzer gehört. Und die Urbid ID benennt den eigenen Planeten im Netzwerk. Denn da hast du einen Planeten. Es geht nicht nur um heute, träumen wir vielleicht immer eine eigene Wohnung zu haben. Hier gibt es eigene Planeten. Ein Planet, es kann aber nur maximal vier Milliarden von diesen Planeten geben. Ein Planet ist ein Adressraum und der ist aber auch ein Stück ein virtuelles Land. Wir versuchen uns dem mal langsam zu nähern, nehmen uns einfach mal so ein Clip aus einem Image Video von Urbid anhören.
Ich habe jetzt gerade die Webseite hier urbid.org, keine Ahnung, wie das mit einem zusammenhängt. Ich verstehe nichts von dem, was ich verstehe.
Ich verstehe es auch nicht und ich kann auch sagen, ich werde jetzt für große Verwirrung hier sorgen. Aber warum beschäftigen wir jetzt überhaupt uns damit? Warum fragt Theresa mich, ob ich das kennen würde? Nun, Peter Thiel hängt mit da drin. Die Neo-Reaktionären in den USA, absurd sich gebahrende Republikaner, eine intellektuelle, relativ gelangweilte Elite in New York und in Beverly Hills. Es gibt Konferenzen, wo sie sagen, wir könnten vielleicht auch mal darüber nachdenken, ob die Monarchie nicht eigentlich die beste Regierungsform für uns wäre. Das heißt, es geht jetzt hier ganz viel durcheinander. Es werden literarische Fiktionen rezipiert und überlegt, ob man sie umwandeln kann in Programme, die dann die Welt programmieren. Das heißt, wir gehen jetzt richtig rein in einen Kaninchenbau, der sich anti-intellektuell und intellektualistisch zugleich gibt.
Was für mich schon mal bedeutet, wenn mich jemand fragt, wie ich das finde, sage ich schon mal gut, ich bin dabei. Und mal gucken, ob ich jetzt meine Meinung ändere.
Wir hören mal rein.
Und wenn Adressen finit sind, haben Spammer nowhere zu schicken.
Urbit ist eine semi-dezentralisierte Netzung.
Warum braucht man einen persönlichen Server? Ein Unix-Server ist ein Hauptframe für die Big Data von allen anderen.
James Dusterberg hat für The Point Mac einen ausführlichen Artikel über Urbit geschrieben. Da heißt es, wenn es schon nicht einfach ist, bei Urbit einzusteigen, so ist es konzeptionell als Projekt vielleicht noch schwieriger. Das Unternehmen, das es aufbaut, namens Tlon, finanziert die Entwicklung des Netzwerks durch den Verkauf von einzigartigem, tokenisiertem Adressraum. Ein oft gehörter Slogan lautet, wenn Bitcoin digitales Geld ist und Ethereum digitales Recht, dann ist Urbit digitales Land. Aber Urbit war schon in der Entwicklung, bevor das Bitcoin White Paper veröffentlicht wurde. Und sein Ursprung liegt nicht in der aktuellen Welt des Web3 und dieser Dezentralisierungsbemühungen, sondern im ersten Dotcom-Boom. Im Jahr 1994 brach Curtis Jarvin, der spätere Gründer von Urbit, sein Informatik-Doktor-Studium an der UC Berkeley ab, um im Silicon Valley sein Glück zu finden. Nun wissen wir also schon, das geht weit zurück. Wir haben hier schon eine wichtige Gestalt gehört, Curtis Jarvin, zu dem kommen wir noch einmal zurück.
Und wir haben schon gehört, wir haben es da mit einem Unternehmen zu tun, das nochmal dahinter steht, URBIT, und das ist TLON. TLON, also geschrieben T-L-O-N. Oder im Deutschen würde man sagen TLON, denn es gibt eine Erzählung von Jorge Luis Borges, worauf sich diese Firma gründet, in dem, was sie da eigentlich vorholt. Aber dazu kommen wir gleich noch. Wir sind also nach wie vor sehr verwirrt und hören nochmal ein Image-Video. Diesmal ist das eines, das schon sechs Jahre alt ist.
Und Erbit ist komplett open source und patentfrei. Erbit als Werkzeug ist ein Personal-Cloud-Server. Ein Personal-Server ist eine komplette Redesignung der Cloud-User-Ausgabe. Du wirst deine eigenen Daten, Code und Identität und kontrollierst sie. Wir denken, dass Personal-Server nicht ein praktisches Produkt ist, wenn es ein Personal-Linux-Server auf der öffentlichen Internet ist. Meine Eltern sind nicht Linux-System-Administrator.
Wie das immer bei solchen Projekten ist, kann man fast nichts nutzen. Alles ist noch in der Entwicklungsphase und das schon wahnsinnig lang.
Also, dass es von 94 ist, ich kann das alles gut nachvollziehen. Manche, so wie ich, kennen ja dieses Gefühl, man kann so Sachen im Internet machen, dann holt man sich erst mal seine eigene Domain. Man will es ja selber machen. Dann holt man sich so ein Web-Space, denkt sich, brauche ich nicht eigentlich einen ganzen Server. Dann kauft man sich einen viel zu teuren Server. Dann hat man einen ganzen Server, dann kann man alles drauf machen. Irgendwann landet man aber doch wieder bei seinem Twitter-Profil. Nutzt dann doch lieber die Clouds, die so corporate-mäßig angeboten werden, weil man dann so ein bisschen sicher ist, dass sie auch funktionieren. Aber der Drang ist doch immer da. Und das scheint hier irgendwie bedient zu werden.
Ganz richtig. Wir kommen zu dieser Sache, dass man das doch selbst gerne in den eigenen Händen hätte. Kommen wir nochmal zurück, denn da ist natürlich auch eine politische Komponente mit verbunden. Auch hier geht es schon darum, dass man so etwas wie eine Verfassung braucht. Wir hören nochmal was von Urbitt selbst.
Und in Tlan haben wir realisiert, dass ein Netzwerk im Jahr 2016 nicht unverwundet durch eine unbekannte Kooperation gewährleistet werden kann. Wir haben eine Stiftungskonstitution für diese Republik geschrieben und ein fünftes Adress-Spacen gesetzt, um es permanent zu finanzieren.
Diese liberalen Träume.
Man könnte dem ja das Gedicht von John Donne entgegenhalten, das 400 Jahre alt. Es ist aber der Libertäre-Versuch, sich ganz rauszulösen, schaffe ich es ohne Gesellschaft? Ja, wenn ich dann eine Community um mich aufbaue. Also das ist einfach nur ein Austauschen. Die wollen nicht diese anonyme Gesellschaft, die ja viele Vorteile mit sich bringt. Eigentlich auch, dass man sagt, gut, wir sind zwar nicht politisch einer Meinung, aber wir dürfen trotzdem beide auf Twitter sein, solange wir nicht irgendwelche Grenzen total überschreiten. Aber hier geht es dann wiederum so eine Community-Bildung.
Das ist ja dieses, komm ins Kliemannsland, verwirkliche dich selbst.
Ja, unter meiner Ägide aber bitte.
Vor meinem Publikum, finde dein Selbst vor meinem Publikum.
Ja, Düsterberg schreibt, im Moment gibt es jedoch nur wenige Anwendungen, die auf Orbit laufen können und funktionell ähnelt es nichts weiter als einem einfachen Messaging-Service mit höchstens ein paar tausend aktiven Benutzern. Als ich mich einloggte, fühlte ich mich in die Usenet-Chatrooms der 90er Jahre zurückversetzt. Und in der Tat schienen die Diskussionsthemen auf charmante Weise ähnlich. Gewichtheben, Akte X, okkulte Schriften, Lieblingsmusik, coole Turnschuhe. Wir hören Theodore Blackman von Tlon jetzt.
Es ist ein Umfeld, in dem eine Applikation runnt.
Peer-to-peer-Applikationen.
Auf gut deutscher Weise selbst nicht so richtig.
Ja, ich gucke ja gerade wieder Person of Interest, weil sie es anbietet. Amazon stellt damit Werbung und Erbrechen zur Verfügung. Das verstehe ich auch alles nicht. Aber da schwingt ja, und es beginnt einem ja ganz häufig immer wieder mit, dass man diese Virtualisierung von Software mal so richtig weit treibt, nämlich gar keine Rücksicht mehr auf den Computer nimmt. Hauptsache irgendwas mit Silicate und so. Hauptsache es macht irgendwas, ob es am Ende auf der Kaffeemaschine läuft oder im ICE oder auf dem Smartphone oder wo auch immer. Und das ist ja auch dieses Bild, was Jonathan Nolan da von dieser Bewachungssoftware macht, dass die am Ende aus ihrem Containment ausbricht und sich dann einfach im Internet so breit macht, so wie Skynet und so weiter. Es ist mir egal, welche Computer. Hauptsache sind halt so Computer. Es gibt ja viele Computer. Es gibt WLAN. Also breiten wir uns so aus. Und ich glaube, hier werden einfach alle Wünsche, die man so hat, mal so reingebracht. Ich hätte gerne eine Software, die ich selber bedienen kann, aber die überall läuft und nur ich und mein Admin-Passwort. Alles andere ist sozusagen Cloud, alles austauschbar, alles geht überall und so. Also in deren Sicht als Szenario finde ich schon witzig, vor allem weil er auch gar nicht so richtig drüber reden kann, was er da macht.
Also je mehr man liest und hört dazu, ist es eine große Verwirrung. Es gibt ein paar gute Artikel, also dieser James Dusterberg, das kann ich sehr empfehlen. Aber gehen wir mal zu diesen Ursprüngen, denn man kann ja mit einer literarischen Referenz vielleicht doch weiterkommen. Tlon heißt das Unternehmen und es gibt eine Erzählung von Jorge Luis Borges, die heißt Tlon, uqba orbis teatius. Was ist damit jetzt gemeint? Borges, 1899 in Buenos Aires geboren, war ein Büchermensch, der früh erblindete, aber dann Leiter der Nationalbibliothek wurde. Was eine gewisse Paradoxie natürlich bedeutet, aber das war auch für Borges natürlich dann eine Innenschau, die er halten konnte und er hatte die Geschichten im Kopf. Und er war nach wie vor jemand, der sich viel vorlesen ließ. Und der hat sehr interessante, rätselhafte Geschichten geschrieben, nicht mehr im Sinne von ich muss mal einen großen Roman verfassen, sondern kurze Geschichten, die sich auf etwas beziehen, was es entweder gibt oder was gar nicht da ist. Und diese Geschichte Tlön, Ukbar, Orbis, Tertius, diese erzählt davon, dass es da ein Land gibt, nämlich Ukbar. Und man erlebt jetzt hier zwei Forscher, die darüber diskutieren, wo das liegt. Und man denkt erst, das könnte wohl eine Region irgendwo im Irak sein. Es gibt einen Eintrag in einem Lexikon dazu, in einer Enzyklopädie zu diesem Ukbar. Aber es gibt nur dieses eine Exemplar dieses Lexikons. Und es gibt auch in keinem anderen Lexikon, in keiner anderen Bibliothek, irgendeinen Hinweis darauf, dass es diese Region überhaupt geben kann. Was ist da also los? Es spinnt sich dann fort, dass irgendwann eine große, andere Lexikon-Reihe auftaucht. Diese behandelt nur dieses Land, dieses ferne Land. Und schildert die Sprache, schildert die Gewohnheiten dort, die Struktur, die Geografie. Es gibt also eine Enzyklopädie über etwas, von dem man gar nicht weiß, ob es das gibt. Dann wird das immer so fortgesetzt. Man vermutet, dass diese Brave New World, das Werk einer Geheimgesellschaft von Astronomen, Biologen, Ingenieuren, Metaphysikern, Dichtern, Chemikern, Algeprarikern, Moralisten, Malern und Geometern ist, geleitet von einem unbekannten Genie. Individuen, die diese verschiedenen Disziplinen beherrschen, gibt es zwar in Menge, nicht aber Erfindungsbegabte und noch weniger, die fähig wären, die Erfindung einem strengen systematischen Plan unterzuordnen. Dieser Plan ist so weit gespannt, dass der Beitrag jedes einzelnen Autors verschwindend klein ist. Anfangs war man der Ansicht, Tlön sei ein bloßes Chaos, eine unverantwortliche, ausgebotene Fantasie. Heute weiß man, dass es ein Kosmos ist und dass die verborgenen Gesetze, die ihn lenken, wenn auch nur provisorisch formuliert worden sind. Das heißt, man hat jetzt Tlön beschrieben in einer mehrbändigen Enzyklopädie und man geht davon aus, dass die klügsten Köpfe sich zusammengesetzt haben, um ein fiktives Land mit einem funktionierenden System zu entwerfen. Nun ist die Pointe aber die folgende. Wie ist es jetzt mit dieser Fiktion und was bedeutet sie für unsere Realität? Also bislang haben wir nur ein paar Berichte über dieses Tlön. Und dann heißt es aber weiter, dass offenbar immer wieder, also wir sind dann in den 40er Jahren des 20. Jahrhunderts, Gegenstände auftauchen, die nicht von dieser Welt sind, die aus diesem Tlön sind. Also man weiß gar nicht, gibt es das Land? Eigentlich sollte es doch nur eine Fiktion sein, aber zugleich sind diese Gegenstände da. Und das heißt dann zum Beispiel auch hier, alle Menschen, die eine Zeile von Shakespeare wiederholen, sind William Shakespeare. Also die Frage ist, wenn du die Fiktion wiederholst, wenn du die Fiktion sagst, ist sie in der Wirklichkeit geworden? Bist du dann auch William Shakespeare? Das ist eine Frage, die sich dann hier philosophisch stellt. Den Begriff des Plagiats gibt es nicht. Man geht davon aus, dass alle Werke das Werk eines einzigen Autors sind, der zeit- und namenlos ist. Ein Buch ohne Selbstwiderlegung gilt als unvollständig. Das heißt, wir haben hier ein System, eine Schlöngesellschaft, die den permanenten Widerspruch erstellt. Aber jetzt sind wir immer noch bei diesen einzelnen Gegenständen. Und dann gibt es in dieser Erzählung, die angeblich 1940 geschrieben ist, ein Nachtrag von 1947. Das ist aber nur eine Fiktion des Autors. Es sind also immer mehr solche Gegenstände da. Und das heißt dann plötzlich, dass es immer mehr dieses Eindringen von Gegenständen aus Klön gab. Der Kontakt und der Umgang mit Klön haben diese Welt aufgelöst, heißt es dann plötzlich. Das heißt, die Fiktion wird so dominant, die Welt, die man imaginiert hat, ist so stark, dass sie in der Realität ist. Bezaubert von seiner Strenge vergisst die Menschheit ein ums andere Mal, dass es eine Strenge von Schachspielern, nicht von Engeln ist. Schon ist das erschlossene Uridium von Klön in die Schulen eingedrungen. Schon hat seine harmonische Geschichte die in meiner Jugend herrschende ausgelöscht. Das heißt, wenn die Fiktion stark genug ist, dann kann sie alles verändern. Und es endet dann damit, dass es heißt, Englisch, Französisch und das bloße Spanisch werden dann vom Planeten verschwinden. Die Welt wird Tlön sein. Nur ausgelöst von der Fiktion verwandelt sich die Welt. Und das ist genau diese Fantasie, die man bei bei Orbit aufgreift. Und deswegen hat sich dieses Unternehmen dahinter Tlön genannt, dass man glaubt, wir müssen jetzt erst einmal etwas digital errichten. Eine ganz andere Welt, wo Eigentum anders strukturiert ist und dergleichen. Und dann wird sich das schon auf die Wirklichkeit übertragen. Ein bisschen so wie Professor Rauschnabel dann da eintauchen geht.
Es ist ein bisschen wie Weihnachten und das Thomas Theorem. Die gehen ja nicht ohne Grund in die Kirche. Also gibt es zu Weihnachten plötzlich eine Botschaft Gottes, also auch ein Gott. Sonst wären ja alle grundlos da. Damit ist die Existenz Gottes bewiesen. Um das endgültig nicht zu verstehen, was du uns gerade vorgetragen hast, warte ich aber auf den Film von Christopher Nolan zum Thema.
Es wäre ideal für ihn. Es wäre ideal. Mal sehen, wie wir dann darüber reden. Wir können natürlich auch fragen, ob Christopher Nolan vielleicht den Film schon gedreht hat. Und wir müssen nur noch mal unter anderem Gesichtspunkt blicken.
Vielleicht müssen wir Tenet rückwärts gucken, um zu verstehen, ach so, die Dinger kommen aus Tlön.
Gut, wir hören weiter.
Na gut. Wir als Podcaster hängen ja alle so diesem Traum nach, dass wir den Podcast, den wir auf unserem Computer zusammenschneiden, aufnehmen und so weiter, dann nicht auf einen Server schicken, weil der mit einer Gigabit-Leitung angebunden ist, sondern dass wir selber zu Hause, wie alle anderen auch, mit einer Gigabit-Leitung versorgt sind, sodass tatsächlich alle Hörer den Podcast von uns zu Hause runterladen. Das scheitert aber nicht am Computer, sondern wirklich nur an der Internet-Leitung. Aber das ist auch wieder, wie ich vorhin schon meinte, da stecken viele Wünsche drin, die ich auch immer so hatte, aber das ist mir doch zu schräg. Da muss ich hier auch wieder sagen, den Wunsch habe ich auch, aber das ist mir doch zu schräg.
Wie auch der Wunsch, ohne intermediär auszukommen.
Genau. Apple AirDrop, von Smartphone zu Smartphone übertragen durch eine direkte WLAN-Verbindung, rasend schnell, auch lange Videos einfach einmal drüber, aber werden wir gesehen, in China, wurde Apple gezwungen, das auszuschalten. Also das ist hier steckt so die drin.
Ja, also diese Grundlage, auf der man überhaupt anfängt, so ein System zu bauen, ist ja sehr interessant, dass man sagt, wir haben diese Vermachtung durch die Konzerne, und deswegen müssen wir eine Alternative suchen. Zugleich aber ist Peter Thiel dann Geldgeber in diesem ganzen Spiel. Das heißt, es sind Milliardäre wieder im Hintergrund, aber das eine hat dann wiederum mit dem anderen nichts zu tun. Da sind wir wieder bei dem Punkt, den du eben schon angesprochen hattest, bei Andrew Tate. Wir haben jetzt jemanden, der der König für die Insel ist, der aber selber kein Insel ist, also der selber nicht dem Phänotyp eines Insels entspricht. Wir haben den Milliardär aus New York, der sagte, ich mach mal hier was für die Arbeiterklasse. Und diese Konstellation haben wir hier in gewisser Weise wieder. Und dann hat man diese universale Fantasie auch insofern, als man von Monden und Planeten spricht. Man versteht überhaupt nicht mehr, was da eigentlich gemeint ist. Aber, wie Han-Yven das schon bei X-Borgess nachlesen konnte, es geht tatsächlich darum, dass man sich in diese Welt vertieft. Und wenn man anfängt, dazu Artikel zu lesen, dann muss man sich immer weiter reinarbeiten, um das zu verstehen. Es handelt sich aber jetzt nicht um eine Schwäche des Systems, insofern, als man sagen würde, man muss man noch die Nutzerfreundlichkeit verbessern, dass man sagt, es muss so leicht verwendbar sein wie Twitter. Sondern es geht vielmehr darum, dass das sich Einarbeiten in diesen Kosmos, also ein Geheimwissen zu akkumulieren, das eigentliche ist, worum es hier geht. Das heißt, wir haben zum einen jetzt hier so ein technisches Netzwerk, bei dem wir und auch die Macher selbst nicht genau verstehen, was es eigentlich sollen, wie es funktionieren soll. Wir haben aber die Möglichkeit, uns ganz intensiv auseinanderzusetzen, wie ist das jetzt nochmal mit den Planeten und den Monden und kann ich dann auch irgendwas abtreten und wem gehört welches Land? Das heißt, ich kann jetzt auch ein Archiv mir aufbauen, ich kann mich Tage, Wochen, Jahre damit beschäftigen, wie man das aus der Krypto-Szene ja auch schon kennt. Und hat damit eine eigene Welt sich geschaffen, mit der man sich beschäftigen kann. Also früher machte man dann vielleicht die Märklin-Eisenbahn, baute man sich im Keller und sagte, hier baue ich mir mal eine Welt auf. Und das wird jetzt hier auf der technischen Ebene gegeben. Und jetzt können wir uns alle da mal, wenn wir wollen, reinfuchsen. Und es ist auch immer der Wunsch, zu irgendeinem Schlüssel zu gelangen, zu einer Erkenntnis.
Das ist immer witzig, diese Cast-Communication-Computer-Club-Leute, die da so ein bisschen verbandelt sind mit. Die haben ja so eine natürliche Aversion gegen Facebook zum Beispiel. Die wissen aber, Facebook ist super erfolgreich, sowohl bei den Nutzern als auch bei den Werbenden, Werbetreibenden und so. Und wenn die dann mal Kontakt zu Facebook haben, indem sie einfach an der Benutzeroberfläche sitzen und feststellen, hä? Also damit schlagen sich die normalen Leute darum. Ich dachte, unsere Sachen sind kompliziert. Also die sozusagen auch das, so funktioniert das und so. Und es war auch ein Erfolgsrezept bei Snapchat. Bei Snapchat, Snapchat war so kompliziert, wie ist das mit der Kamera, wo kriege ich welchen Effekt her und so, dass sich die Kids auf dem Schulhof das gegenseitig zeigen mussten und dadurch so diese Snapchat-Verbandelung stattfand. Da kam nie ein Handbuch mitgeliefert, wurden immer so neue Features gedroppt und man wusste nie so richtig, ja genau und welche jetzt ach so du kennst das schon und dann zeig mal. Und dann hat man darüber so eine geschworene Gemeinschaft gegründet.
Also ein bisschen Schnitzeljagd.
Genau, man geht so gemeinsam, erarbeitet sich so die Handlungsmöglichkeiten innerhalb dieses Zeugs und das scheint hier auch wieder, das ist wie so eine Harry Potter-Geschichte. Man nimmt sich einmal die 300 Jahre Texte und dann sagt man sich Intertextualität. Richtig, dann baut man alles zusammen.
Ja, und das darf uns auch nicht wundern, denn der Gründer, Curtis Darwin, was hat er eigentlich gemacht? Düsterberg führt das aus. Jahrelang führte Darwin ein hermetisches Leben. Ab 2004 stellte Google Books Tausende von urheberrechtlich nicht geschützten Büchern kostenlos online zur Verfügung. Die meiste Zeit seines Lebens verbrachte David Darment in vergessenen philosophischen und wirtschaftlichen Texten aus dem 18. und 19. Jahrhundert zu forschen. Im Jahr 2007 startete er unter dem Pseudonym Mancius Moldbuck einen Blog mit dem Titel unqualifizierte Vorbehalte. In den folgenden neun Jahren veröffentlichte er Millionen von Wörtern mit pedantischen und widersprüchlichen Gedanken, die das Ergebnis seiner selbstbestimmten Reise durch das digitale Mausoleum vergesstener Schriftsteller sind. Wenn Sie schon einmal von Curtis David gehört haben, dann wahrscheinlich aus diesem Grund. Der Blog war der Ausgangspunkt für die Neoreaktion, eine politische Theorie, die die Demokratie ablehnt und den Markt heiligt, indem sie den Libertarismus mit dem Monarchismus kombiniert, um von CEOs geführte Stadtstaaten zu befürworten. Nach der Wahl Trumps im Jahr 2016 gab es eine Reihe von Berichten, die die Neoreaktion mit der Alt-Right und dem plötzlichen politischen Stimmungsumschwung in Verbindung brachte. Yavin soll Steve Bannon, Milo Yiannopoulos und andere Persönlichkeiten der frühen Trump-Ära beraten haben und hatte, wie wir hörten, ein offenes Ohr bei Teal, in dessen Haus er die Wahlergebnisse von 2016 beobachtete.
Das ist ja jetzt eine Rabbit-Hole für sich, wenn wir jetzt die Berater, der Berater, wenn wir da angekommen sind, sehr gut.
Wir sind bei den Beratern der Berater angekommen und wenn man sich so Interviews mit diesem Yavin ansieht, der sehr nerdisch wirkt, dann bezieht er sich tatsächlich auch laufend auf irgendwelche Schriftsteller aus dem 18. Jahrhundert.
Das ist eigentlich irre.
Und sagt, das habe ich da aber schon bei den Kontra-Revolutionären da und dort gelesen.
Ja, 2016 steht Donald Trump auf der Bühne und macht Sprüche gegen die Links von Fox News. Gewinnt dadurch Popularität, sticht aller anderen 17 republikanischen Kandidaten aus, gewinnt sozusagen die Hoheit über das Fernsehbild am Abend bei den Wählern, die er erreichen will, fährt ein Sieg gegen Hillary Clinton und durch diesen Moment gewinnt all dieses Geplapper von irgendwelchen Leuten, die in irgendwelchen Räumen zu irgendwelchen Themen irgendwelchen Blödsinn erzählen, totalen Sinn, weil das ja die Berater, die Berater des Siegers waren. Das ist nicht schlecht. Das ist mal so richtig rabbit hole, aber so retrospectiv, so hinten erzählt.
Und sie treffen sich jetzt aktuell. Es gibt dann solche Urbit-Konferenzen in New York. Und dort sind dann auch viele Intellektuelle, die eine große Langeweile empfinden.
Genau.
Also Leute, die irgendwas zwischen 20 und 40 sind, die überlegen, gut, Bernie Sanders wäre vielleicht noch mal so ein Umschwung gewesen, es hat nicht geklappt. Jetzt die beiden Administrationen, die machen ja eh nicht Politik für mich. Irgendwie ist mir auch so langweilig in der Demokratie. Wäre das nicht mal schön, wenn man es noch mal krachen lässt?
Ja, wir hören gleich von ganz vielen Frauen, die auch auf so einer Sensur sind, aber in sich suchen und das sind die Männer.
Nein, nein, nein, ich muss es schon gleich. Nein, also es ist sicherlich männlich dominiert, aber es sind einige Frauen da, die auch in diesen Berichten vorkommen. Da ist z.B. Amanda Milius, das ist die Tochter des Regisseurs von Conan der Barbar, die auch Trump-Supporterin ist, die auch für eine tough diplomacy ist, die mit dem Grinnell befreundet ist.
Man muss ja keine Geschlechterunterscheidung machen, sondern es gibt die, die nach innen suchen und die, die nach außen suchen.
Ich glaube, so kann man es eher schildern. Und sie ist auch ganz angetan von all dem. Ich will das mal gerade, weil wir gar nicht so viele Clips dazu hören, weil es interne Partys sind, auf denen sich dann Journalisten herumtreiben. Denn es ist ja auch immer dieser Reiz des Verbotenen, dass man da gerne mal schaut, was machen die da eigentlich. Und es geht jetzt hier um diese schon angesprochene Amanda Emilius. Sie nämlich ist auch in diesen Kreisen zuhause, sie ist Filmemacherin. Sie hat so einen verrückten Film wohl gedreht, wo sie dann sagt, warum Trump überhaupt nicht beeinflusst ist von den Russen und was weiß ich, irgendwas. Muss man glaube ich nicht näher sich mit beschäftigen. Aber für die Vanity Fair, ich kann diesen Artikel auch sehr empfehlen, war James Polk dort auf diesen Partys zu Gast. Das ist ein Artikel sehr, sehr, sehr lang. Und da schreibt er, Amanda Emilius hat in der Mainstream-Politik gearbeitet, tritt aber auch in sogenannten Dissidenten-Podcasts auf. Und befindet sich am Rande einer Kulturszene, in der rechte Politik einen Glanz angenommen hat, der an Coolness grenzt. Sie sagt, sie sei zu Blackpilled, um viel darüber nachzudenken, wie es aussehen würde, wenn ihre Seite gewinnen würde. Blackpill hatte ich noch nie vorher gehört.
Was ist mit Rot und Blau?
Blue und Redpill, wir sind ja die Schlafschafe, wir haben noch alle die blaue Pille. Und Redpill ist, wenn man wirklich erkannt hat, was hinter dem Schein und den Illusionen steckt. Blackpill ist nun folgendes, wir springen mal gerade dahinter. Blackpill kann das eine wie das, also kann vieles sein. Und zwar hören wir jetzt mal ganz kurz Austin Dunham, der das jetzt auf so einer Ebene des Männlichkeits-Coachings, also so Entrotatemäßig löst. Übrigens gibt es auch das Gerücht, dass Entrotatet bei Urbitt angemeldet ist.
Würde mich wundern, wenn das nicht ein großes schwarzes Loch ist, in dem sie alle so gut reinkriegen.
Black Pill meint hier. Es gibt natürliche Gegebenheiten und die sind entscheidend zum Beispiel beim Dating. Warum hat das was mit Black Pill zu tun? Black Pill hier auf diese Coaching-Variante gemünzt bedeutet, du kannst das nicht ändern. Das ist so. Und wenn man jetzt aber Black Pill überträgt auf den politischen Kontext, dann geht Amanda Milius davon aus, dass ohnehin alles rabenschwarz aussieht. Düsterberg schreibt auch, Black Pill ist ein Onlinebegriff, mit dem Menschen beschrieben werden, die glauben, dass unsere Welt so verkorkst ist, dass nichts mehr sie retten kann. Und aus dieser Haltung heraus, dass es ohnehin alles keinen Sinn mehr hat, kann man ja vielleicht noch mal das Leben genießen und gibt sich dann einer solchen Gegenkultur hin und treibt sich auf verrückten Partys herum. Sam Seder ist ein Linker, der einen Podcast macht und er wird dann auch von einer Hörerin gefragt zum Thema Black Pill.
All I can tell you is that the only thing I can give you honestly is like I think an insufficient answer in that nothing's gonna happen once you take that Black Pill.
Ja, eine schwierige, schwache Antwort, aber vielleicht finden wir hier schon einen Kern. Ich will es jetzt nicht überinterpretieren, aber wir sind an einem Punkt angelangt, wo man sagen kann, linksliberale Hegemonie gibt es in einem gewissen Grade, also was jetzt zum Beispiel die gleichgeschlechtliche Ehe anbelangt. Solche Dinge wären aufzuzellen, aber wir haben ja ökonomisch keine Gleichheit hergestellt, sondern wir haben eine noch größere Ungleichheit jetzt, wie wir ja heute schon mehrmals angesprochen haben. Die linke Antwort ist ja eine sehr schwache darauf, beziehungsweise sie hat überhaupt keine. Und die linke hat zudem ja das große Problem, sie muss immer wieder so einen Ordnungsruf laut werden lassen, wenn irgendwelche Grenzen überschritten werden. Das heißt, die linken sind sehr stark in einer domestizierenden Position, gerade dass sie sagen, ja so was sagt man aber nicht, das macht man aber nicht, das gehört sich aber nicht. Das ist eine völlig neue Rolle, verglichen mit dem, was die linke Gegenkultur, popkulturelle Gegenkultur, Subkultur der 50er, 60er, 70er, 80er Jahre waren. Da waren nämlich immer die Eltern sagen, das macht man aber nicht, aber ich lass mich doch piercen, lass mir doch lange Haare wachsen, höre doch die Rolling Stones und mache doch dies und habe Sex vor der Ehe. Das sind alles diese Themen, die nicht mehr auszuhandeln sind. Die Grenzüberschreitung heute liegt woanders. Und das ist, ich will den Gedanken fortsetzen, also diese Grenzüberschreitung liegt woanders. Wir hören jetzt einen Ausschnitt aus einer Artikel, den ich gerade vorlesen möchte, von Ruby Sutton für Astra Mec. Und da sagt sie, Wie das Eintauchen in die Geschichte eines Podcasts, das Entwickeln von Verschwörungstheorien oder die Beschäftigung mit Borgas erfordert, die Nutzung von Urbit einen konzentrierten Fokus, den man heute gerne als autistisch bezeichnet. Diese Einstiegshürde scheint die Urbit-Gemeinschaft zu dem geformt zu haben, was sie in dem Moment war, als ich ihr begegnete. Ein Ökosystem von Menschen, die den Verhaltenskodizés auf der Erde und im Internet skeptisch gegenüberstehen, die vom mythologischen Universum von Urbit angezogen werden, weil sie das Gefühl haben, dass etwas an der Art und Weise, wie sich die Dinge an der Oberfläche abspielen, falsch ist. Sie ist dann bei einer Villenparty in Kalifornien und sagt, auf der Rückseite des Hauses befindet sich eine Infinity Pool. Dort nehme ich in einem Meter von männlichen Programmierern Blickkontakt mit einem Mädchen auf. Sie trägt einen Hologrammausschnitt eines Mädchens mit wässrigen Augen bei sich. Ich frage, was es mit der Hologrammfigur auf sich hat. Ich sehe sie ständig. Bei Me Lady dreht sich alles um Liebe, erklärt sie, und hält das Hologrammädchen hoch. Schönheit, Ästhetik und gesundes Leben. Sie zieht mich hinein, um mir einige ihrer Freunde vorzustellen. Wir machen zum Beispiel keinen Scheiß mit Samenölen. Drinnen läuft ein Anime auf dem Flachbildschirm. Und Leute spielen Schach unter einer lichten Steinreproduktion mit sechs Tafeln. Ein Mann nimmt im Wohnzimmersessel ein Telefonat entgegen. Ich plättere in einem Exemplar von Industrial Society and its Future von Ted Kaczynski. Ted Kaczynski war der UNO-Bomber, der in den 80er, 90er Jahren diese Briefbomben schickte, weil er ein Technikfeind ist. Und auch die Urbid-Leute sagen, wir müssen aus dem technischen Zeitalter so aussteigen, dass wir uns nicht ganz der Technik entledigen. Aber wir brauchen andere Technik und die liefern wir hier mit Urbid. Und sie nennen sich auch zum Teil Teddys Neffen. Also sie kokettieren damit, dass sie mit einem nach wie vor in Haft sich befindenden Terroristen auch durchaus was verbindet.
Der auch eine publizistische Dimension hat. Also hat er dieses Manifest geschrieben.
Ja, das auch ganz wirr ist. Also wo ein Gedanke natürlich widerspricht dem anderen. Aber er hat die beziehungsweise wirr, er hatte eigentlich ein libertäres Konstrukt da entwickelt, das zugleich fortschrittsfeindlich ist.
Also es stecken so Ideen drin, wo man sich wieder denkt, als Schirmerer sagte ja, so Ideen kommen auf zwei Arten auf die Welt. Entweder als Buch oder als Technik. Und es ist aus einer Zeit, in der Technik noch nicht, wie hier jetzt sozusagen, ich kann es selber machen. Das ist Software, die kann ich zu Hause machen. Ich bin nicht irgendeine Maschine ausgeliefert oder so, die das erstmal eine Firma, die irgendwas herstellen muss, sondern dieser Ansatz und das begegnet, also das scheint ja hier maßgeblich zu sein. Das ist viel wichtiger als... Diese Handwitthoheitsbeweisung, die man sich da selber beibringt.
Wie wichtiger als über welche Blockchain geht das denn jetzt nun? Und nochmal zu diesem Gegenkulturgedanken zurück. Es gibt extrem viele sehr lange Artikel dazu. Ich habe jetzt viel mehr hier mitgebracht als was ich vorlesen kann. Aber es wird eben diese Gesellschaft geschildert, in der man politisch unkorrekt sich verhalten kann, wo man auch sagen kann, ich bin gar kein Demokrat, warum sollte ich auch Demokrat sein? Man kann auch mit White Supremacy dort Anklang finden. Also es ist das ganze Potpourri an allem, was man sich so vorstellen kann, dabei. Aber es ist irgendwie so ein bisschen hip, ein bisschen cool, ein bisschen schick, sich gerade damit auseinanderzusetzen. Es ist auch ein bisschen belesen. Man muss die Referenzen kennen. Man braucht dieses Geheimwissen. Und wenn wir jetzt noch mal über Jugendkultur und Gegenkultur sprechen, dann ist doch sehr interessant, dass wir heute die Jugendkultur nicht mehr in der Musik antreffen. Es ist gar kein Problem, heute für ein 17-Jähriger zu sagen, ich höre gerne diese eine Heavy Metal Band und ich finde Taylor Swift gut und ich gehe aber nächste Woche ironisch zu einem BTS-Konzert. Das ist überhaupt nicht mehr das Problem. Da war früher viel mehr, sagen wir mal, Sortenreinheit da. Was den Kleidungsstil, Frisuren, Piercings, Tätowierungen anbelangt, ist man auch völlig frei in der Wahl und es gibt nicht mehr klar erkenntlich, das macht man, wenn man 17 ist und dieser Gruppe zugehört, sondern alles ist möglich. Man muss nur aufpassen, dass vielleicht Papa und Mama nicht ganz genauso aussehen. Das heißt, wir haben es eigentlich da mit einem Verschwinden von Jugendkultur zu tun und zugleich aber wird die Jugend als Phase bis über den 80. Geburtstag hinaus fortgesetzt. Und wir haben auch nicht mehr das Spiel mit der Transgression, weil Transgression heute was ist, na ja, was will man machen? Gut, es gibt diese Leute, die Transgression üben im Sinne von Entrotet, die sagen, ich hau jetzt noch mal richtig auf die Kacke, wo der Planet schon brennt. Aber selbst ist das so nicht mehr da. Gut, es gibt kleinere Drogenüberschreitungen vielleicht, aber wenn da jetzt noch weitere Legalisierungswellen kommen, ist da auch nicht mehr Transgression möglich. Das heißt, wo Transgression möglich ist, ist es im politischen Rahmen, also mit solchen Äußerungen, mit Ansichten, die antidemokratisch oder was auch immer sind. Und wir können eigentlich sagen, die gesamte Gegenkultur und Jungkultur ist nicht verschwunden, sondern die ist wirklich ins Netz gewandert. Und die ist dort in diesen großen Foren mit all den popkulturellen Referenzen, wie es früher einmal war, nur viel eklektizistischer, dass hier alles zusammengeht. Ted Kaszczynski, Roy Lichtenstein und vielleicht noch irgendein neuer Song.
Ja, du brauchst einfach eine Jugendkultur als Jugend, bei der du es dir mit deinen Älteren nicht verscherzt, weil du einfach ökonomisch von denen abhängig bist und auch darauf angewiesen, dass sie mit dir willendig so eine Art Schicksalsgemeinschaft gründen. Weshalb es supergut ist, im Keller zu sitzen und nicht mit bunten Haaren, die man nicht einfach ablegen kann, wenn man in die Küche geht, sondern man geht in seine virtuelle Welt, zockt zum Beispiel oder macht sowas. Kann aber einfach ausschalten. Da geht man die Treppe hoch und ist der beste Sohn der Welt.
Früher musste man sich rausschleichen.
Genau.
Und dass man nicht zu spät nach Hause kommt.
Und das will man ja gar nicht. Und ich habe ja in Altenrepublik auch nochmal die Juvenilisierung als Gegenentwurf. Dass nämlich diese Kolonialisierung der Jugendkultur von oben, von den Älteren stattfindet. Weil die Eltern plötzlich, nachdem die Kinder so erleben, ich ja auch gerade erst mal so durch sind, durchgröpfte, dass man dann eigene Freiheiten für sich wieder, aber dann eben mit Budget auslebt. Und dass Jugendkulturen, nachdem wir sie weder politisch wie in der ersten Hälfte des letzten Jahrhunderts, als wir einfach zu viele Jugendliche hatten, und dann müssen wir als Hitlerjugend und so weiter gründen, weil irgendwie müssen wir sie ja disziplinieren. Die können ja nicht alle machen, was sie wollen. Und dann in der zweiten Hälfte so ökonomisch, ach so, die haben so viel Geld, weil das gerade Wirtschaftswachstum ist und so, dann sollen die mal unsere Musik kaufen, unsere T-Shirts, unsere Klamotten und so weiter. Jetzt hat man halt nichts davon. Also man hat weder viele Jugendliche noch besonders Vermögende. Also werden sie ein bisschen untergebuttert. Aber dieses Nachholende, Juvenilisierende, die Elterngeneration, die sich noch mal... Und so kann man auch dieses Urbe zerstören, wie bei Facebook, sobald die Eltern da auftauchen und mitmischen wollen.
Richtig. Und das ist aber dann vielleicht nicht gegeben. Wir haben es sicherlich mit einem Netzwerk zu tun, das jetzt gerade von reaktionären Rich Kids erst einmal dort besiedelt wird. Aber die Folgen davon wiederum, dass dann solche pseudo-intellektuellen Persönlichkeiten sich daraus bilden, das hat natürlich wieder den Effekt, dass dann alle aus dem Jugendzimmer darauf zugreifen können. Und wir haben es ja auch dann mit relativ alten Jugendlichen zu tun, also Leuten, die dann über 30 sind. Und das Erstaunliche ist, dass das Verbotene nicht darin liegt, dass man die Klassenfrage in den Mittelpunkt rückt. Also das ist ja auch in gewisser Weise das Verbotene. Also es findet nicht statt oder kaum statt. Man wird nicht eingesperrt, wenn man was sagt, weil man findet einfach nichts statt. Sondern das Verbotene bedeutet immer, ja man ist ein bisschen sexistisch, ein bisschen anti-vogue, ein bisschen antidemokratisch, was auch immer. Also man kann sich da dann was zusammensetzen. Und das ist ja auch erstaunlich diese Gleichzeitigkeit, die wir da haben. Also diese Neoreaktionären, die jetzt auch nochmal damit spielen, zu sagen, ich mache jetzt mal TikTok-Challenges, ich bin eine gute Hausfrau. Also ich setze jetzt dem Feminismus mal etwas entgegen und sage, es gibt eigentlich nichts Schöneres, als zu Hause zu sein und einen reichen Mann zu haben, der arbeiten geht. Das ist ja diese Gleichzeitigkeit, dass wir im Iran Frauen haben, die sich entledigen wollen, dem Islamismus und dem damit verbundenen Patriarchat. Wir haben zugleich Russland, das sich von der Demokratie verabschiedet, China, das wieder autoritärer wird, Indien, das autoritärer wird. Das heißt, das Antidemokratische, was hier aufgerufen wird, in Beverly Hills oder in New York, ist ja in dem Sinne keine Gegenkultur global betrachtet, sondern demografisch gesehen bilden die ja bereits die Mehrheit. Und diese nicht zur Kenntnisnahme globaler Gleichzeitigkeit verbindet aber diese Neo-Reaktionären dann wiederum auch mit den Volken, die ja gerne so tun, als wären diese Identitätsfragen dieselben, die sie sich stellen, wie sie auch in anderen Ländern gestellt werden. Also es gibt ja dann solche tollen Diskussionen, ja wie können wir das schaffen, dass wir Hollywood-Blockbuster diverser machen, denn es ist doch auch schade, wenn diese Filme in China gezeigt werden und da keine chinesischen Figuren vorkommen, wo dann einfach China sagt, ja ist uns doch egal, wir haben doch unseren eigenen Blockbuster. Also das ist ja auch so, ich hatte so eine Diskussion bei so einem Vortrag bei der Rosa-Luxemburg-Stiftung, da wurde ich dann auch darauf angesprochen, ich würde das ja gar nicht thematisieren, wie rassistisch die Algorithmen sind, wenn wir von Influencer und sowas sprechen, sag ich, ja worüber sprechen wir jetzt? Also Algorithmen belohnen nach dem Matthäus-Effekt, aber wenn man in andere Länder guckt, da sind natürlich nicht, in Brasilien sind keine Influencer, die aussehen wie Bibi und Julienco in den Charts. Das sind halt deren Influencer und da sind die Algorithmen wieder anders. Also was heißt diese globale Perspektive, dass da die Länder jeweils etwas hervorbringen, was sie einfach löst von der amerikanischen Popkultur. Das wird gar nicht gesehen, sondern man ist hier wirklich so in seinem eigenen Saft am Schmoren und überlegt, naja, wie könnte man jetzt noch irgendwas machen, was spannender ist. Und das wäre vielleicht so ein bisschen mit dem Reaktionären kokettieren.
Ich habe die neue Ausgabe von Corporate Therapy mit Ulrich Brooklyn. Kam die Tage und ist auch ein Soziologe und da greift Mary auch noch mal dieses Bild auf oder die beiden. Man ist auf Sinsuche, findet so ein Kanal, so eine digitale Autobahn, die man entlangfahren kann, wie auch immer, dann zum Beispiel Urbitt. Und dann ist aber die Frage, welchen Ansprüchen will ich da jetzt eigentlich genügen? Ist da eine Community? Was wollen die Entwickler der Community? Was will ich und so und alles geht drunter und drüber. Und am Ende ist es ein mega Aufwand und alle sagen, es ist mega kompliziert, wir müssen uns alle reinarbeiten, aber keiner kommt auch noch einen Schritt vorwärts, weil alle Anforderungen gleichzeitig gestellt werden. Es ist die alte Logik der Bauernregeln. Es gibt immer die eine Bauernregel und die klingt super schlüssig, richtig logisch und dann gibt es genau das Gegenteilige als auch Bauernregel, die genauso in sich total schlüssig und logisch klingt. Deswegen ist es auch nicht verwunderlich, dass dieses Konzept blaue Pille, rote Pille, blaue Pille und rote Pille, blaue Pille und rote Pille und schwarze Pille, dass man aus dieser Dialektik niemals rauskommt. Und jetzt gerade ist es halt Urwit. Alle verstricken sich da drin. Keiner weiß weiter. Wie in einer Organisationsberatung. Du hast diese Mode. Dann kommt irgendwer mit dem Spruch und sagt, ja, Dirk Becker zum Beispiel, die Reform, oder Luhmann so, die Reform soll auf jeden Fall Wirbel und Lärm verursachen. Schnelles vergessen, damit man dann die nächste Reform an die Reform anknüpfen kann. Und bei der vierten Reform schon nicht mehr merkt, dass man sich im Kreis dreht. Also, dass man nach dem psychologischen, dem soziologischen und dem neurolinguistischen Programmieren wieder beim sozialologischen Ankommen und dann dasselbe nochmal macht. Und am Ende dreht sich alles immer nur im Kreis. Und das Einzige, was triggert, ist dieses FOMO. Und das ist vielleicht geblieben aus Jugendkultur, dass man früher dieses, hast du schon die Neue von so und so gehört? Nee, aber Vorsicht, wenn es zu viele hören, wird es uncool. Also ich sag dir jetzt, das ist der neueste heiße Scheiß, aber sagst nicht weiter so ungefähr. Und wenn die Bands dann zu groß werden, wurden sie uncool. Und so ist das hier auch wieder.
Ja, sie versuchen auch gar nicht immer.
Genau, und ich sag dann, nee, an dem Moment ist es noch cool. Aber jetzt haben wir es hier besprochen.
Ist schon nicht mehr cool.
Ja, jetzt kennen wir es schon ein paar mehr wieder. Und irgendwann ist es auch urbit uncool. Und dann kommt jemand mit dem nächsten um die Ecke.
Ja, und der Versuch... Das ist der ewige Kreis. Das ist schon der ewige Kreis. Aber es hat diese politische Komponente, also dass ich ja doch, das ist ja eindeutig zu sehen, im Netz wahnsinnig viel zusammenbraute. Und wir haben das dann im Nachhinein sehen können, was hat sich durch Facebook ergeben politisch. So können wir, glaube ich, auch wenn es jetzt hier noch um kleine Krüppchen lästig handelt, aber es sind Intellektuelles, sind Vorreiter und die haben dann vielleicht doch mehr Impact, als man glaubt. Man kann hier sehen, dass man eine Meinungspluralität hergestellt hat, die an die Grenze dessen geht, was man sich eigentlich so vorstellen konnte, dass das einfach mal so auch diskutiert wird, dass man, dass es ein bisschen schick wird, sich in New York darüber zu unterhalten, ob man nicht doch vielleicht eine Monarchie haben will. Elizabeth Sandifair hat sich auch damit beschäftigt. Sie hat dann im Interview gesagt, Javans Überzeugung ist, dass Kalifornien sich im Grunde abspalten, seine eigene Nation werden und einfach einen CEO mit monarchischen, gottähnlichen Kräften einsetzen sollte. Damals schlug er vor, dass Steve Jobs eine besonders gute Wahl für den absoluten Monarchen von Kalifornien wäre und dass der Zweck des Besitzes von Kalifornien und dessen Führung als Unternehmensmonarchie ausdrücklich der Profit sei. Das war auch ein Teil von Javans philosophischer Vision, was die Welt tun sollte. Er glaubte sehr, sehr stark daran, dass reiche Eliten die absolute Kontrolle über alles haben sollten und dass Menschen, die keine Grundbesitzer sind und nicht viel Geld haben, im Grunde als das Äquivalent von Sklaven betrachtet werden sollen. Jetzt haben wir eben den Engeler gehört, wie er in der Anhörung sagte, er hat das könnte so eine neue Form der Leib-Eigenschaft mit sich bringen. Und hier sehen wir es dann, dass es nicht für das Metaverse, sondern generell ausbuchstabiert wurde von Darwin. Und den hören wir jetzt mal. Der war nämlich in einer Debatte mit Ben Burgess, der von Jacobin ist. Und dann dachte man sich, gut, man bringt jetzt mal zusammen. Vielleicht ist das erkenntnisbringend. Ich kann sagen, nein, das ist nicht der Fall. Man hält es kaum aus. Also ich habe das mal so durchgeskript, es ist kaum auszuhalten, was da geschwätzt wird, weil dieser Darwin überhaupt nicht daran interessiert ist, an einem erkenntnisinteressierten Diskurs. Er sagt jetzt hier erst mal was zur öffentlichen Meinung. Und er zitiert dann, wie übrigens sehr viele da, Chomsky.
Also eine der Dinge, die sehr klar von dem 20. Publiche Meinung ist nicht eine Grundlage, sondern ein Effekt.
Ja, Javin versucht dann, ihm deutlich zu machen, dass es schon einen Unterschied gibt, ob es Journalisten gibt, die natürlich herrschende Meinungen wiedergeben und dass es da auch immer wieder Machtkonzentrationen gibt und der auch Chomsky zustimmt, der weiß nur darauf hin, dass Chomsky ja die Verbindung zum Kapitalismus herstellt und die kappt aber dieser Javin und kappen auch die anderen alle, die glauben einfach, der Journalismus sei eine abgekapselte Medienelite, die die Meinung diktiert, aber das hat nichts mit Ökonomie zu tun, das hat nichts mit kapitalistischen Interessen oder irgendetwas zu tun, sondern das ist so für sich losgelöst. Da hat sich halt so eine Elite gebildet. Und gegen diese Elite müssen wir ankämpfen. Das ist die Idee, die Idee kann man es ja kaum nennen, also das ist die Idiotie, die dahinter steht. Wir sehen aber auch über diese eigenartige Medienkritik, Chomsky, aber ohne Chomsky hinaus, dass dieser Javin hochgefährliche Ansichten hat, denn auch hier haben wir eine starke ethno-pluralistische Tendenz, also diese Idee. Ja, die Welt ist vielfältig, aber deswegen ist gut, wenn jeder an dem ihm zugewiesenen Platze auch bleibt. Was ist meine Antwort? Das ist eine Abkehr vom Universalismus und das verbindet ihn ja absolut wieder mit einer linksliberalen Identitätspolitik, die immer sagt, wir müssen jetzt erstmal über unsere kulturelle Herkunft und da kommen wir auch gar nicht so raus und entsprechend müssen wir Filme besetzen und so weiter. Es ist schon interessant, wie eng dieser Identitäts- und Kulturdiskurs zusammengeht, also wie das die ganze Zeit eigentlich alle Debatten strukturiert. Das ist so erstaunlich und das ist aber nur dem geschuldet, dass man das Ökonomische ausschließt. Also indem man sagt, wir reden nicht über die Ungleichheit im ökonomischen Sinne, wenn das Ökonomische einfach keine Rolle spielt und bei denen auch keine Rolle spielen muss, weil die ja fast alle reich sind, die sich da engagieren, dann hat das zufolge, dass man nur noch auf die eigene Identität zurückgeworfen ist. Was denn sonst? Denn mit einem Universalismus allein kann man auch keine Politik machen, solange nicht dann auch materiell in irgendeiner Weise abgebunden ist. Und da das aber nicht stattfindet hier, hat man diesen permanenten Kampf der Identitäten. Und es ist dann auch so ein ganz billiges Kukettieren damit, dass man einen Umsturz will, aber natürlich niemals eine ökonomische Umsturz-Fantasie hat, sondern immer nur so eine ganz diffuse. Also Ben Burgess hat dann danach einen längeren Artikel für Jacobin geschrieben über dieses Treffen. Das klingt dann vollendermaßen. Die Kathedrale ist Jarwins Bezeichnung für die Schicht der Elite-Journalisten und Akademiker, die seiner Meinung nach die öffentliche Meinung prägen und letztlich die Richtung der Gesellschaft diktieren. Und der eigentliche Grund, warum wir eine Führungspersönlichkeit brauchen, die er bereit ist, mehr Monarch, die mehr bereit ist, Monarch zu sein als George W. Bush, neben Augustus sind Jarwins bevorzugte historische Beispiele Napoleon und Lenin, ist genau der, dass eine solche Figur unabhängig von den Launen der öffentlichen Meinung agieren und somit die Macht der Kathedrale brechen könnte. Einiges von dem, was Jarwin über die Kathedrale sagt, ist so, als würde man das Propagandamodell von Noam Chomsky und Edward Herman nehmen und dieses Modell von allem befreien, was es sinnvoll macht. Chomsky und Herman konzentrieren sich auf das Eigentum an den Medien als einen wesentlichen Teil der Geschichte. Jarwin bittet seine Zuhörer, den Milliardär hinter dem Vorhang zu ignorieren und gibt vor, nicht zu verstehen, dass A. Bezos die Redakteure der Washington Post jederzeit feuern und ersetzen kann, wenn ihm danach ist. Und was noch wichtiger ist B. Sie es gar nicht erst in diese Position geschafft hätten, wenn sie die Welt auf eine Weise sehen würden, die die Interessen von jemanden bedrohen, der reich genug ist, die Post zu kaufen. Also die ökonomische Sache wird ausgeklammert. Also diese Debatte ist wirklich so irre, dass ich es gar nicht mitgebracht habe. Wenn sie dann darüber diskutieren, dass Jeff Bezos zwar die Washington Post gekauft hat, aber er eigentlich, also das würde gar nichts bedeuten. Das hätte gar nichts mit Macht zu tun. Man soll sich lieber mal angucken, wem die New York Times gehört. Da sei nämlich der eigentliche Feind. Und so geht es weiter und weiter. Und was immer man sich von diesen Leuten anhört, ist eigentlich, dass sie damit kokettieren. Wir können doch mal die moderne abräumen und mal wieder zurückgehen in feudale Zeiten. Dass sie zugleich technizistisch und technikfeindlich sind. Dass sie Fortschritt wollen im Sinne des Rückschritts. Also man ist nicht konservativ. Also man sagt nicht, wir müssen noch so ein paar Dinge bewahren. Das wäre so ein traditioneller Republikaner. Das wäre so ein McCain. Das wäre ein Konservativer. Aber was die tatsächlich wollen, ist, dass man ein konservativer Revolutionär ist, beziehungsweise ein Reaktionär ist. Hans Dünger hat sich ja auch immer als Reaktionär bezeichnet, nicht als Konservativer. Das heißt, wir sind hier sehr nah an dem dran, was wir in den Zwanzigerjahren finden konnten. Also ich glaube, diese Wunsch nach Dissidenz, diese Langeweile über die parlamentarische Demokratie und zugleich diese ökonomische Not führen dazu, dass man nach allen Seiten die Fühle ausrichtet und man dann auch sehr davon angezogen wird, wenn wieder irgendwo ein neuer Prediger auftaucht, der was erzählt.
Ja, aber es ist so ein interessantes Desinteresse an Geschichte und was sie uns lehren kann irgendwie. Die sitzen dann immer da, also gerade Peter Thiel, denken sich irgendwas aus, übersetzen das dann in irgendwelche Unternehmen, die irgendwelche Software machen mit irgendwelchen Zielsetzungen, wie sowas hier, und verbittern darüber auch so, weil da so eine Enttäuschung immer mit schwebt. So, ah, hat wieder nicht funktioniert, ah, es waren wieder diese scheiße User, die es nicht richtig gemacht haben, meine Armee hat nicht funktioniert, was auch immer. Dieses Ganze geht man nicht aufs College, sondern gründet, und dann wird aber aus denen allen nichts, es gibt keine vorzeigbare Geschichte, keine Heldengeschichten, die man da irgendwie dran kleben kann an diese Forderung. Und am Ende verbittert man so mit dieser Unzufriedenheit über die Welt, während Gegenentwurf zu all dem Conan O'Brien, der alte Showmaster, der jetzt nur noch Podcasts macht, ein absoluter Geschichtsnerd ist, der jede scheiß Biografie und jedes Buch über alles Mögliche liest. Und dann aber, wenn er selber Medien produziert, absolute nur noch Klamauk macht, weil er so ungefähr abschätzen kann, wie sehr es eh keinen Sinn hat, wie sehr alles schon ausgetestet wurde, was man als Idee mal noch kurz vorbringen kann und sich komplett, also es kam mir gerade so als, da muss man so diesen, wahrscheinlich auch seine eigene Art.
Auf die eigene Art, ja.
Weil das ist ja nicht zu vertragen.
Das ist ja ganz frustrierend, was der da so von sich gibt. Aber es gibt durchaus welche, die das dann genießen, jetzt gerade den Untergang dort in New York. Also Amanda Milius sagt, we are just the last normal people hanging out at the end of the world.
Ja, aber, also ja, genau. Und es ist aber so amüsant irgendwie, wie die so da sitzen, wir müssen mal ein Netzwerk gründen im Rahmen einer Demokratie, in der wir ja irgendwie leben. Und dann entwickeln wir so eine Idee von nur noch das Individuum zählt und wir brauchen den Monarchen. Und alles passt mit nichts zusammen. Es sind einfach immer nur die Gegenentwürfe der Realität, die man vorfindet.
Und Borgess hat aber alles auch schon mal aufgeschrieben.
Genau. Und es wird, es steht alles schon irgendwo geschrieben, wurde auch schon mal ausgetestet und so weiter.
Und gut, wir hören noch einen letzten Clip und dann leite ich über zu deinem Thema, denn wir wollen nochmal spirituell werden, wollen aber erst eine Sache noch. Was ist vielleicht so faszinierend daran? Wir hören jetzt Anthony Arroyo, der Chief Product Officer bei Clon ist. Und er sagt Folgendes.
Also, das Problem ist, dass ich nicht eine Gemeinde von Leuten habe, die ich einfach in den Chat gehen kann und frage, habt ihr noch eine neue Musik gehört?
Ich möchte das Dorf im Internet haben und möchte die Übersichtigkeit haben. Der Nachbar hat mir gerade diesen Song empfohlen und das bitte in der digitalen Welt. Es ist die Sehnsucht nach Übersichtigkeit, die Sehnsucht, die Religionen befriedigen können. Und damit ist, dass der letzte Punkt, ich hatte eben schon erwähnt, da war eine junge Frau mit einem Me-Lady-Shirt. Und diese Figur, weiß nicht, ob du die mal gesehen hast. Ich habe sie dir jetzt mal ausgedruckt. Das ist also so eine Anime-Figur mit großen Augen. Ja, was ist das? Die Me-Lady Maker Kollektion ist ein Kunstprojekt, das von einem mysteriösen Online-Kollektiv namens Remilia ins Leben gerufen wurde. Im Gegensatz zu den typischen NFT-Projekten existieren die Me-Ladys in einer anderen Welt als der Rest von Web3. Hier gibt es keine Vagmi-Slogans, keine Anspielungen auf die eindeutig vorpuppertäre Ästhetik von Stoner Cats. Bei den Me-Ladys kreuzen sich die politäistische Religion des Vedismus, Rave-Kultur, Risikokapital und das Podcast-Ökosystem der New Yorker Innenstadt. Sie sind auch an URBIT beteiligt, einem kühnen Projekt, mit dem das Internet von Grund auf neu aufgebaut werden soll. Um Me-Ladys zu verstehen, muss man sich mit ihrem Slogan auseinandersetzen. Ich sehne mich nach Netzwerksspiritualität. Das ist ein Mantra dieser Remilia-Anhänger. Sie sind auch Mitglieder der nun aufkeimenden. Literaturszene von Downton, New York City. Es suggeriert Zusammengehörigkeit, vielleicht so etwas wie eine Singularität oder die kosmische Vereinigung des Third Pact in der Anime-Serie Neon Genesis Evangelion. Aber es ist letztlich auch Kauderwelsch, ein kultureller Signifikannt, mehr als eine kohärente Aussage über den Zweck. Und das ist typisch für diese Gesellschaft, dass es eigentlich auch alles Quatsch sein könnte. Und trotzdem ist es ein Quatsch, mit dem man sich jetzt mal beschäftigt, weil es kein Alternativangebot gibt. Welches Alternativangebot könnte es geben? Also wenn man jetzt sagt, wie könnte man das von links zum Beispiel gestalten? Müssen wir jetzt auch eine linke Milady produzieren? Brauchen wir eine linke Spiritualität? Nein, das glaube ich nicht. Also sicherlich muss man auch im Netz vertreten sein, das ist ja klar. Aber ich glaube, dass man es schaffen muss, dass der Materialismus, wie das Sexy wird in dem Sinne, dass also die ökonomischen Fragen, die sind, die das Leben verbessern. Und dass es nicht irgendein komisches Anime ist, das mir Spiritualität verspricht. Und eigentlich ist der Nährboden doch gut für diesen großen politischen Umschwung, aber er kommt nicht, weil es auch vielleicht nicht besonders attraktiv ist. Also selbst ich, der glaube ich eine große Distanz zu dem hat, was ich da heute jetzt hier entfaltet habe, muss sagen, irgendwie ist es schon auch toll, dass man da noch so und so was sich reinarbeiten kann, dass das auch ein bisschen lustig ist, dass auch alles nicht gleich so sektiererisch ist, sondern ich kann mich auch da hinsetzen und wahrscheinlich sagen, gut, dann lese ich nur noch aus Lenin vor, ja, geht auch noch hier. Also indem man diesen Karneval da mitfeiern kann, hat das natürlich etwas, was gerade wo sonst immer Grenzüberschreitung als etwas Problematisches angesehen wird, hat das eine große Verführungskraft, gerade auf junge Leute. Also man will ja in jungen Jahren, wenn man an diese anthropologische Konstante einmal glaubt, schon auch transgressiv sein. Und wenn es von links überhaupt kein Angebot mehr gibt, außer zu sagen, ihr müsst jetzt vielleicht doch nochmal alle mehr verzichten, auch in Solidarität für die, weiß ich nicht, wo kein Problem sind, hat man keine attraktive Wirkung auf junge Leute. Es ist erschreckend, wie dumm das ist, was die davon sich geben. Und ich habe ja dann auch von Andrew Tate mir zwei, drei Minuten angehört, dass das ja im Kopf nicht auszuhalten. Aber in gewisser Weise ist nachvollziehbar, warum ein solch schrecklicher Typ erfolgreich sein kann, weil es kein Gegenangebot gibt. Was soll man machen? Die jungen Wilden im Bundestag sind auch nicht inspirierend.
Andrew Tate ist auf jeden Fall unterhaltsam, auch so eine Art und Weise, wie auch Donald Trump unterhaltsam war. Es dämmert ja so ein bisschen um ihn herum. Die Show ist nicht mehr allzu gut und nicht mehr allzu gefragt. Und sie bespielt ein Publikum, das eine Anforderung hat, nämlich gib mir alles auf einmal. So wie auch die ganzen Boomer jetzt da sitzen und nochmal, wir haben es ja häufig thematisiert, Stranger Things gucken, im Sinne von gib mir noch mal mein ganzes Lebensgefühl von vor 30 Jahren, aber alles auf einmal, alles in einer Stunde. Die Highlights meiner Kindheit, der 80er, meiner Jugendlichkeit, alles nochmal richtig kondensiert. Sitzen halt andere Leute da und sagen gib mir alles, was jetzt gerade aktuell cool und irgendwie ausgefallen ist und alles jetzt gleichzeitig. Und ja, Andrew Tate ist halt einer, der sozusagen das Angebot macht, also man kann ins Urbeid gehen und da alles gleichzeitig finden oder den Anspruch haben oder bei Andrew Tate nicht nur den Bugatti, sondern auch die zwei Ferraris und dann noch die 31 anderen Autos und so weiter. Alles auf einmal sehen und jeden Tag eine andere Frau, die man da sehen will. Das Gegenprogramm dazu ist die Antwort steckt in dir, Wolfgang. Geh nicht auf die Suche, frag nicht woanders, suche bei dir selbst. Wir nutzen jetzt ein Angebot, das uns Arte macht, um uns nicht nur in die neue Spiritualität reinzugucken, sondern auch sie noch mal zu unterscheiden von der alten Esoterik. Das ist die Unterscheidung, die hier maßgebend ist. Die Reportage heißt, der Traum vom optimierten Ich trifft es da nicht so ganz. Weil es ist jetzt nicht so sehr dieses Optimierungs-Fitness-Irgendwas, sondern es gibt doch schon so einen spirituellen Influencer. Und wir beginnen mal da, wo es immer losgeht. Realität. Was ist eigentlich Realität? Wir sitzen hier mal direkt, also es ist so eine typische Reportage. Eine Frau, materiell soweit abgesichert ist auf Sinn-Suche, sucht sich also Angebote, die es so gibt und findet 1 zu 1 Beratung. Ist also Klientin, in dem Sinne ausgeliefert, ihres Gurus sitzt bei ihr am Tisch. Und hier hört man mal so, wir springen mal so mitten rein in so ein Gespräch.
Gibt es Techniken oder irgendwas, was du mir mitgeben kannst, damit ich das Gefühl stärker machen kann?
Erst mal achte auf deine Worte. Bemärke es, wenn du das jemandem erzählst und du machst dich klein. Und dann korrigiere dich. Das ist ganz wichtig. Unsere Worte erschaffen Realität, erschaffen, zeigen uns unsere Gedanken.
Die Sehnsucht nach solchen Erkenntnissen wächst.
Die Sehnsucht nach welchen Erkenntnissen wächst? Dass mir jemand sagt, ja, dann achte mal auf deine Worte. Wenn du eine Botschaft hast, überbringen sie richtig. Also eigentlich Nonsens. Aber...
Ja, jeder, der schon mal mit Menschen zu tun hat, weiß das ja eigentlich.
Denkt man. Also man holt sich hier nochmal die Selbstverständlichkeiten, die allgemeinen Plätze ab. Aber wie auch immer, Worte erschaffen Realität, hören wir hier, und die Sehnsucht nach diesen Erkenntnissen wächst. Und...
Naja, wir sehen das doch daran, dass es Instagram-Profile gibt, die nur kacheln sind mit Sinssprüchen. Zum Beispiel. Dummerweise hat man diesen Algorithmus ja jetzt bei Instagram so angestellt, dass man laufend jetzt was angezeigt bekommt, was man nicht abonniert hat. Und ich weiß nicht, was da los ist, aber ich bekomme zum Beispiel sehr viele Sinssprüche jetzt angezeigt. Und das sind Profile, die auf 4, 5, 800.000 Follower kommen. Und dort stehen solche Sätze. Achte auf deine Worte, Worte schaffen die Wirklichkeit.
Ja, vielleicht steckt ja irgendeine Botschaft noch drin. Wer weiß? Ja, es ist jedenfalls irgendwie inhaltlich absurd, aber es findet trotzdem statt. Und diese Realität, in der die Worte so viel Neues schaffen, die wird ja aufgestört. Wir Menschen, wir begegnen uns ja nicht mehr so viel. Es kam ja auch Corona und so weiter. Also ist ja diese Guru-Frau, ist eine weibliche Form Guru, oder haben wir da wieder keine feminine Guru-Innen? Ein Guru, eine Guru. Wir haben es ja eben schon gehört, hier nochmal ein kleiner Hinweis zur aktuellen Realität, die vielen so zu schaffen macht.
Immer mehr Klienten buchen Linda Giese, um besser bestehen zu können in einer zunehmend technisierten Welt. 180 Euro kostet die halbe Stunde.
Wir brauchen uns nur umschauen. Die Technik ist überall, hält sie Einzug. Das macht die Menschen aber auch letztendlich ein Stück weit einsam. Früher hat man dich besucht, wenn du Geburtstag hattest, oder hat zumindest angerufen. Heute kriegst du eine WhatsApp.
Und doch hat gerade der technische Fortschritt den Boom der neuen Spiritualität erst möglich gemacht.
Ganz richtig. Das hängt nämlich eng damit zusammen. Und wir sehen hier ein Interieur mit Stühlen, die alle mit weißen Hussen überzogen sind. Auch sie trägt eine weiße Bluse. Und man hat auch noch Buddha-Figuren aufgestellt. Denn es kann ja nie schaden, das auch noch mit reinzunehmen.
Ja, genau. Der Gag ist natürlich, die beiden treffen sich auch nur über Facebook. Also der Kontakt kommt über, ich google mal, keine Ahnung, spirituelle Hilfe, meine Nachbarschaft. Und dann kommt da halt so ein Guru und dann miedet man sich da ein. Und das Ziel, wenn man dann einmal den therapeutischen Weg hier geht, also ich habe es in Anführungszeichen therapeutischen Weg genannt, dieser Beschäftigungszeit, ist eine neue Haptualisierung der eigenen, wie auch immer. Wir sehen sie ja schon mit so einer großen Klangschale irgendwie, sitzen sie sich dann wirklich gegenüber, schauen sich in die Augen. Wir haben es ja bei beiden gelernt, nicht nur die große Politik, sondern auch das Kleine. Auch wir sitzen uns ja hier echt gegenüber. Und das wird jetzt neu kultiviert.
Auch Nicole kam mit Linda über Facebook in Kontakt.
Jetzt hast du deine neue Entscheidung und deinen Mut ganz tief in dir verankert, weil Schwingung ist Information, Energie ist Information und dein ganzes Sein bis in deine kleinste Zelle ist jetzt informiert mit deinem neuen Weg.
Die Informierung des ganzen Körpers über eine Klangschale, wir wissen ja.
Aber ist die Moderne einfach vielleicht schon vorbei? Also wir tun zwar immer noch so und versuchen, wieder im modernen zu argumentieren. Jetzt haben wir eben Urbit gehabt, jetzt wird hier Informationsübertragung via Klangschale. Vielleicht sind wir auch schon fast ausgestorbene.
Also ja, Modernität heißt ja, dass wir super alt werden, super lange noch, super gut aussehen, dass uns eigentlich die Umwelt nichts mehr anhaben kann. Der SUV als Panzer und so weiter.
Ja, und Modernität bedeutet aber auch, gewisse Erkenntnisse mitzunehmen und nicht mehr irgendwohin zurückzugehen. Oder zu sagen, ja, es gibt noch diesen anderen Teil im Menschen, der zum Beispiel an etwas glauben will. Aber dafür haben wir ja Institutionen geschaffen. Diese pröckeln aber ja gerade weg. Also die Kirchenaustritte kommen ja immer wieder zu neuen Rekorden. Und dann sind solche Mode-Atheisten immer ganz froh, wenn sie dann diese Zahlen haben und jubeln. Und dann denke ich mir, nee, die kommen alle da in der Klangschale wieder an. Es wäre vielleicht doch besser, die würden einfach sonntags zu einem ausgebildeten Theologen gehen und würden sich da eine kleine Bibelauslegung anhören und so ein generelles Verständnis für ein Miteinander. Aber das wäre weniger gefährlich, als das, was da eigentlich laufen, passiert. Und nicht so kostspielig. Da sind die Kirchensteuer doch relativ gering gegenüber dem, was da ausgegeben wird.
Das Gefahrenpotenzial schätzen wir gleich noch mal ein. Auf jeden Fall kommt hier alles zusammen. Wir sind Papst Franziskus, liegt gerade im Sterben.
Wir reden von Benedikt.
Wir sind Papst Benedikt, richtig. Sorry, Franziskus bat ja noch mal um Segelungen und so. Wir haben ihn natürlich alle in unsere Gebete eingeschlossen, ist ja klar. Und Steinmeier und Scholz machen keine guten Predigten. Die ersetzen das nicht. Mehr ist nicht da. Und jetzt auch noch dieses WhatsApp. Wir werden gar nicht mehr angerufen zu Weihnachten und zum Geburtstag, sondern wir kriegen nur noch so Nachrichten, die wir selber lesen müssen. Wir haben irgendwie so den Realitätskontakt verloren. Auch Urbid findet ja nur virtuell statt. Was also machen und anstatt irgendwas Vernünftiges zu machen, holen wir uns die materielle Welt als Klangschale vor uns, versetzen sie in Schwingung und weil wir das Ding, mit dem wir das in Schwingung versetzen, anfassen, überträgt sich dann die Frequenz in unseren Körper. Wir haben ihn informiert. Das ist ja dieses, okay, jetzt, also sie zahlt jetzt viel Geld und dafür wird sie wieder herangeholt an das echte, das haptische, das fühl spürbare und so weiter und es wird eine Wechselbeziehung hergestellt zwischen Klangschale und ihr. Die Beziehung wird in Frequenzen dargestellt und dann geht das alles seinen Gang. Das ist alles ganz nett und ist aber auch wahnsinnig teuer. Plus, das ist natürlich jetzt eins zu eins. Jetzt haben wir ja neue Technik, Podcasts und so weiter. Du kannst ja auch im großen Stile das machen.
Also Esoterik bedeutet für mich, es passiert ganz viel im Außen. Das heißt, jemand legt mir z.B. Karten oder Orakel für mich in einer Kristallkugel. Spiritualität heißt, ich erschaffe etwas aus mir heraus. Ich habe alles in mir und ich bediene mich nur mithilfe von Coachings oder nehme das eben als Hilfsmittel.
Du brauchst nicht mal mehr deinen Guru, sondern die Antwort auf alles steckt schon in dir drin. Du musst es nur noch wachkitzeln über eine Klangschale, über einen Guru, der dir noch mal die Lebensweisheiten bringt, die entweder als Instagram-Kachelmüll oder für 200 Euro die Stunde dir nahe gebracht werden. Aber und das ist also das ist nicht neu, aber es hat gerade wieder Konjunktur. Es steckt schon in dir drin. Du bist dir selbst genug. Du musst es nur entsprechend artikulieren, wissen, was man will.
Wir hatten diesen Trend vor 10, 15 Jahren mit den Wünschen, die man ans Universum richten kann. Das ist ja auch nach wie vor noch da. Aber was wir jetzt hier einfach verquickt sehen, ist, dass das ja schon in einem Atemzug gesagt wird. Coaching und Spiritualität. Das heißt, wir sind hier schon bei so einer Verschließung von eigentlich zwei Komponenten, die erst einmal getrennt werden. Also man hat eine spirituelle Seite und dann hat man zum Beispiel eine berufliche Seite. Man hat ja gerade im Protestantismus eine sehr starke Trennung zwischen dem Irrdischen und dem Reich Gottes. Und das ist dann, was in der Kirche ist, ist nicht da draußen. Und deswegen wurden ja früher sogar bei den Protestanten die Paare vor der Kirchentür getraut, weil das ein weltliches Ding war, die Ehe. Das ist ja bürgerlicher Staat und dergleichen. Das heißt, wir haben jetzt so eine Verschränkung, die da stattfindet. Und sie bedeutet auch, dass es eigentlich darum geht, eine Seele sich zu basteln, die gut funktioniert in einer Welt, die ja neoliberal geprägt ist. Und wir haben es bei den Influencern ja dann auch mit den Vorbildern zu tun, die sagen, seht her, bei mir hat es auch gewirkt. Wir haben ja jetzt tatsächlich viele dieser spirituellen Influencer. Ich glaube, du hattest das auch mal mir geschickt mit den zwei, mit den Zwillingen.
Lisa und Lena, die sich taufen lassen.
Die sich auch haben taufen lassen und haben das dann groß geschildert. Also das wollen wir niemandem in Abrede stellen, das machen wir. Aber es war interessant, wie das dann auch so aufgeladen wurde. Oder es war jetzt in der Rheinzeitung ein einseitiger Bericht über, also nicht ein einseitiger, sondern eine ganze Seite. Ein ganzseitiger. Ein ganzseitiger Bericht über Jana Highholder, die auf publis.com, wo die jetzt in der Schweiz sind, die über Instagram spirituelle Botschaften und die Botschaften Jesu verbreitet. Und ja, auch die Kirche vor allem ersetzt dadurch, dass man das jetzt alles über die Social Media Kanäle löst.
Ja, und das hat sehr viele Vorteile für die Gurus, die Influencer. Weil zum einen, du kannst es übers Internet machen, wenn deine Botschaft ist, die Lösung steckt schon in dir drin, inhaltlich.
Und Jesus weiß es auch.
Und Jesus weiß es auch. Genau, zur Not kannst du sogar in den alten Büchern nachlesen. Aber es ist dieses, die Lösung, also die inhaltliche Lösung steckt in dir drin und methodisch kann ich dir das gleiche anbieten, wie allen anderen. Also, wir können es auch gleich allen gleichzeitig anbieten. Ich kann es also über Bücher, Podcasts und so weiter auf der Bühne vermarkten. Wir brauchen gar nicht das 1 zu 1 Gespräch. Also, da sind ja extreme Skalierungseffekte drin. Die Frage ist dann nur, wer nutzt sie zuerst?
Dieser Highholder hat dann auch schon in ihrem jungen Alter ein halbes Dutzend Bücher geschrieben.
Genau. Du kannst ja immer dasselbe Buch schreiben. Genau. Jedes Jahr wieder. Das muss ja nur so aktuell mein neues Buch und so. Dann kann man sich da ein bisschen selbst plagiieren. Uns wird hier auch eine dieser neuen Koryphäen vorgestellt.
Die Berlinerin Laura Malina Seila ist der Superstar der spirituellen Szene. Ihre Ratgeberbücher sind Bestseller. 14 Millionen Mal wurde ihr Podcast heruntergeladen.
Und das ist jetzt, ohne die jetzt vergleichen zu wollen, inhaltlich. Denn das ist inhaltlich was anderes, aber es ist strukturell. Das, was jetzt die Männer bei Andrew Tate und Co. finden, da finden sie Orientierung. Wie bekomme ich eine gut aussehende Frau? Wie schaffe ich es überhaupt, sie anzusprechen? Und wie muss ich meinen Körper hochskalieren, damit alles gut funktioniert? Das bekommen sie da. Und da gibt es ja dann auch die absurdesten Theorien mit, das wurde ja auch schon vor Jahren besprochen, wie wann sollte man unanieren, um nicht am Ende dem und dem zu schaden? Da gibt es ja auch mit Strömungen und Wellen und was die da alles so durch deklinieren.
Also innerlich kannst du, glaube ich, ins Unendliche treiben.
Ja, genau. Und dann hast du auf der anderen Seite diese Erbauungsinfluencerinnen, die sich dann wahrscheinlich überwiegend an weibliches Publikum richten.
Hier haben wir ein rein weibliches Publikum und auch einen sehr weiblichen Mitarbeiterstab, gar nicht so klein.
Digitale Verbreitung. Das ist das Wesen dieser neuen Spiritualität. Allein Lauras Instagram-Account hat 140.000 Abonnenten.
So, wir müssen zum Spiriton Louis Ring 21 an den Vörtener Eingang.
Inzwischen hat Laura 11 Mitarbeiterinnen. Meist im Hintergrund halten sie ihr den Rücken frei.
So, also Setting ist gemacht. Das Mittelling zwischen Podcasts und Bücher und 1 zu 1 ist natürlich der Auftritt. Ich würde sagen, ganz profan, der Live-Podcast. Aber nicht für 18, 50 Euro wie bei uns mit 200 Leuten, sondern das muss dann schon teurer und größer sein.
99 Euro haben die Besucher für ein Ticket bezahlt und sind aus allen Teilen des Landes angereist. Laura Malina Seila ist inzwischen auch eine Marke. Sie hat interkulturelle Kommunikation an einer amerikanischen Elite-Uni studiert. In den USA hat sie erlebt, wie viel professionelles Marketing ausmachen kann.
Und diese Halle ist so groß, dass sie fast für Helene Fischer geeignet wäre.
Ja, da kann man auf jeden Fall ordentlich Programm machen. Also da werden dann schon die sechsstelligen Tagesumsätze gefahren, die man ja dann wahrscheinlich auch braucht für seine zehn Mitarbeiterinnen.
Und ich garantiere dir, die Leute, die da sind, sind aus der Kirche ausgetreten.
Wahrscheinlich. Irgendwo muss es ja verankert werden.
Aber die sind nicht atheistisch geworden.
Ja, genau. Wir haben ja auch damals schon 2019 noch in der allerersten uns auch gefragt, die Lücke der Kirche, wie wird sie gefüllt hier im Podcast? Also eine Nullnummer. Und hier kriegen wir wieder eine dieser Antworten. Ein bisschen besonders ist schon, dass auch die Mitarbeiterinnen schon mit zum Publikum gehören.
Auch für das Team weit mehr als ein Job.
Also ich bin auch eigentlich fatolisch, war auch Messdienerin und so, ich habe auch immer so ein bisschen gestruggelt, da für mich eigentlich das Praxis nahezufinden, also wie lebe ich das im Alltag? So, ne? Für mich war Gott so im Außen, Gott ist so irgendwie im Außen und diese moderne Spiritualität bringt einem das ja ganz anders nahe, insofern, dass eigentlich, zum Beispiel Laura, so das so vermittelt, so du hast diese Schöpferkraft. Gott ist alles, Gott ist auch in dir, du hast diesen Schöpfer auch in dir.
Ja, das ist idealtypisch, wie du es eben auch beschrieben hast. Da wächst jemand schon mit so einem religiösen Bezug aus, verliert den aber, bleibt aber dabei, unterscheidet dann zwischen Institution und der Kirche selbst, sucht dann neue zum Folgen und dann bleibt sie so in dieser Zwischenwelt. Ja, ich arbeite für die, aber bin auch Publikum von ihr. Also so irgendwie, ne?
Ja, wie das ja bei vielen ist.
Es wird noch lange Orientierung brauchen, bis sie ihren Weg gefunden hat.
Jaja, aber da halte ich doch fest zu Papst Benedikt.
Mach das mal. So, und wir, ich leg noch mal Wert drauf. Es ist dieses, die Antwort steckt schon in mir drin. Ich brauch keine externe Kirche. Ich brauch nur, ich brauch niemanden, der mich bepredigt, sondern jemanden, der mich inspiriert. Ich will nicht aus normativen Zwang sonntags in die Kirche gehen, sondern ich möchte aus freiwilligen Stücken mir einen Podcast anhören, mir noch mal in ein Buch zu einem Abend gehen, wo das da irgendwas der Bühne abgefeiert wird.
Mal so ein Häppchen mitnehmen.
Genau, so wie es sich anbietet, aber nicht als Befehl und Imperativ, sondern als Inspiration.
Normalerweise ist ja an eine institutionelle Religion auch einiges geknüpft. Da sind ja sehr viele Pflichten mit verbunden.
Zum Beispiel.
Und auch Einschränkungen des eigenen Lebens. Das ist dann hier nicht mehr gegeben, sondern es ist mehr, wie man dann sagt, Empowerment.
Ja, aber auch auf so eine interessante Weise, weil während die Frauen in der Kirche ja ganz große Maria 2.0 Anstrengungen machen, um formale Rollen zu spielen, sehen wir hier junge Frauen, die sich ganz auf diese Publikumsrolle zurückziehen wollen. Ja, also ich möchte gern, dass das Ticket wirklich teuer ist, damit ich einen Anspruch habe an mein Guru. Ja, und nicht wir uns irgendwie auf Augenhöhe begegnen und ich vielleicht auch noch was leisten muss, sondern ich habe schon bezahlt. Jetzt möchte ich gerne einen tollen Abend haben und der findet dann auch statt.
Das möchte ich noch eine Sache sagen, weil das ist so entscheidend. Die zahlen Geld, um nur Publikum zu sein und da sind so viele Leute, also da ist es nicht möglich, dass die nochmal mit ihr reden können groß, sondern sie tritt auf, sie ist Guru, tritt wieder ab.
Sie muss auch schnell weg.
Sie muss auch schnell weg, hat ja auch diese elf Mitarbeiter, die sie da durch die Gegend kutschieren. Und das ist ja interessanterweise das Gegenteil von dem, was die Kirchenreformen in den vergangenen Jahrzehnten bezwecken sollten. Wenn wir an das Zweite Vatikanische Konzil von den 60er Jahren denken, dann war es ja die Überlegung, wie kann man eigentlich die Gemeinde mehr als aktiven Tat in die Messe integrieren. Das hat dann mitunter auch ein paar Blüten getrieben, die etwas komisch wurden. Aber es war tatsächlich der Versuch, dass man nicht mehr den Priester hat, der nur weit weg steht oder von der Kanzel herunter und sonst hat man nichts damit zu tun und noch alles auf Latein. Nein, es war tatsächlich der Versuch, dass man sich als Gemeinschaft versteht und dann auch jeder eine Stimme dort haben kann. Und zum Beispiel auch so etwas wie gemeinsames Vorlesen von Fürbitten, solche ganzen Reformen haben ja dazu geführt, dass man eigentlich glaubte, wieder Gemeinschaft stiften zu können, was dann aus verschiedenen Gründen nicht die Kirchenaustritte aufgehalten hat.
Genau, hier trifft sich auch jeder für sich mit ihr. Sie steht halt auf der Bühne und ist weit weg, weil sie viele gleichzeitig trifft, aber hier bildet sich auch nicht wirklich Gemeinschaft. Denn brauchst du ja eh keine anderen Menschen, die Antwort steckt ja in dir selbst drin. Und dieser Dreh ist interessant. Warum braucht man trotzdem noch den Guru auf der Bühne? Oder diese ganze Szenerie oder die ganze Welt, wenn auch die Antwort in mir drinsteckt? Und so, wie das ganze spirituelle Angebot nur noch methodisch ist und nicht mehr inhaltlich, weil Antwort steckt ja schon in dir, ich zeig dir nur Wege und so, kannst du mal das und das machen. Und übrigens hier die Worte schaffen Realität. Aber es müssen deine Worte sein. So klappt das auch auf der Bühne. Der Guru steht auf der Bühne und erklärt nochmal, wie man die Welt, beispielsweise die Veranstaltung, bei der man gerade ist. Es hat ja auch einen gewissen erhebenden Moment. Man ist da, es ist laut, wie man die Welt nur nochmal als Energietankstelle für sein eigenes Ich benutzt.
Du stellst dir jetzt vor, wie du dieses universelle, göttliche Ja, diese Energie aus dem Universum in deinen Körper ziehst mit Yes, Yes, Yes. Eins, zwei, drei.
Yes, Also man ist ein bisschen treibend, aber eigentlich ist es albern. Und der Gegenentwurf, der hier bei Arte...
Das ist ja exakt dieses Motivationsding. Das ist ja Magnolia. Das ist ja alles, was man vor diesen Coachings kennt, die ja dann auch immer solche gemeinsame Aktionen machen, um das dann nochmal bei TikTok viral laufen zu lassen.
Also vor 30 Jahren konnte man das über die Business-Schiene laufen lassen. Dann ging halt die Belegschaft einfach geschlossen irgendwo hin und dann hat irgendwer irgendeine Motivationsrede gehalten. Ja, es hatte damals so richtig Konjunktur, als auch so Westernhagen getourt hat und so, immer in die Westfalenhalle ging und sich nochmal...
Schau dir mal an, wie groß das Business jetzt geworden ist. Es ist noch größer geworden. Nein, nein, das sind ja extrem erfolgreiche Unternehmen. Also was heißt Unternehmen?
Also das sind so komische Sachen.
Die große Hallen werden da gefüllt. Und ich kann auch sagen, ich war jetzt in diesem Jahr ja in vielen Hotels durch die Vorträge. Und es kam immer wieder vor, dass so ganze Männertruppen in diesen Frühstückszellen saßen und dann zu irgendeinem komischen Seminar gingen. Und das war sicherlich nicht irgendein Excel-Seminar, sondern das waren schon, ich sag mal, wenn da 25 Männer zwischen 25 und 35 sitzen und alle tragen diesen einen MS-Gürtel, dann weiß man schon, dass da eine große Orientierungslosigkeit ist. Und da würde ich sagen, wenn ich da an den Tisch gegangen wäre und hätte gefragt, kennt ihr eigentlich ein Trotate, wäre die Antwort ja.
Gegenentwurf, der hier nochmal vorgestellt wird, ist Hypnose, um das innere Ich herauszukitzeln, was uns da, was auch immer, das Kind in dir, das Ich in dir, der Gott in dir, wie auch immer, es sind ja unendliche Angebote. Hier wird mal kurz der Preis genannt.
Ziel der Hypnose, belastende Erinnerungen löschen und mit positiven Emotionen überschreiben.
All die Gefühle, die dürfen jetzt alle hochkommen. Und je intensiver die da sind, umso besser. Wir werden einfach diesen Gegebenheiten Sinne Bedeutung entziehen. Und du fängst jetzt an, deine Augenäpfel hin und her zu bewegen. Von links nach rechts und rechts nach links. Einfach hin und her und her. Manchen gelingt das ganz gut, dir nicht so gut. Deswegen reiß dir deine Augen auf und folgst dem Stift.
Einfach folgen.
Und wenn es weg ist, spontan die Augen schließen. Nicht länger warten. Einfach, wenn es weg ist, die Augen zumachen.
Rund 200 Euro kostet eine Sitzung. Oft reichten ein, zwei Behandlungen, sagt Giese, um mit Hilfe äußerer Reize die gespeicherten Informationen im Unterbewusstsein dauerhaft zu verändern.
Sie war ja vorher auch bei dieser Gurufrau. Das kostet 180 die halbe Stunde. Die Worte schaffen Realität und so. Das Angebot, was sie alle machen, ist, die Wahrheit steckt in dir. Das muss nur irgendwie entfaltet, neu programmiert, wie auch immer gefunden werden. Sinn wird ja, wie wir wissen, gefunden und nicht geschaffen. Das ist ja der große Fehler, wahrscheinlich, da der so drinsteckt. Und jetzt bin ich zum Jahresende, aber auch durch Zufall, weil nämlich sonst keine Podcasts kamen. Also meine Playlist war leer, hab ich ja so mal in der allgemeinen, was gibt es denn so im Angebot, Podcast gehört. Und da bin ich von Sternen publiziert, eine neue Medizin, die Biontech-Story gestoßen. Und was die hier alle wollen, ist ja Bewältigung oder Umgang, produktiver Umgang mit der Realität. Und das können wir ja auf jeden Fall Ugo Shahin unterstellen und seiner Frau, weil die haben mehrere Unternehmen gegründet, Mainz entschuldet, die Welt vor Corona gerettet und sind superreich, machen aber innerlich noch genau das, was sie immer machen wollten. Und leben völlig selbstbestimmt, also in einem Maße selbstbestimmt, wie es auch Andrew Tate, dem Getriebenen, wahrscheinlich.
Der muss aufpassen, dass er in Rumänien nicht geschnappt wird und so.
Genau, solche Sachen. Das ist ja alles gut. So und wir hören uns mal drei Ausschnitte an. Also ich empfehle diesen Podcast sehr, weil zum einen es ist eine wahnsinnig tolle Geschichte. Plus sie ist dann auch noch irgendwie ansprechend erzählt. Es ist nicht so ein überprogrammierter, überladener Podcast, in dem irgendwie nochmal auf sieben Kanälen Musik und so, sondern es ist einfach so ein bisschen Konzentration auch auf die Wortspenden der Macher. Und in einem Aspekt stellt uns Shaheen selbst hier einen Umgang mit, ja die Welt ist super kompliziert und die Lösung steckt aber in dir drin. Ja, das Virus ist auf der anderen Seite der Welt ausgebrochen, aber die Lösung steckt in mir drin. Also macht so ein Angebot, wo ich mir denke, wir können uns ja lustig machen über diese ganzen SIN-Fluencer hier und so, aber so eine Methodik gibt es ja dann doch, mit der man immer wieder weiterkommt und die man auch so ein bisschen auffangen kann, falls man mal so richtig verloren ist. Man muss es halt nur konzentriert machen und klar auch ein bisschen Klugheit und so ist vielleicht nicht schlecht, so ein bisschen IQ, das hat er ja auf jeden Fall mit an Bord, aber es ist vielleicht doch für uns alle so ein bisschen interessant. Also, der Aufhänger ist Shaheen, kennen wir, gegründet, Biontech, erhört von Corona, setzt sich hier in den entwickelten Impfstoff. Und wir fragen uns, wir haben ja auch diesen Text gelesen von dem Wells über Moderna, die ja damals im Januar den Impfstoff designt haben und dann war quasi nur noch Testen angesagt, also war inhaltlich eigentlich fertig. Genau das gleiche hier ja auch bei Biontech. Und ich will mal so eine interessante Doppelung vorschlagen, aber wir hören uns erst den Clip an.
Und Ugo Sahin, Mitgründer und Geschäftsführer von Biontech, der sitzt zu Hause in Mainz an seinem Computer und liest neue Artikel in der Zeitschrift The Lancet.
Das ist dieses Paper, was unschuldig auf meinem Bildschirm erschien.
The Lancet, das sagt mir jetzt gar nichts.
Ja, das ist eine der angesehensten medizinischen Fachzeitschriften weltweit.
Und am Montag war ich dann in Deutschland, hatte natürlich davon gehört, dass es in Wuhan einen Ausbruch gab. Und das ist aber nicht etwas gewesen, was mich beunruhigt hatte, weil solche Ausbrüche, die gibt es jedes Jahr irgendwo. Und bis ich mich am Freitagabend hingesetzt habe und dieses Paper gelesen habe, auf welches im Lancet erschienen war, ich war neugierig, um zu verstehen, was so die Grundeigenschaften dieses Ausbruchs da sind.
Ich habe ja das Paper gelesen, über das er hier spricht, und es ist ziemlich interessant geschrieben. Es beschreibt die Geschichte einer Familie. Die waren bei ihren Angehörigen in Wuhan und stecken sich auch dort an und kehren dann danach mit einer Lungenentzündung zurück in ihre Heimat.
Verstehe. Das heißt, diese Familie war nie auf diesem berühmten Wetmarket in Wuhan. Und damals war das ja der erste bekannte Hotspot von Corona. Für Ugo Sahin ist damit sofort klar, eine Mensch zu Mensch Übertragung ist möglich. Und das sind sehr schlechte Neuigkeiten.
Was mich sehr beunruhigt hat, war ein gar nicht so deutlich herausgestellter Aspekt in dem Paper, nämlich dass ein Familienmitglied angesteckt war, aber keine Symptome hat, kein Fieber, keinerlei Symptome.
Also im Januar 2020, noch Wochen bevor die Weltgesundheitsorganisation überhaupt den Namen Covid-19 genommen hat, um die Krankheit zu beschreiben.
War das erst so spät?
Ja, die haben erst irgendwann. Am 1. Dezember 2019 gab es bei Spiegel online diesen ersten, es gibt eine neue Krankheit oder sowas in China oder so. Dann kam gar nicht im Dezember noch hoch und dann im Januar kam plötzlich die ersten bei diesem Münchner Auto-Dingster-Booms. Das war dann so im März schon. Das ist dann so, ne?
Aber im März waren wir schon im Lockdown, Mitte März.
Genau, dann ging es schnell. Also dann hat es noch zwei Wochen gedauert, dann kamen die Osterfällen.
Also ich weiß, ich war auf der Berlinale im Februar 2020 und da wurde ich so, weil ich täglich die Tagespresse las, ein bisschen unruhig und fing schon so an, mir die Hände mehr zu desinfizieren als sonst, weil man damals ja gar nicht wusste, was soll man machen.
Also hier geht es konkret um den 24. Januar und es war zwei Wochen, bevor der Name COVID-19 vergeben wurde an die Krankheit und bevor das irgendwie nennenswert war. Und Schein hat diese Texte gelesen, die er sich selber zusammengesucht hat, nach Überschrift gescannt und dann kam er irgendwie auf 30 und hat dann 12 davon gelesen. Und ein einzelner Bericht, wo ein einzelner Fall beschrieben wurde, einer asymptomatischen Vertragung, war für ihn der Trigger zu sagen, das ist der Unterschied zu allem anderen. Also fast kompletten Krankheitsgeschichten, der kompletten Menschheit, das wird einen Unterschied machen. Und das ist ja schon besonders, denn wir haben es mit dem Virus zu tun, das kann man nicht sehen. Er selber ist gar kein richtiger Virologe im Sinne von, ich kenne mich jetzt mit Corona-Viren aus, muss ich da auch erst reinlesen. Aber eigentlich können wir es gar nicht sehen. Das Virus ist zu klein. Wir können nicht mal die Krankheit sehen, aber genau das, die Unsichtbarkeit der Realität oder die Unsichtbarkeit eines Phänomens, wird die Realität später so krass verändern, dass wir heute schon mal drüber nachdenken müssen. Das war dann der Moment, wo er sich hingesetzt hat, hat sich den RNA-Strang runtergeladen, wie bei modernern hat er halt einfach gesagt, okay, ich mache jetzt mal neun verschiedene Versionen, wie man das Spike-Protein identifizieren könnte. Und dann überprüfen wir mal, welcher davon der am besten funktionierende Vielversprechendste ist und genau das bauen wir dann in unserer mRNA-Technik in die Impfung ein. Und dieser Prozess dauert dann so zwei Tage. Aber das ist ja am Grunde, was diese ganzen ESO-Leute wollen, dass sie den einen Schmetterlings-Flügelschlag sehen, der ihre ganze Welt verändert und dass sie den nicht verpassen. So wie Uga Sahin in so einem Text einfach liest, ah, da gab es in einer Krankheit, die noch gar keiner kennt und die noch keinen Namen hat und die auch noch nicht beschrieben würde, einen einzelnen Fall, der noch mal von den wenigen sich besonders her vorstellt, weil eine asymptomatische Übertragung.
Nur ist das, was dann Uga Sahin tut, etwas auf etwas Trittes ausgerichtet. Das heißt, er löst sich jetzt von seinem Ich.
Das kommt dann noch dazu.
Ich würde sich jetzt nur fragen, wie schütze ich meine Seele vor dem Virus?
Wie werde ich jetzt Milliardär? Ah, ich brauche eine Impfung.
Oder dann noch vielleicht, wie werde ich Milliardär oder was? Und hier ist jetzt der Forschungsgeist geweckt und dann ist es auf etwas Trittes ausgerichtet. Das wäre mein Lebenshilfetipp. Wann immer man sich in Krisen befindet, ist es gut, sich mit etwas zu beschäftigen, was außerhalb von einem selbst liegt. Das ist gerade nicht dann nochmal in sich tief hineinhorsen und habe ich vielleicht noch ganz andere schlimme Gefühle gerade, sondern es ist die Beschäftigung mit etwas anderem oder die Beschäftigung gemeinsam mit anderen Menschen. Denn das ist ja auch etwas, diese Innenschau, die da eingefordert wird, ist ja zugleich ein großer Akt der Entsolidarisierung. Man zahlt ein teures Ticket, hat seinen Yes-Yes-Moment zwar in einer Masse, aber nie in der Form, dass man dort eine Gemeinde erlebt, sondern es ist vollkommen egal, wer links und rechts neben mir steht. Hauptsache, dass Yes-Yes-Yes wird laut genug gebrüllt, dass irgendwas in mir passiert. Und das ist dann so, dass man danach wieder alleine irgendwo hin zurückgeht und dann wieder alleine mit sich ist und wieder sucht, was finde ich noch? Alles in meiner Seele. Und dieser Akt der Entsolidarisierung ist im höchsten Maße schädlich, aber symptomatisch für unsere Gesellschaft. Und überhaupt nur sinnstiftendes schafft man, wenn man es auf etwas drittes auslegt. Und das hat er ja in mehrfacher Hinsicht. Also auch dadurch, dass er dann mit seiner Partnerin zusammenarbeitet. Also auf diese Art des Lebens ist er auf etwas noch ausgerichtet, nämlich auf ein Projekt gemeinsam.
Also die Story ist so irre. Biontech ist ja dann ein zweites Unternehmen, die haben vorher Ganymede gegründet, aus der Onkologie der Uniklinik Mainz oder so heraus, weil sie da so ein paar Ansätze hatten. Und dann in jeder Finanzierungsrunde wurde das Unternehmen aber immer weiter verwässert. Also irgendwann konnten die gar nicht mehr so mitbestimmen, mussten auch immer alles rückkoppeln mit den Eignern und so weiter. Und das genau wollte er vermeiden, weshalb er auch später so auf Milliardäre trifft, die ihm dann sagen, nachdem er das so eine Stunde vorstellt, wow, sie erfüllen ja unseren Lebenstraum. Dürfen wir einsteigen? Und dann sagt er, nee, ich habe das einmal durchgemacht, kein Bock. Und es dauert dann ewig lange, bis sie dann das hinkriegen, dass sie da finanziell einsteigen dürfen. Und er lässt dann dieses erste Unternehmen erschüttelt so richtig ab, als Last von sich, weil er meint, das ist jetzt hier dem Markt ausgeliefert, wir können ja gar nichts mehr selbst machen und es ist gar nicht unsere Forschungsrichtung. Und was für ihn so eine Niederlage ist, ist aber der größte Biotech-Exit Deutschlands, mit mehr als einer Milliarde Exit. Also es ist völlig verrückt. Und genau, dann können die da bei Biontech und sitzen eben 2020 auch bei Biontech. Und er sieht dann halt abends, was da los ist, an diesem Einzelfall, einer asymptomatischen Übertragung und weiß sofort, was das bedeutet, nämlich dass sich die Krankheit unsichtbar ausbreitet und man einfach nicht weiß, wo sie ist, bis sie dann irgendwann mal aufploppt, weil sie einen Opfer gefunden hat, bei dem es als Krankheit ausbricht. Also ruft er im Januar 2020 in seinem privaten Umfeld die Pandemie aus.
Mein Mann hatte zwar lange nachts noch gelesen, aber das ist jetzt nicht unbedingt etwas, was ich nicht gewohnt wäre. Ja, ich wusste, er arbeitet sich in irgendwas hinein und das scheint spannend zu sein. Und am nächsten Tag war es aber so, dass wir den Tag ganz normal angefangen haben und er dann gesagt hat, dass er die Befürchtung hat, dass wir eigentlich schon in einer Pandemie sind.
Das finde ich auch gut. Es ist nicht so, es kommt eine Pandemie, sondern es ist schon eine Pandemie. Sie ist halt nur noch sehr klein. Aber wir können gar nichts dagegen machen. Es wird eine große.
Könnten jetzt 100 Clips vorspielen, tun es nicht. Haben es aber in vage Erinnerung. Wer alles auftrat, Ende Januar und sagte, naja, eine Pandemie ist das auf keinen Fall.
Das Robert-Koch-Institut im Februar, die Gefahr für die deutsche Bevölkerung ist gering.
Ja, ein bisschen aufpassen.
Spahn kommt auch vor im Podcast. Wie er im Bundestag sagt, wir sind gut vorbereitet. Wenn ihn das noch mal einholt.
Ich bin natürlich erst mal so vor den Kopf gestoßen und denke, ja, was denn jetzt? Und muss ich erst mal damit, weil wir hatten ja, Sie haben die Nachrichten zitiert, wir hatten ja überhaupt gar keinen Hinweis, noch nicht mal Diskussionen irgendwo in Medien, die auffällig gewesen wären. Das heißt, es war erst mal so ein Schlag vor den Kopf, dass man sich jetzt mit etwas beschäftigen soll, womit man gar nicht gerechnet hat.
Wir haben uns unterhalten und Österm konnte das nachvollziehen. Wir haben keinen Grund gefunden, warum es keine Pandemie werden sollte.
Keinen Grund gefunden. Es ist so erstaunlich. Also hier könnte man doch auch fast wieder sagen, ja, die Unternehmer. Also die Unternehmer sind dann vielleicht doch die Visionäre.
So, und jetzt gibt es ja hier, wir haben ja jetzt verschiedene Modelle gehört, man sucht Resonanz zur Welt, in der man lebt, wo ist eigentlich mein Platz, wer bin ich und so weiter. Dann gibt es verschiedene Möglichkeiten, entweder man nimmt einfach an der Welt teil über Begegnungen, Freundschaften, soziale Netze in nicht virtuell, wie du es beschrieben hast, oder man sucht sich irgendeine Aufgabe, die nicht man selber ist, irgendein Hobby oder so. Man erschafft irgendwas, was Künstlerische ist, was Wissenschaftliches, wie auch immer. Und manche Menschen entscheiden sich wirklich dafür, ich bin auf Resonanz-Suche, also zahle ich 180 Euro für so eine Guru, die stellt mir eine Klangschale hin, dann habe ich da so ein Glasding, streiche da drüber, dann gibt das so eine Resonanz, und das ist dann meine Resonanz mit der Welt. Jetzt bin ich am Ziel, jetzt habe ich es hergestellt, ja, und es ist absurd. Und wie ging es besser? Wenn wir jetzt sagen, inhaltlich alles gerechtfertigt, man darf durchaus auf die Suche nach den ganz kleinen Puzzleteilen gehen, die einem die ganze Welt verändern, die eigene oder die ganze, wie bei Shahin, dass man sagt, ich mache euch mal eine Info und das betrifft dann alle, nicht nur mich. Also inhaltlich alles gesetzt, aber methodisch, ist die Klangschale wirklich der richtige Weg? Oder was auch immer? Genau, Shahin beschreibt hier nochmal sein, wie er das so, seinen Ansatz zu denken und überhaupt. Und die Antwort ist natürlich, ja, methodisch muss man sich, aber dann heißt das halt wirklich unterwerfen, man muss sich den Prinzipien der Wissenschaftlichkeit unterwerfen. Keine Spirentzien, weil man glaubt, es irgendwie besser zu können, als diejenigen, die einem die Geschichte dargelegt haben. Also man steht auf den Schultern der Riesen, muss man dann aber auch stehenbleiben. Man muss mit Konsequenz, dem methodisch dann aber auch treu bleiben. Man darf nicht glauben, dass einem eine Klangschale oder irgendwie weiterhilft.
Im Gespräch mit ihnen merkt man sehr schnell, dass er sehr analytisch denkt.
Dementsprechend habe ich ein Denken, welches mathematisch sehr geprägt ist und präzise ist. Und die Wissenschaft ist so ein bisschen wie Mathematik nur viel komplexer.
Das sagt er jetzt nicht nur so. Er hat neben Medizin auch Mathematik studiert.
Dadurch, dass sie komplexer ist, wird vielen nicht klar, dass trotz dieser Komplexität ganz klare Zusammenhänge immer bestehen. Und eines der wesentlichen Aspekte in der Wissenschaft ist, dass man, auch wenn man die Zusammenhänge nicht kennt, akzeptiert, dass Zusammenhänge da sind, die dann identifiziert werden müssen.
Ich denke nochmal gerade darüber nach, wir hatten so viele Clips heute zum Thema Ukraine und haben doch sehr fahrlässige Äußerungen gehört, haben sehr flapsige Bemerkungen von Präsidenten gehört. Man fragt sich dann mit Blick auf die Corona-Pandemie, wo wir diese ganzen Politiker inklusive Spahn hatten, die lange Zeit gesagt haben, oh, ist gar kein Problem, haben wir im Griff und ne, Masken brauchen wir nicht, ah doch, jetzt brauchen wir Masken. Wissen die eigentlich, was sie tun? Das ist ja eine Frage, die man sich stellen darf. Und jetzt hat man hier jemand, der sehr früh sehr viel erkennt und trotzdem in aller Bescheidenheit, der auch sagt, wo sind die Grenzen der Erkenntnis und was bedeutet das, wenn es diese Grenzen gibt, weil es ja trotzdem noch die Sachen gibt, die es gibt, nämlich, dass es Zusammenhänge gibt. Was bedeutet das eigentlich als Übertragen darauf, auf die Weltkriegsgefahr, nämlich, dass man sich eigentlich wünscht, dass Leute, die zu entscheiden haben, sich ihrer eigenen Begrenztheit gewahr werden und die Dimension des Ausmaßes erkennen und nicht erst mal leugnen, weil Politiker das zum Beispiel sehr gerne so machen, und dann nachher darauf hoffen können, dass die Journalisten das ohnehin wieder vergessen haben, was vor vier Wochen gesagt wurde. Das ist in so einem Fall dann noch halbwegs möglich. Wenn es mal eskaliert ist, weltkriegerisch, dann ist es nicht mehr denkbar. Ja, ich bin jetzt nicht dafür, ich sage, die Wissenschaftler müssen die Politik leiten. Ich weiß, dass es zwei unterschiedliche Sphären sind, aber man erlebt auch momentan eine große Fahrlässigkeit und ist dann doch hier, wie ja schon auch bei dem NASA-Forschungsdirektor zu buchen, auch einmal mehr wieder erstaunt, wie ein wissenschaftlicher und auch unternehmerischer Blick, wenn er dann analytisch ist, zu wirklichen Erkenntnissen und auch zu einer gewissen Demut führen können.
Genau, du hast eben auch die Grenzen von Erkenntnissen gesprochen. Und ich glaube, wir hören nochmal sein O-Ton hier, weil das ist für mich wirklich die Botschaft für die nächsten Jahre dieses Jahrzehnts. Wir müssen diesen Kontrast nochmal verstehen zwischen, was diese Influencer für ein Angebot machen. Wenn du nur in dich schaust, kannst du alles erklären. Du musst nur tief in dich schauen. Und wie er hier so ein bisschen davon abweicht, nicht nur weil er sagt, wir nehmen mal den wissenschaftlichen Weg. Also die mathematische Formel muss aufgehen am Ende. Du kannst ja nichts ausdenken. Es wäre schon schön, wenn du es irgendwie formalisieren und operationalisieren kannst. Aber, und das ist ja auch diese Botschaft, du musst aber nicht alles inhaltlich im Detail verstehen, sondern die Zusammenhänge.
und präzise ist. Und die Wissenschaft ist so ein bisschen wie Mathematik nur viel komplexer.
Das sagt er jetzt nicht nur so. Er hat neben Medizin auch Mathematik studiert.
Dadurch, dass sie komplexer ist, wird vielen nicht klar, dass trotz dieser Komplexität ganz klare Zusammenhänge immer bestehen. Und eines der wesentlichen Aspekte in der Wissenschaft ist, dass man, auch wenn man die Zusammenhänge nicht kennt, akzeptiert, dass Zusammenhänge da sind, die dann identifiziert werden müssen.
Es gibt gerade zu Corona so viele Verschwörungstheorien oder andere Theorien, Erklärungsalternativen. Wo kommt das Virus wirklich her? Wo wird es von Menschen erschaffen? Ist es diese Gain-of-function-Forschung gewesen? War es ein Tier auf diesem Markt? Warum hat die Politik da so spät reagiert und so weiter? Wer hat was gewusst? Alles egal. Einzig ausschlaggebend ist, es gibt die Krankheit und sie überträgt sich auch asymptomatisch. Und damit hat sie ein Gefahrenpotenzial, unabhängig von allem anderen. Diese Erkenntnisse spielen alle gar keine Rolle, sondern man braucht nur diesen Zusammenhang kennen. Und dann kann man alles andere weiter, was einem selber dann aus der Lage hilft. Er beschreibt das ja auch, wie sie ihm gar nicht, also er betont am Anfang gar nicht, es gibt da ein Virus und es bricht aus. Es könnte ja auch SARS-CoV-1 sein, also es ist schon weitreichend, aber bleibt im Grunde in China und trocknet dann da aus. Sondern seine Überlegung war, das wird uns auch hier betreffen, wo wir leben. Also noch ist auf der anderen Seite der Welt, aber es kommt auch zu uns. Also es ist damit unser Ding. Und für diese Erkenntnis wusste er nichts anderes wissen, außer den Zusammenhang akzeptieren, dass eine asymptomatische Übertragung bedeutet, es wird sich einfach übertragen. Unsichtbar. Bis es dann bei alten Leuten und den Opfern irgendwann auftaucht. Und ich denke mir jetzt irgendwie, ich wünsche mir eigentlich, dass man diese Wünsche, die in dieser komischen neuen Spiritualität drinstecken, aufgreift. Weil die sind ja auch irgendwie da. Und dass irgendwer, irgendwelche Podcasts oder was auch immer dazu macht, in denen das nochmal auf so eine amüsante Art und Weise beschrieben wird, was die nächsten Jahre so passiert. Weil das Metier ist ja irgendwie da. Also das Milieu ist ja da, dass die Angebote ökonomisch werden gemacht. Und so wie diese Laura dieses ökonomische Angebot macht, ich weiß, was ihr wollt und ich biete es euch einfach. Ich spiele es euch einfach vor. Es ist mir doch egal, ob ihr das wirklich glaubt oder nicht. Hauptsache, das Ding ist ausverkauft. Dass man das mit diesem Anspruch auch nochmal betrachtet. Also dass wir da so eine Reflektionsebene irgendwie rein drin haben, die gar nicht so sehr, die sind, was wir bisher immer haben, da sind irgendwelche Männer und die schreiben verschwörungstheoretische Briefe und so. Also erkläre ich euch jetzt mal, die sind irgendwie einsam und sind da abhängig. Also dass man so, wir erklären euch, wie das funktioniert, sondern dass man einfach, es gibt das und ja, es steckt in jedem von uns so ein bisschen drin, dass man so einen produktiven Umgang damit findet, die Sachen erklärbar, handhabbar und diese Zusammenhänge trotzdem aufziehbar. Also ich bin, was das angeht, immer noch unzufrieden mit unserem Podcastangebot und hier habe ich aber so einen echten Wunsch, dass jemand, so wie du, mit diesem Urbit-Zeug einfach mal um die Ecke kommt und einem das beschreibt. Die Zusammenhänge, die da da sind. Ich will dann keine Erklärung darüber, was eine Verschwörungstheorie ist und so. Das habe ich alle tausendfach gehört. Das ermüdet ohne Ende, aber dass man die Phänomene, die da sind, so wie ein Virus, das echt da ist, auch wenn man es nicht sieht, wie man sich der Empirie mal verschreibt.
Dass das Stadion voll ist und alle yes, yes, yes rufen. Das müsste man Thomas Theorie mal ernst nehmen.
Es gibt keinen Gott, aber die sind trotzdem alle wegen Gott da. Also gibt es doch irgendwie einen Gott, zumindest dort bei denen und so. Dass wir uns das mal ein bisschen mehr verdeutlichen und erklären, was hier passiert. Es gibt einen Podcast, der so ein bisschen, das ist dieser QAnon Podcast in Amerika, der allerdings jetzt sein Thema so ein bisschen verliert, weil die es auch nicht richtig schaffen, da umzuswitchen. Aber so in der Art, dass wir jetzt mal so eine, keine Ahnung, Berichterstattung zum Thema einschwenken, wo sich Leute mal solche Phänomene vorgreifen. Und zwar, weil sie auch selber so ein bisschen angefixt sind davon. Um sich vielleicht auch selber wieder frei zu schwimmen von solchen Versuchungen, die da drin stecken. Kann ja jeder mal überlegen. Aber nächstes Jahr, dass wir auch mal Zuhörer sein können bei sowas.
Wir sind am Ende dieser Folge und am Ende des Jahres angekommen. Und wir haben jetzt keinen Jahresrückblick gebracht. Warum auch? Weil wir ja ohnehin immer schon auf den Monat zurückblicken. Und wir ein gutes Gedächtnis haben im Gegensatz zu vielen anderen. Und deshalb können wir auch uns einfach auf gewisse Dinge beziehen, die vor vier Monaten waren und können das hoffentlich auch noch im nächsten Jahr. Und wir freuen uns sehr, wenn alle wieder mit dabei sind. Noch einmal der Hinweis, der Live-Salon, den wir schon über die Bühne gebracht haben, den kann man im Salon dann hören. Der ist dort verfügbar. Und als nächster Salon kommt dann im Januar das Thema kognitive Apokalypse, eine Pathologie der digitalen Gesellschaft. Über dieses Buch werden wir sprechen. Hast du schon sonst was, was du uns offerieren wirst? Oder ist noch alles in der Schwebe?
Es ist noch alles in der Schwebe, aber gestern schlug ich die Zeitung auf, nachdem ich den Briefkasten geöffnet habe. Und Johanna Schöner schrieb einen Text, einen kleinen, aber er erschien zumindest als, ich weiß nicht, ist das ein Leitartikel? Zeitleitartikel, also ein bisschen kleiner als man es so kennt, jetzt aus der FAZ oder so. Aber Überschrift klein und allein, Deutschland missachtet das Wohl seiner Kinder, das wird bald bittere Konsequenzen haben für alle. Und die Zwischenüberschrift, angeschlagene Jugendliche sollen der Alten Republik zuversicht einhauchen. Vielleicht lesen wir einfach das erste Mal einfach mal einen vollständigen Text. Vielleicht bietet sich das an, der ist wirklich nicht so lang. Und ich bin nur darauf aufmerksam geworden, weil auf Twitter plötzlich so alle ein bisschen aufmerksam wurden. Also die SOS-Kinderdörfer, das Kinderhilfswerk und so fingen plötzlich an, diesen Text zu vertweeten und sich also wirklich zu bedanken bei der Autorin, dass man da noch mal ein Fokus drauf gelegt hat, in der Hinsicht werden wir einsteigen, wie wir ausgestiegen sind, aus diesem Jahr ins nächste Jahr und hier noch mal ein Fokus auf die Jugend legen. Ansonsten weiß ich noch nicht genau, was ich mitbringe.
Ich lege definitiv ein Fokus auf die Musik und zwar werde ich sprechen über das Buch Die Kunst des Komponierens, wie Musik entsteht von Klaus Steffen Mahnkopf. Das ist jetzt allerdings kein Buch, das uns die Kompositionslehre näherbringt. Also ich kann ja auch nur ein bisschen Noten lesen, aber mehr nicht und dafür ist es auch gar nicht gedacht, sondern Mahnkopf, der Komponist und Musiktheoretiker ist, der versucht zu erklären, wie diese Musik eigentlich funktioniert. Was unterscheidet eigentlich dann auch die klassische Musik von der populären Musik? Sicherlich werden wir auch die eine oder andere Wertfrage beantwortet bekommen, oder wir beantworten sie uns selbst. Gibt es bessere und schlechtere Musik? Und wenn ja, woran kann man das erkennen?
Da bin ich gespannt auf diese Antwort.
Ich bin nämlich doch der Ansicht, dass man unterscheiden kann zwischen E und U, aber vielleicht kann man das noch mal auf ein anderes Fundament heben mit Mahnkopf. Das ist etwas, worüber wir sprechen. Die anderen vier Texte will ich mir auch mal offenhalten, denn ich habe mir schon so ein kleines Portemonnaie zusammengestellt, aber bin noch etwas unschlüssig. Sehr gut, dann sehen wir uns im neuen Jahr.
Wir weisen kurz darauf hin, der Salon im Januar kommt leider erst am 10. Januar. Also wir schaffen es nicht in diesem typischen eine Woche später, aber dann am 10. Januar könnte gespannt sein.
Bis dahin gibt es ja noch den alten Salon zu hören, beziehungsweise den Live-Salon. Einen guten Rutsch.
Einen guten Rutsch, bis 2023, haut rein.